The year was 1983, and seven year old Andrea
Bradbury was wandering the streets of Nashville,
Tennessee.
One of her favourite activities was to head
down to the local movie theater and fantasize
about the movies she’d one day be old enough
to see.
This fateful weekend, Andrea’s local theater
was playing a brand new release: Jaws 3D.
What she didn’t know is that this simple,
innocent activity would bring little Andrea
into dangerous contact with SCP - 178 and
change her life forever.
Jaws 3D isn’t exactly a classic - it was
one of the many forgettable sequels pumped
out to cash in on the 3D craze of the early
1980s.
People paid extra for the privilege of sitting
in the dark with an uncomfortable pair of
cardboard glasses while cheesy effects leapt
out of the screen towards them.
Many of the moviegoers simply threw away the
cheap, disposable glasses as soon as they
left the theater, leaving them scattered on
the sidewalk outside.
Seeing a pair of 3D glasses on the ground,
right there for the taking, was the highlight
of little Andrea’s week.
She may not have been old enough to see any
of the movies, but she knew that a local shop
sold books with images that popped off the
page with a simple pair of 3D glasses.
Excited by the prospect of getting to experience
3D, Andrea grabbed a pair of glasses and ran
straight for the bookstore.
Later that night, she was in her bedroom,
with a stereoscopic image of a Ferris wheel..
Andrea adjusted the glasses - and the Ferris
wheel really did pop right off the page.
She marveled at the image coming out of the
book and felt like she could almost touch
it.
But suddenly a strange feeling came over her.
She had the feeling that she wasn’t… alone.
Still wearing the glasses, Andrea looked up
from her book and saw it, standing in the
corner of her room.
Something huge.
Something monstrous.
Andrea’s parents heard her scream and came
rushing into her room.
There was their little girl, dead.
It looked like she’d been mauled to death
by a wild animal, but there was no sign of
her killer.
The windows were shut tight, unable to be
opened from outside.
It was like whatever horrible creature had
done this had vanished into thin air.
The coroner's report didn’t give any other
clues as to who could have done this, except
that whoever, or whatever had murdered her,
it appeared to have three long and incredibly
sharp claws.
The terrible tragedy of Andrea’s death rocked
Nashville, but it never made the national
papers.
Why?
Because the SCP Foundation was immediately
on the case.
Undercover agents in the US Fish and Wildlife
Service flagged the strange death as anomalous,
and SCP field personnel arrived to do their
own investigation of the crime scene.
There they quickly discovered Andrea’s 3D
glasses - which would eventually be classified
as SCP - 178.
An Agent looked over the glasses.
There didn’t seem to be anything out of
the ordinary about them, just your regular
cardboard frames with blue and red tinted
film over the eyes.
Everything about them seemed normal, so he
tried the glasses on himself.
He picked up the open book up off the ground
where Andrea had likely dropped it, and saw
the Ferris wheel pop up off the page.
Nothing abnormal.
Until he turned his head slightly...
He saw the head of some kind of… thing,
only an inch away from his own, looking over
his shoulder at the book.
Being a trained SCP agent, he maintained his
composure, and looked around the room.
As he did he saw that several other creatures
were standing and watching.
None of the rest of the recovery team seemed
to notice the creatures, and when the agent
removed SCP - 178, they vanished.
It appeared that they had found whatever had
caused Andrea Bradbury’s death.
The glasses were immediately taken to the
nearest Foundation containment site for further
testing.
Seeing these mysterious entities through SCP
- 178 may have answered one question, but
it raised many others.
What are these creatures?
Were they real, or merely illusions created
by SCP - 178?
If they are real, are they somehow summoned
by SCP - 178, or simply revealed by them?
There was already one death that could be
tied to the glasses with some certainty, but
just how dangerous were they?
The SCP Foundation was about to find out.
Foundation scientists devised a series of
experiments, with a test chamber separated
from an adjoining observation chamber by a
panel of reinforced bulletproof glass.
A member of D-Class personnel was placed into
the test chamber, along with SCP - 178.
He was instructed to put on the glasses and
report what he saw back to the researchers.
The D-Class followed the orders, however when
he did so, he quickly entered a state of extreme
distress.
He threw away the glasses and covered his
eyes, screaming wildly.
When ordered to compose himself and explain
what he saw under threat of termination, the
D-Class described a “hideous” creature
standing close to his face, watching.
When asked to elaborate, he described it as
having “too many eyes.”
After that, the D-Class refused to put the
glasses back on again, despite direct orders
and threats from Foundation staff.
He was then removed from the test chamber
and observed.
Although he experienced two days of mild paranoia,
after thirty total days of observation the
D-Class was found to have no long lasting
psychological effects.
Disappointed by the meager results of the
first test, the researchers had at least confirmed
that they did indeed have an anomalous object
in their possession, and pressed on with the
experiments.
They used the same methodology again on another
D-Class.
She was placed into the chamber and instructed
to put on SCP - 178, then describe the entity
she saw in great detail.
When she put on the glasses she recoiled in
horror at the monster she saw staring back
at her.
She said that the creature was tall and bipedal,
with two additional upper appendages ending
in large conical protrusions.
She also described the creature’s head as
being “smooth.”
When asked if the creature exhibited any kind
of aggression or hostility, she said that
it was completely still.
It was just standing there.
After a few minutes though, the creature seemed
to lose interest, and began staring at the
wall.
The researchers were happy to learn more about
the creature’s physicality, but they still
weren’t confident that it wasn’t just
an illusion created by the glasses.
They needed to engineer an interaction.
For the next experiment, they decided to alter
the particulars.
A fractal blue and red image, in a similar
style to the stereoscopic Ferris wheel from
the book Andrea had purchased was fixed to
one wall.
Against the opposite wall, they placed a bucket
containing ten standard tennis balls.
This time, the D-Class - a convicted murderer
and arsonist - was told that he was helping
to test a new 3D augmented reality project.
The entities he would see, as far as he knew,
were little more than digital projections.
Though when he actually wore SCP - 178 and
saw them, he commented that whoever designed
them must be crazy.
The researchers instructed the D-Class to
pick up a tennis ball and throw it at one
of the entities.
The second he did so, deep lacerations began
appearing all over his body.
The onslaught was brutal and quick, and the
D-Class was dead soon after that.
This confirmed to the researchers that the
creatures did seem to have some level of tangible
presence, and they could be extremely violent
if provoked.
Next, they wished to see if it was possible
to have any kind of interaction with the creatures
without it immediately descending into violence.
To test this theory, the researchers brought
a nineteen year old D-Class into the testing
chamber under the same pretence of testing
new 3D technology.
Much like the others, she was still horrified
by the appearance of the creatures, but was
calmed down by the researchers.
They asked her to speak to the creatures directly,
without exhibiting any kind of aggression.
She said, “Hello, weird thing, how are you
today?” in a somewhat bored voice.
And this was all it took to sign her death
warrant - she was immediately slashed to death
by invisible creatures.
The results seemed clear: Any interaction
whatsoever with the creatures while wearing
SCP - 178 was a death sentence, like a slightly
more outgoing Shy Guy.
But the researchers would soon find that this
anomaly had even more surprises.
For their next test, they brought in two subjects:
One would wear SCP - 178, and dictate to the
other how they should interact with a creature
they could not see.
The results of this experiment were bloody,
yet informative.
Both subjects were slashed to death when the
unseeing D-Class interacted with one of the
creatures on her companion’s instructions.
It appeared that anyone with sufficient knowledge
of the creatures who attempts to interact
with them is doomed, even if they can’t
directly see one of them.
It was an upsetting realization for the researchers:
SCP - 178 may be much more dangerous than
they initially imagined.
And what they’d learn in the next experiment
was even worse.
They adopted the same methodology as the last
for the following experiment - two subjects,
one seeing and the other interacting.
However, this time, as soon as Subject number
one put on the glasses, they knew that something
was terribly wrong.
He began panicking, stating that the entire
chamber was full of the creatures, all standing
and watching.
The researchers undertook these experiments
knowing that they didn’t often turn out
well for the D-Class, so they didn’t seem
too worried about this new development…
that is until the subject stated that they
could see three more of the creatures, and
they weren’t in the test chamber.
They were in the observation room.
In fact, one of them was looking right over
one of the three researchers’ shoulders.
Immediately, the researchers lost composure
and began to panic.
They were used to putting D-Class in danger,
that was part of the job, but they weren’t
prepared for this!
In just moments, the observation room became
a bloodbath as the three researchers who’d
been designing and performing all the experiments
were torn to pieces by creatures they couldn’t
see
SCP - 178 had gone from being one of the more
innocent looking anomalies to one of the most
mysterious and deadly.
The creatures seemed to be powerful, violent,
and incredibly numerous.
The fact that they can only be observed through
178’s stereoscopic lenses and kill anyone
who even attempts to interact with them makes
them almost impossible to understand.
It was always a tragedy when the Foundation
lost good researchers, but the work must continue,
and the experiments were soon restarted with
increased safety measures.
Of course those didn’t do much good, and
after another disastrous experiment that resulted
in the whole sector getting locked down, all
research into SCP - 178 was placed under increased
scrutiny.
They needed to find some way of observing
the creatures, without the risk of having
to share space with them.
The proposed solution was seeing if the SCP
- 178 glasses were compatible with camera
technology for remote viewing.
Much like all stereoscopic glasses, they found
that looking through only one lens at a time
was ineffective.
The solution was relatively simple: A dual-lens
camera in a roughly similar configuration
to human eyes.
This, however, didn’t give them the comfort,
or the answers they hoped for.
Researchers commented, upon finally seeing
the creatures, that they were even more hideous
than they’d ever imagined.
As they observed a victim interacting with
the creatures via their new camera, they found
that as soon as the creatures were interacted
with in any way, they would grow three long
claws and attack.
And they were as fast as they were ferocious.
From the observations, there were only a few
things that the Foundation now knew about
them for sure: Their physical appearance,
their violent nature, their enhanced physical
abilities, and the fact they appear to be
pretty much everywhere.
And who knows how long they’d been here,
observing us humans while we glided by them,
ignorant to their presence?
It’s enough to make you think twice before
putting on a pair of 3D glasses again.
But of course, never putting on the glasses
doesn’t mean you’re safe.
Just knowing about them puts you in danger.
They could be standing next to you right now,
looking over your shoulder as you watch this
video.
Just remember: If you want to be safe, you
can’t ever let them know you’re aware.
After all, just because you can’t see something,
doesn’t mean it can’t hurt you.
SCP Foundation agents stationed at Area 37
had intercepted chatter from a normally closed
communication system in a nearby city.
To anyone else, the calls that the Foundation
were eavesdropping would seem innocent - even
boring, but the Foundation immediately recognized
the coded language being used.
They were listening to communications between
underground cells of The Serpent’s Hand
- a dangerous paramilitary organization that
stands in opposition to everything the Foundation
is trying to do.
Once deciphered, the Serpent’s Hand messages
revealed plans for killing Foundation personnel,
breaking into containment sites, and releasing
anomalous creatures and objects into the world
- pretty standard stuff for the Foundation’s
least-favorite, anomaly-loving insurgents.
But they kept using one code that even the
Foundation didn’t have any intel on - they
kept asking about the condition of The Sisters.
Fate has a funny way of sneaking up on you
though, and in time, they would know more
about the powerful, sadistic, reality-warping
beings known as The Sisters than they could
have possibly imagined.
But what they would eventually learn was not
the kind of data that anyone would ever want
to have.
After intercepting clear lines of communication
from a local Serpent’s Hand cell, triangulating
the location of their compound was child’s
play, and Mobile Task Forces were dispatched
from Area 37 with orders to neutralize the
potential threat before they could mount an
attack on a facility.
Just when the Serpent’s Hands least expected
it, they had heavily-armed Foundation soldiers
kicking down their doors, crashing through
windows, and rappelling down from the ceiling.
As expected, the Serpent’s Hand put up a
fight, but thanks to their superior training
and the element of surprise, the Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces came out on top.
They were able to capture fifteen surviving
members of the group for interrogation, as
well as a collection of anomalous objects
being stored by the group.
Among them were a small wooden loom, an enamel
needle, and a glass eye.
When the task force obtained these seemingly
mundane items, a haunted-looking Serpent’s
Hand began laughing wildly.
He kept repeating, “You have no idea what
you’re getting yourselves into...”
Nobody knew just how right this man was.
Not yet, anyway.
Congratulating themselves on a job well done,
the Mobile Task Forces hauled their captives
and the new anomalous items back to Area 37
- a heavily isolated Foundation site that
specializes in the early containment of anomalous
objects for initial observation and study.
The objects hadn’t displayed any anomalous
properties in transit - maybe the Serpent’s
Hand was lying and these weren’t dangerous
items at all, or it was actually just a pile
of junk.
Either way, they were sent to a Foundation
researcher on site to conduct preliminary
tests.
The loom, the needle, and the glass eye were
laid out across the table for observation,
when suddenly, the attending researcher felt
a dark presence looming behind him.
He turned, with sweat beading on his brow,
and saw three humanoid, translucent figures
floating in the air behind him.
They would soon become known as SCP - 1765
One, Two, and Three.
The researcher could feel the power emanating
from these silhouettes - reality seemed to
bend and shimmer around them, the way heat
distorts the air into a mirage.
He could tell right away that they were powerful
reality-warpers.
Even in their brief time communicating with
the researcher, One, Two, and Three displayed
both intelligence and unique personalities.
One was clearly the ringleader - displaying
an articulate command of language.
Two displayed a more mischievous side, speaking
with a cockney accent and had a tendency towards
creepy giggling.
Three was the least communicative of them
all - preferring to speak in short, simple
sentences, often consisting of just single
words.
Though of course, actions speak far louder
than words - and it didn’t take long for
the Sisters to define themselves with their
actions.
One told the scared and confused researcher
that they’d been observing the SCP Foundation
for quite some time, and that they deeply
admired the Foundation’s adherence to the
scientific method.
Of course, the researcher wasn’t so much
“flattered” by the Sister’s statement
as they were “afraid for their life.”
They tried to call security for backup, but
found that their tongue was withering and
turning into a shrivelled, blackened husk
in their mouth.
The Sisters didn’t like to be interrupted.
As the tongueless researcher slowly collapsed
in front of them, the Sisters explained the
purpose of their visit - They wished to assist
the Foundation in their quest for knowledge,
and, as such, they would conduct a number
of experiments on their behalf.
They would then happily share the resulting
data with the Foundation to compare notes.
One expressed optimism, saying that she believed
they were about to embark on a beautiful scientific
relationship.
The reality couldn’t be further from the
truth.
The Sisters began their work, moving rapidly
around the facility, bending and twisting
reality wherever they went.
They circled Area 37, marking it as separate
from the rest of the world it inhabited.
Area 37 no longer belonged to planet earth
- it belonged to the Sisters.
It was their private experimentation lab,
filled with live and unwilling guinea pigs.
The Foundation attempted to retake the facility
by force, sending Mobile Task Force Iota-6,
also known as the Canvas Cats, into the belly
of the beast, but they never returned.
In addition to changing the fabric of reality
itself, they also altered the physical structure
of Area 37 to better serve their experimental
designs.
It was divided into four sections, marked
A, B, C, and D, each with its own unique purpose.
Section A - which had formerly been Area 37’s
storekeeping, mess hall, and dormitories - had
been the least affected by the Sisters’
attacks on reality.
The biggest alterations were the appearance
of two large, metal vats situated in the east
corner of the mess hall, a monitoring station
connected to other sections of Area 37 that
replaced the storekeeping zones, and an imposing
marble sign hanging above the dormitories
that reads “CONTROL GROUP.”
A quick refresher from science class, the
control group in an experiment is the group
that isn’t subjected to the experimental
effect the others are, so they can be used
as a benchmark to measure against.
The same was true here - the prisoners in
the control group were the safest of all,
but they were forced to do something almost
as bad, they had to watch the horrors playing
out across the rest of the facility.
One of the Sisters would occasionally return
to this section to oversee the feeding of
the control subjects, and to encourage them
to take part in the observation of their unlucky
peers.
Section B - which had formerly been Area 37’s
outer grounds and sports facilities - had
been transformed into the center of a localized
spatial-temporal abnormality.
In layman’s terms, this meant that its size,
climate, atmospheric composition, pressure,
and temporal flow were all subject to constant
changes based on the whims of Sister Number
One - who oversaw all the experiments performed
in Section B.
For those unfortunate enough to be trapped
in Section B, SCP-1765-1 was their god.
But she didn’t subject them to her whims
randomly.
No, in her own words, the purpose of Section
B was to delve into the effects of repetitive
action performed under unusual conditions
on the human psyche.
For example, one experiment was set up to
test the physical and mental fortitude of
a Researcher, a Field Agent, and a sanitation
worker.
The trio were confined in a sports center
and ordered to measure the length of every
single pipe and the angle at which each connected
to others with nothing more than a wrench,
a ruler, a brown paper pad and a ballpoint
pen.
The task was an arduous one taking over ten
hours.
And as soon as the subjects were done, One
restructured the sports center and ordered
them to perform the task again.
The same happened another 459 times before
One finally concluded the experiment, leaving
the subjects with broken bodies and minds
in the aftermath.
Section C - which had previously been the
facility’s main office block - exhibited
a similar level of anomalous activity to Section
B, except that it was the domain of the more
sadistic and mischievous Sister Number Two.
Her main area of scientific interest was studying
group dynamics and interpersonal relationships
during extreme conditions - very extreme conditions.
For one experiment, the office block had been
transformed into a kind of football stadium,
with the goal posts removed and replaced by
concrete bunkers.
The two teams were the captured Serpent Hand
members, and the members of MTF Iota-6, fresh
off their attempt to retake the site.
The two groups were forced into a deadly game
with incomprehensible rules - including rising
platforms and hooded figures throwing fiery
projectiles into the crowd, trying to incinerate
the players.
But victory didn’t lead to safety, as the
winners of the game were crushed to death
with giant metal hammers, just for the fun
of it.
Two didn’t even try to pretend that this
act had a valid scientific justification.
Section D - which had once been the facility’s
high-risk containment area - was now the strangest
and most mysterious section of all.
Under the charge of the equally peculiar and
enigmatic Sister Number Three, this area appeared
physically unchanged from its state prior
to the arrival of the Sisters.
Temporally, however, Section D was the most
warped of them all.
It existed in a kind of temporal bubble, outside
of the rest of our reality’s timeline, giving
Three a frightening amount of control over
all that went on in her domain outside of
time.
There she was performing the most strange
and incomprehensible experiment of all.
The subject was the former Site Director of
Area 37.
He was brought to a table, and asked to choose
between two different flavors of ice cream
that were presented to him.
Sounds simple enough, so then why is this
the worst of them all?
Because the Site Director is caught in a time
loop.
He’s been choosing between various flavors
of ice cream for over ten thousand hours,
and he doesn’t even seem to know.
Three’s only comment on the matter?
“Delicious.”
All attempts to liberate the unfortunate inhabitants
of Area 37 have failed miserably.
The Sisters don’t appear to operate on any
form of logic or empathy, and thus, cannot
be reasoned with.
With talks having failed and Mobile Task Force
Iota-6’s attempt to retake the site ending
in disaster, the only solution left was to
create a guarded perimeter around the area,
using technology like the Scranton Reality
Anchor to fight back against any potential
escape by the Sisters.
The Sisters are potentially so dangerous that
if they ever truly set their minds to leaving,
it’s considered acceptable to detonate the
facility’s on-site nuclear warhead in hopes
of finally putting a stop to them.
In the meantime, the Foundation has built
giant external servers for processing the
vast quantities of research data the Sisters
are constantly sending from their horrifying
experiments.
Sadly for the inhabitants of Area 37, their
grim fate continues to this day.
The experiments never stop, and the subjects
of said experiments seem to be condemned to
the eternal torment of SCP - 1765.
In a way, their unwilling sacrifice protects
us all - because if ever the Sisters were
interested in performing experiments on a
larger sample size…
Well, all we can do is hope we end up in the
control group.
One of the primary aims of the SCP foundation
is to contain the anomalies that they discover.
Secure, Contain, Protect is their mission
statement, after all.
However, there are some forces so unknowable
and malevolent that there is no way to truly
contain them.
SCP-4205 is one such force.
Very little is known about SCP-4205, even
compared to other SCPs, many of which are
mysterious by their very nature.
We do not know what it is, we do not know
what it wants, and we do not have any meaningful
way to stop it.
The best that can be done to protect yourself
from it is to implement the few known preventative
measures available, and pray that it doesn’t
set its sights on you.
The little information that exists on SCP-4205
was recorded by Wade Dalitz, a former junior
researcher at the Foundation.
He wrote the initial report on SCP-4205 on
a computer, Terminal 4, which was linked to
his brain and consciousness as he wrote.
Though his work was highly valuable, and provided
many previously unknown insights about the
nature of the SCP, sadly his knowledge could
not save him.
The official entry on SCP-4205 was his final
act before his death on December 11, 1992.
Before we get deeper into that entry, and
Wade’s final day on earth, it’s important
to understand what SCP-4205 is.
Or, at least, understand the little we know
about what it is.
4205 is a Keter class SCP, meaning that it’s
incredibly difficult or complicated to contain.
It also shows extreme hostility toward all
life.
It is described as an amber-colored pair of
human-like eyes, with the ability to appear
spontaneously in windows, mirrors, or any
other glass or glass-like surface.
One of the reasons so little is known about
these eyes, is that anyone who sees them dies
within seconds.
The effect is nearly instantaneous.
Much like the mythical basilisk, the gaze
of SCP-4205 is deadly and inescapable.
The eyes only seem to appear to people who
are alone in a room, and never in places where
there’s more than one person.
But aside from that, there is no way to predict
where the eyes will appear.
Since it is unknown if the eyes are part of
a corporeal body, or even present on this
plane of reality, there is no way to contain
them or stop them from killing.
This brings us back to that fateful day, December
11, 1992.
The day that the SCP Foundation would finally
be given some tangible information on the
mysterious amber eyes, at the cost of one
of their researcher’s lives.
Wade Dalitz, a young man fresh out of his
university studies, was brought onboard as
a Junior Researcher by Dr. Mark Forsyth, a
Senior Researcher.
Dr. Forsyth recruited Wade after giving a
guest lecture at his university and being
impressed by Wade’s keen observational skills,
thirst for knowledge of the unexplained, and
determination to understand that which seemed
to defy explanation.
After Wade graduated, he was recruited by
Dr. Forsyth, and given the position of Junior
Researcher at the SCP Foundation.
where he assisted Dr. Forsyth, now a site
supervisor, in his research.
After several months of working under Dr.
Forsyth with minimal responsibilities, Wade
was finally given the opportunity to write
his first SCP report... on SCP-4205.
Following some initial documented appearances
of 4205, Dr. Forsyth approved further research
into the anomaly, with Wade appointed as the
lead researcher on the subject.
According to Wade’s entry, he was responsible
for the discovery of SCP-4205 when he spotted
the anomaly in a window.
Though later reviews of security footage determined
that he was not the first person to observe
the eyes, he did claim to be the first to
observe them and live to tell the tale.
In his writing on the subject, Wade is puzzled
by the fact that he survived his encounter
with SCP-4205, and wonders what could have
set him apart from the others that fell victim
to its gaze.
He found himself frustrated as he documented
SCP-4205, his rough drafts of reports dissolving
into angry rants about his own incompetence.
Wade had difficulty adjusting to his new responsibilities,
especially with the added element of his assigned
subject’s mysterious and volatile nature.
In between his reports on SCP-4205, its previous
appearances, and its effects on its victims,
he wrote letters to his father, desperate
for reassurance that he was not messing everything
up.
Letters that would sadly go unsent.
In his coverage of SCP-4205, Wade made note
of a troubling recurring element in each victim’s
death.
When medical professionals attempted to revive
the victims, it was always noted that their
brain activity stopped much more quickly than
in cases of death by natural causes.
When examined, all aspects of the body aside
from the brain were completely unharmed.
The brain, however, showed massive nerve damage
in the amygdala, hippocampus, medial temporal
lobe, and occipital lobe.
The appearance of this brain trauma has been
compared to the effects of electrical shock
or a severe head injury.
In addition to Wade, six other people on record
encountered SCP-4205.
Every encounter ended the same way, with sudden
brain death and severe nerve damage immediately
after viewing the eyes in a reflective surface.
The first encounter occurred on January 5,
1990, when Deputy Liaison Gena viewed the
eyes in a reflective glass one-way window.
Security tape reveals that the eyes appeared
in the window eight minutes before the Deputy
Liaison spotted them.
As soon as he did, he fell from his chair
and immediately died.
Though the specifics varied from case to case,
the end result of every encounter was the
same, with none surviving long enough to relate
what they experienced.
Every encounter except Wade’s.
As he continued his documentation of SCP-4205,
Wade’s mental state quickly began to deteriorate.
The process of his mind coming apart, and
his thoughts giving way to confusion, fear,
and anger at his own survival, is documented
in his reports on the SCP.
He agonized over the question of why he was
able to survive gazing into the eyes of SCP-4205
when so many others had not?
The question consumed him until he was unable
to eat, sleep, or do anything but obsess over
the SCP he was tasked with researching.
As he became more agitated, he began to write
about the eyes appearing to him again.
On one occurrence, he attempted to touch them,
and described the sensation like touching
a balloon to your arm after it has been charged
with static electricity.
He continued to report seeing the eyes.
The worst was when trying to sleep, during
which he was overtaken by violent sleep paralysis
and plagued with visions of the amber eyes.
The only comfort Wade seemed to find was in
memories of his loved ones.
He wrote about his mother and his father,
even as their memories grew foggier to him.
He also mentioned a man by the name of Theodore
Quale, who he claimed was a researcher at
the Foundation.
Later fact checking determined that this was
not the case, and that Quale must have been
someone from Wade’s past.
He wrote about Quale wistfully, mournfully,
with words of love and loss, tormented by
the sense that he was losing his grip on reality
and everything he once held dear.
As Wade descended deeper into a hell inside
his own mind, he continued to mull over the
questions of SCP-4205.
Was there more to it than what was visible?
Did it have a body?
Why had he survived his encounter with it?
And what did it want from him?
He decided that those who had perished immediately
were the lucky ones.
They had escaped the torture that had overtaken
his life.
The eyes were everywhere now, watching him
even as he attempted to unlock their secrets
on a Foundation computer.
He spoke to the eyes at one point, but refused
to write down what they had said to him.
His last entry, his last thought, was a plea
for Theodore Quale’s embrace.
There is no more written about the research,
or about the eyes, only a simple, desperate
need for a comfort that is long lost.
Now is the part of our story where terror
meets tragedy.
Contrary to what Wade thought, and what was
recorded in his final computer entries, he
did not survive his brief brush with SCP-4205.
The truth is that he spotted the amber eyes
in the glass above his terminal monitor while
recording the entry, and died seconds later.
Though his death was swift, it felt agonizingly
slow, as revealed by his descent into panic
and paranoia recorded in his writings.
The entries recorded as a result of the connection
Wade and the computer, his physical contact
with it at the moment of exposure to SCP-4205’s
anomalous effects allowing the terminal to
archive his final thoughts before he succumbed
to the deadly nature of the eyes.
The entries were never physically typed, but
rather jumped from his dying mind into the
mainframe.
His entries, the echoes of a dying mind, offer
a glimpse into the way that SCP-4205 kills
its victims.
In the seconds leading up to death, the amber
eyes fast-forward a person’s mind, feeding
on the electrical impulses that it gives off
as it speeds through what seem to be days
of fear and of a loosening grip on reality.
The death may be swift, but the suffering
is long.
Wade left the foundation with a digital fingerprint,
an echo of the person he was at his core in
addition to his experiences with SCP-4205
itself.
Wade spent his final moments terrified for
his life, dreaming of a father that he missed
and a long-lost love from his college days.
His sacrifice must not be forgotten.
Because no one ever survives an encounter
with SCP-4205, his documented final moments
are the only first-hand account in existence.
Junior Researcher Wade Dalitz gave us a gift
in death.
He allowed the SCP Foundation a glimpse into
the true horror of the amber eyes, and a reminder
of what they are capable of stealing from
us.
So be careful of windows, mirrors, screens,
and all reflective surfaces.
When you look into them, you never know what
you might see looking back.
It goes without saying that the SCP Foundation
archives are filled with some terrifying monsters.
Even the deadliest creatures can, in theory,
be defeated, or at least soundly avoided.
After all, they’re just flesh and blood
- or in some cases, metal or concrete.
But what if reality as you know it one day
just…broke.
Or worse, you were transported to a reality
so frightening and alien to our own that death
seemed like the only escape – but you couldn’t
even give yourself that.
This brings us to today’s topic – the
terrifying alternate reality of SCP – 3001.
The Foundation is no stranger to freaky alternate
dimensions, but what was experienced by joint-lead
researcher Dr. Robert Scranton at Site 120
is a truly unique nightmare.
Co-managed by his wife, Dr. Anna Lang, Site
120 is a facility largely designed for research
into SCPs with dangerous reality-warping capabilities
in order to mitigate future containment breaches.
Reality warpers are among some of the more
perplexing and dangerous SCPs, from the pocket
dimension-creating SCP – 106 to the SCP-creating
Doctor Wondertainment, and everything in between.
Scranton and Lang’s goal to further study
such entities was an admirable one, if a little
over-ambitious, and on January 2nd, 2000,
during the testing of a new technology created
by the Foundation’s leading power couple,
disaster finally struck.
Scranton and Lang had already been the brains
behind one of the Foundation’s most valuable
tools in the fight against reality-bending
SCPs: The Scranton Reality Anchors.
Their follow up, the Lang-Scranton Stabilizer
– or LSS – likely would have been an even
more advanced variant of their earlier invention
and should have been a huge success for the
team.
But things didn’t turn out that way…
Dr. Scranton and several other researchers
were gathered in Reality Lab A performing
routine tests on the LSS prototypes.
While other technicians ran diagnostics tests,
Scranton stood at the control panel, the blinking
red light above the console confirming that
everything was going according to plan.
But as anyone who’s fallen victim to one
of the Foundation’s many anomalies will
tell you, just because you’ve done everything
correctly doesn’t mean you’re safe.
Scranton began operating the machine, not
knowing that something was rumbling up towards
him from below.
Without warning, a sudden, unexpected burst
of seismic activity rocked the entire base.
Researchers grabbed onto whatever was closest
as the world shook around them.
In his panic, Dr. Scranton clung to the LSS
control panel as the seismic blast fried the
circuits and kicked it into overdrive.
There was a blast of magnificent, blinding
light, and when the rumbling stopped not only
was the doctor gone, he had been erased from
reality as we know it.
The earthquake had caused a deadly malfunction
in the machine meant to stabilize reality,
and instead tore a rift in it, dragging the
unfortunate doctor and the control panel into
oblivion.
His wife, Dr. Lang, and the many researchers
who idolized him were devastated by his unexpected
demise at the hand of what should have been
his crowning achievement.
The one silver lining was that this reality-ripping
event had almost definitely eliminated the
doctor quickly and painlessly.
As far as The Foundation and his loved ones
were concerned, Scranton’s death had been
immediate and complete – a luxury afforded
to few Foundation employees who die anomalous
deaths.
But sadly that isn’t how Dr. Scranton’s
story – or the story of SCP – 3001 – ends.
No, this is where it all begins.
How do we know all this?
In the hellish new place where Scranton had
been transported, the control panel from the
LSS that he’d been clinging to for dear
life had been transported with him, and continued
to record audio data from this anomalous location.
Not that Dr. Scranton realized it, not at
first, anyway.
As far as he knew, he’d suddenly been transported
into a pitch-black location.
No sights, no sounds, no scents.
True nothingness.
At first, the doctor was confused.
One second, he was testing out his new technology,
and the next he was quite literally nowhere.
In spite of his current situation, the doctor
was still an intelligent and rational man.
He took a moment to compose himself, hoping
that in time his eyes would adjust to the
new darkness around him.
But that moment never came: The darkness remained
perfectly absolute.
Much like the darkness in another reality-defying
SCP, the deadly endless staircase known as
SCP – 087, the dark seemed thick, almost
like you could touch it.
The doctor, not wanting to give himself to
despair and die in this impossible place,
and with no other options seemingly available,
began walking.
Either he’d find his way out, or the Foundation
would find him.
No need to panic.
It may have altered the doctor’s temperament
if he knew that the Foundation already assumed
he was dead, and that no search party was
going to come looking for him.
Still, logic dictates that if a person walks
for long enough, they’re bound to find something.
The problem Scranton was about to face was
that SCP – 3001 doesn’t run by any kind
of conventional logic.
He walked and walked and walked, but he didn’t
seem to get any nearer to or farther from
anything but how could even know?
After all, in total darkness, there aren’t
any landmarks to assist in navigation.
The doctor walked and paced and screamed for
days on end, but he made no progress.
He was alone in an empty world.
He had no choice though, so he kept walking,
and walking, and walking.
For eleven days.
During that time, he felt his hunger and thirst
grow.
He was in terrible pain from a mix of starvation
and dehydration, but the release of death
didn’t seem to come for him.
He was going to have to learn the rules of
this new place the hard way, and it grimly
dawned on Dr. Scranton that dying in this
place might not even be the worst possible
outcome.
He paced and repeated facts to himself, hoping
to ground himself in the moment and avoid
the panic that could so easily set in.
“Name, Robert Scranton.
Age, 39.
Birthday, September 19, 1961.
Favorite color, blue.
Favorite song, "Living on a Prayer."
Wife…
Anna…”
Little by little, the words seemed to turn
to nonsense in his mouth as the terror grew.
Just as he felt like he was about to lose
his mind, he noticed something - a small oasis
in the endless darkness of SCP – 3001: The
glowing red light of the LSS control panel.
Where had it come from?
And how was it still recording?
The doctor had no idea, but he was grateful
for any kind of familiarity in the strange
darkness around him.
Perhaps the LSS could be the key to saving
him, or at least figuring out what on earth
was going on here?
Whatever the case, there was no denying that
having the panel here was better than nothing.
At least, when it was found… if it was ever
found, then people would know what had happened
to him.
As the days passed and he continued to mysteriously
survive, Dr Scranton deduced that one didn’t
need food or water to survive continually
in SCP – 3001.
The location had an anomalous effect on its
inhabitants.
As the days passed and turned to weeks of
wandering in the darkness, Dr. Scranton further
deduced that he was no longer in his home
dimension – this was an entirely separate
pocket dimension, much like the one possessed
by SCP – 106, but featureless.
A perfect, self-contained void.
Now dimly illuminated by the red light of
the panel, Dr. Scranton explored further into
the void around him.
He travelled for months on end, the pain of
his deficiencies growing by the day, but found
he was getting nowhere.
All things considered, he wasn’t even sure
he was moving, or whether reality and the
darkness was swirling around him like a thick
liquid.
Rather than walking on a single flat surface,
he was moving in all directions across a three-dimensional
plane.
The space-time continuum appeared to be entirely
broken here, where movement is more defined
by the conscious intention to move than any
real geographical repositioning.
Dr. Scranton knew that this place broke every
single one of Kejel's Laws of Reality Parameters,
and from his years working with a plethora
of reality warpers in Site 120, he had a theory
for why this pocket dimension was so strange:
It had an extraordinarily weak Hume field.
Before we get back to Dr. Scranton’s semi-living
nightmare, we need a quick primer on Hume
theory, and why having a weak Hume field is
such a problem.
A Hume is a unit of measurement for the strength
and amount of reality in a given location
or being.
In an area with an incredibly low Hume field
relative to our world, such as SCP – 3001,
universe breaches and anomalous incidences
rise significantly.
At the time of his being trapped there, SCP
– 3001 had the lowest number of Humes in
any recorded environment, making it a phenomenally
anomalous zone.
It was for this reason that starvation and
dehydration never took hold of him despite
causing him great pain, and the worst by far
was yet to come.
Dr. Scranton wasn’t trapped in this dimension
for weeks or even months.
He was trapped in the darkness for years.
And it took a nightmarish toll on his body
and mind.
The small flashing red light on his LSS control
panel became his only friend and as the years
drew on, he would hold entire conversations
with his only source of illumination.
He knew that his days were numbered – if
he didn’t escape dimension within around
three years, the Hume field would diffuse
further, and he would be left in a truly horrific
state.
But based on how little headway he’d made
in the time he’d been there, he didn’t
feel optimistic.
He kept speaking into the recorder, if only
to break the silence and prevent him from
going completely insane.
But even that would only hold it off for so
long.
Alone and talking to himself endlessly in
the darkness, Dr. Scranton could feel his
mind slipping as the confines of the pocket
dimension constricted and his body began to
change.
The low Hume field slowly diffused his physical
matter, destroying the physical integrity
of his body but never being merciful enough
to actually let him die.
In his haunting audio logs, the doctor described
his hands as diffusing and thinning out like
spider webs.
Over time, there was less and less of him,
and what was left wasn’t entirely human.
As Scranton’s Hume level lowered to equalize
with that of SCP – 3001, the lines between
his body and the LSS control console began
to blur in a twisted marriage of warped flesh
and machine.
The Lang-Scranton Stabilizer was anything
but stable.
Before his mind and body became something
else entirely, the doctor still had the presence
of mind to finally realize how he’d come
to be in this terrible place.
The LSS had opened a wormhole known as a Class-C
“Broken Entry” into a paradoxical pocket
dimension between layers of reality, and taken
him through it.
He’d slipped through a crack in reality
into absolute darkness, and now he was stuck
with a fate far worse than death.
How do we know any of this?
Much like the event in the first place, it’s
a total accident.
Testing superior reality-bending technology
almost six years after the disappearance caused
the sudden return of the missing LSS to Site
120’s Reality Labs.
The only trace of Dr. Scranton that it brought
back with it was the blood and viscera that
coated the console, much to the abject horror
of his still grieving wife, Dr. Anna Lang.
To this day, Dr. Scranton, formerly one of
the Foundation’s brightest minds, remains
trapped in the nightmare of SCP – 3001.
His current condition whether the doctor is
still alive after twenty years of being warped
by the low Hume field of 3001’s darkened
confines is still unknown.
But, for the doctor’s own sake, we hope
he’s been dead for quite some time, because
few things on earth are as horrifying as the
alternative…
It’s 3:00 AM, and the facility is quiet.
Office workers and administrators roam the
halls.
Security Officers stand at their posts, clad
in advanced tactical armour and carrying standard-issue
M4 Carbines.
Three Foundation employees sit at flickering
monitors, watching a live feed of footage
from the containment cell of the infamous
SCP-106, or as it’s referred to by staff,
The Old Man.
No Foundation personnel are permitted to travel
within sixty feet of the cell for security
reasons, and nobody is permitted to physically
interact with the anomaly without the approval
of two-thirds of O5-Command.
The observer’s eyes itch and sting from
the hours of unending blue-light exposure,
but they can’t look away.
The Old Man is crafty – he may have the
insatiable bloodlust of a hungry great white
shark, but he’s not mindless.
He’s a calculating predator, more sadistic
than the worst human serial killer, and he’s
always searching for the next opportunity.
According to Foundation records, he’s been
active since at least World War II, and it
is estimated that he has hundreds if not thousands
of victims to his name.
And many of those made the simple, but extremely
foolish mistake of underestimating him.
After all, it only takes a few seconds of
inattentiveness, the briefest moment of distraction,
to give him the window he needs.
To do what, you ask?
Oh, don’t worry, you’ll find out – just
like they did.
The Old Man has his nickname for a reason
– most of the time, he really does look
like exactly that - an old man.
Or more specifically, an Old Man’s decaying
corpse, his body covered in rotten, dark greyish-black
flesh that looks like putrid meat.
Though the creature has been observed being
able to change shape, the rot seems to run
too deep for the Old Man to ever hide it.
Foundation employees that have observed SCP-106
for extended periods of time have reported
seeing it assume the form of grinning, decayed
children, and women whose rotted flesh barely
hangs on to their creaking bones.
Just seeing the images through a video feed
is enough to cause a lifetime of insomnia
and other sleeping issues.
Still, they have a job to do, and the cameras
remain fixed on the Old Man.
He’s been completely motionless for three
months, just sitting there, like a Buddhist
monk in deep meditation.
A novice might see this period of inactivity
as a cause for celebration, but those with
experience know that this is merely the calm
before the storm.
SCP–106 can remain in a dormant state for
months at a time.
Described by Foundation scientists as a “lulling
state,” it is believed that The Old Man
is simply waiting for its captors to get soft,
make a mistake, or simply have a momentary
lapse in concentration, which is all it needs
to make its move.
It had happened so many times before, and
it was about to happen again.
One of the observers must have felt an overwhelming
wave of anxiety when he saw the creature ever
so slightly twitch.
Just a tiny quiver in the shoulder muscles.
But that was enough to tell the observer that
their day had just taken a terrifying turn.
He grabbed the emergency phone fixed to his
desk and practically screamed into the receiver
that 106 is moving, that they needed a tactical
team stat.
But it was already too late.
He and the two other observers stared into
the monitors with their mouths agape, as a
gooey, rust-like substance began to pool around
the creature on the floor of its cell.
Slowly, the creature craned its withered neck
around.
Its face was fixed into a broad, yellow-toothed,
lipless grin.
Its eyes had the kind of dull, flat malice
of an underwater predator.
It looked directly into the camera.
Directly at them.
And smiled.
The observers know this was bad.
Really, really bad.
With what they could have sworn was a little
nod, the Old Man began sinking into the rusty
puddle it’d made on the ground beneath it,
until it had disappeared entirely.
SCP–106 is capable of phasing through any
solid surface with ease, making it one of
the hardest entities to reliably contain,
and earning it a spot on the dreaded “Keter”
class – reserved for the anomalies that
are a complete nightmare to keep locked up.
Through years of costly research and deadly
trial and error, the Foundation would later
devise ways of at least slowing the creature
down.
It’s shown to have an aversion to lead,
highly complex or random physical structures,
and intense bright light.
None of these cause harm to the creature – as
far as we know, literally nothing can – but
they’ll at least buy you some precious extra
seconds with which to at least try and escape,
seconds the three observers didn’t have.
One of them grabbed the emergency line again
and barked into it that they had lost visual
on the anomaly.
Just then the observers heard a faint crackling
sound behind them, and the hissing of a chemical
burn.
They turned in horror to see a huge, rusty
burnmark expanding across the wall, right
next to the door – which was their only
escape route.
They backed as far away from the door as they
could as a rotten hand began reaching out
of the mass of corrosive, black sludge, followed
by the grinning face of SCP–106, ready to
have some fun.
Meanwhile, two heavily-armed Security Officers
– Agents Goodwin and Resnick – came charging
down the corridor towards the observation
rooms.
It’d become a bleak slogan during SCP–106
escape attempts that all you need to do is
“follow the screams.”
And that motto was proven true that night,
because awful things were happening to the
observation personnel, they were certainly
screaming about it.
Of course, even with top-of-the-line firearms,
there was little they could do to harm the
rampaging Old Man.
He seemed immune to all forms of physical
damage.
All they could hope to do was keep the thing
distracted until the scientists and containment
specialists finished the preparations to lure
him back into his containment cell.
Goodwin surged forward while Resnick covered
his six.
Vigilance was key, as – unlike a standard
human combatant – SCP–106 could attack
from literally any angle including above or
below.
Physical obstacles were irrelevant to him
and no cover was safe.
The hardened security officers could see the
burnmark on the wall of the observation room
as they approached.
SCP–106 was perpetually coated in a thick,
black mucus with powerful corrosive properties
that left any surfaces it touched permanently
marred.
Foundation Scientists speculated that this
mucus served as a kind of pre-digestive substance
that tenderizes meat and bone alike, but to
what purpose this serves is a mystery as the
Old Man has never been observed eating.
It’s postulated that the only purpose is
causing additional pain.
Goodwin and Resnick knew to treat this hissing
sludge as a potential threat, as the corrosive
properties would remain active for as much
as six hours before finally fizzling out.
The two officers shared a quiet nod, before
Goodwin breached the observation room door
with a hard kick.
The two of them surged inside, guns at the
ready.
In their time working at the Foundation, they’d
seen some truly horrific sights.
From the mutilation of D-Class Personnel – typically
death row prison inmates brought in for use
as SCP guinea pigs – to the violence and
mayhem of a containment breach.
But there was nothing in their past that would
ever make the horrifying sight they saw in
the observation room that night feel “normal.”
All three observers were dead.
Almost nothing remained of two of them, and
the third, while still intact, no longer looked
human.
He looked like he’d somehow been dead a
hundred years in the brief period that the
Old Man had been free.
His skin was grey and completely dried out,
and his mouth was locked into a perpetual
scream.
It was a massacre, but there was no sign of
the Old Man.
Goodwin grabbed his radio, and whispered “This
is Goodwin in observation room six.
Requesting immediate back up.
We have no idea where this thing—”
But his sentence was cut off by a sudden scream
from Agent Resnick.
SCP Foundation security officers are as tough
as nails – the best of the best, you might
say, recruited from the top military organizations
in the world – so hearing one of them scream
in fright is a rare if not impossible occurrence.
But even they were forced to yell out in fear
when they looked up to see the Old Man standing
on the ceiling, grinning down at them.
Resnick raised his M4 and shot a three-round
burst at center mass.
SCP–106 didn’t care.
Even under sustained gunfire from the two
security officers, it didn’t even flinch.
The Old Man simply reached down and snatched
Agent Resnick from the ground, like it was
picking an apple from a tree.
The Old Man held Resnick in one hand and pounded
its other rotten fist into the Agent’s body,
breaking all of his bones.
Resnick screamed for his partner to help him
but there was no time.
Before Goodwin could do anything, SCP–106
began receding back into another slimy burnmark
on the wall.
Only this time, he was taking his screaming
victim with him.
Agent Resnick gave one more horrified scream
before he was pulled backwards into the inky
darkness leaving the room silent except for
the burning hiss of the corrosive goo left
behind.
You might think this would be the end of it,
but no.
For poor Agent Resnick, the worst was yet
to come.
He was being dragged into what SCP Foundation
scientists refer to as the Old Man’s “Pocket
Dimension”, a miniature layer of reality
within our own where the malicious SCP is
essentially a cruel, all-powerful God.
According to witness reports extracted from
victims who were taken to this little nightmare
realm, the dimension resembles a series of
twisting, endless corridors where the Old
Man stalks and tortures his captured victims
to the breaking point, manipulating space
and time to its own sadistic ends.
On rare occasions, the SCP will even release
its victims, just for the joy of hunting,
capturing, and torturing them all over again.
While Agent Resnick was learning the true
meaning of terror, containment specialists
were mobilizing in its cell, preparing the
one known tried-and-true method of luring
the Old Man back: Tempting it with the prospect
of causing even more suffering.
In order to do this, Foundation personnel
take one of the aforementioned Class D personnel
and begin inducing extreme pain by breaking
a major bone or slicing a tendon every twenty
minutes.
The victim’s agonized screams are then played
over the facility’s intercom, acting as
bait for the pain-loving Old Man.
The screams echo through the facility’s
otherwise silent halls, as the mutilated corpse
of Agent Resnick falls from a new scorch mark
on the ceiling.
The Old Man can hear the sounds of suffering
ringing out through the air around him, and
he can barely contain his excitement over
the prospect of a new plaything.
The snapped femurs, the torn Achilles tendons,
it was all too good to miss.
Having had its twisted fun with the security
officers and observers, SCP-106 wandered back
to its containment cell, where a new screaming
victim awaited.
The other security officers, containment specialists,
and scientists evacuated the area, leaving
the Old Man alone with his prey.
While the unfortunate Class D was left to
his fate, the rest of the staff commenced
clean up procedures, which mainly involved
wiping the brown and black mucus from the
walls.
It would probably be at least another month
before anything like this happened again,
and new personnel would be transferred over
to the facility to replace the fallen.
All in all, just another night at The SCP
Foundation.
The year is 1941, and the world is gripped
by the most violent and widespread war in
history.
Millions march to war as bloody battles are
fought across the globe, horrendous atrocities
are carried out on groups of people, and parts
of London are bombed to rubble on a weekly
basis.
Considering it’s only been twenty years
since the last world war, it must seem to
the residents of the early 20th century that
the world is coming apart at the seams.
And amongst all this chaos, it’d be easy
not to notice a secluded manor house in the
English countryside disappearing without a
trace for eleven days, before suddenly returning
to our reality.
But thankfully, one organization makes it
its sole duty to notice the unnoticeable and
understand the impossible - The SCP Foundation.
And within that anomalous manor house, Foundation
agents and researchers were about to find
horrors beyond even their darkest imaginations.
This is the grim tale of SCP - 1461, better
known as…
The House of the Worm.
When the manor house reappeared after its
eleven day absence, the Foundation zeroed
in, sending agents inside to investigate.
It was a two-level dwelling complete with
twelve bedrooms, four baths, three studies,
a main foyer slash ballroom, a library, a
kitchen, and a pantry-basement.
The Foundation observed that a number of these
rooms had been fitted with rows of bunk beds,
similar to a boarding house or barracks.
Only later would they understand why.
They found that the upper portion of the home
exhibited no abnormal qualities whatsoever,
but as the agents investigated further, they
found an entrance to the truly anomalous portion
of the manor - The extensive sub-level system.
No previous records of the building kept by
the local council indicated that there would
be anything below the manor’s basement - so
either the mysterious previous occupants,
who were nowhere to be found, had built this
sub-level, or it’d just appeared here on
its own.
Regardless of which was the case, agents and
researchers knew that whatever had happened
down here had everything to do with the manor’s
mysterious disappearance.
They descended into the depths of what seemed
like a man-made cave system, constructed primarily
from a mix of concrete, iron, and brass.
It was a behemoth of 20th century technology
- intricate, snaking systems of pipes, gears,
and pumping pistons.
It was like someone had built an entire factory
down here - but for what?
The agents began to spread out through the
labyrinthine bowels of the manor, hoping to
find some answers, but all they seemed to
discover was more questions.
This place hadn’t been built with any form
of comprehensible logic.
It was full of dead ends, stairways that ascended
and descended to nowhere, doors that would
open to reveal just walls behind them or not
open at all.
It was like a maze built by a maniac.
It didn’t help that it looked like the place
was recently hit by an earthquake with some
passages caved in and mangled machinery strewn
about.
It seemed that no human workers had interfered
with the impossibly complex and bizarre machinery
in quite some time.
A number of the materials used to construct
said machinery, as well as the gray sandstone
filling in the collapsed passageways, remain
unidentified to this day.
Already, the sub-level was proving to be a
complex puzzle box with only an estimated
75% of its layout ultimately being mapped
by Foundation researchers.
However, they would soon realize that this
place wasn’t just confusing - it was deadly.
The only method of self-maintenance detected
by the exploring agents were pipes that would
fire a thick, black lubricant onto the surrounding
machinery.
One of the Foundation agents had the misfortune
of getting covered in it while exploring a
darkened passageway, and eighty percent of
his body was melted as a result.
It appeared that the viscous, black goo was
incredibly corrosive to all organic matter.
A number of the machines also emitted dangerously
high quantities of gamma and X-ray radiation,
making it difficult to explore many of the
caverns without heavy hazmat protection.
And worst of all, were the extremely hostile
creatures living in the caves who would regularly
attack Foundation personnel.
These abominations came to be known as SCP
- 1461 - 1, vicious, steampunk Frankenstein
monsters - once human, but with large parts
of their bodies replaced by crude, mechanical
implants - including metal teeth and claws.
1461-1’s have displayed a taste for human
flesh, and they have dragged multiple Foundation
agents down into their lair to be “converted”
into monsters like them.
It’s believed that SCP-1461 is capable of
controlling these beasts through the strategic
use of sound from its brass speaking pipes,
leading them into areas where Foundation personnel
are present to instigate conflict.
Many of these pitiful creatures have had their
throats replaced by phonographs, endlessly
repeating the same nonsense phrases over and
over again:
“I am what you have made me.
I am choice and I am tyranny.
Forgive me.
I am then and I am now.
What gods they will be, then.
I am evil and I am flesh.
I am the trap.
I am the trapped.
I am beauty and I am chaos.
Children are selfish.
I am the worm.
I have broken God.”
Still, in spite of mazes, monsters, and deadly
chemicals, the agents persisted, and managed
to discover several important locations.
The Gel Production chamber on Sub-Level 3
creates glass jars from the unidentified sandstone,
and fills them with a slime that looks to
contain living eyes and teeth.
The Factory Deliveries room is filled with
a huge number of crates and boxes, which seem
to shift and change in number between Foundation
patrols.
The Speaking Tube Room on Sub-Level Eleven
contains a grand pulpit that acts as the connecting
point for the complex array of speaking tubes
running through the entire cave system.
The body parts of a deceased female also appear
to be wired into the machinery, like spare
parts.
And on Sub-Level Twelve, they found the so-called
Catalyst Room.
Here, they discovered a huge, complicated,
clockwork and steam-powered machine that appeared
to be broken and missing some parts.
Most horrifying of all though, is the raised
platform in the center of the Catalyst Room
on top of which is a metal hospital bed.
A desiccated male corpse rests upon this bed,
its chest punctured by large syringes connected
by tubes to some kind of pumping machine.
The parts connecting this pumping machine
to the overall apparatus of the room were
missing though, leaving its purpose a mystery.
The Foundation assumed that fluids used to
be drawn out of this corpse to somehow power
the machine.
You may be starting to worry that there don’t
seem to be any answers here, that this house
is one big mystery - but lucky for you, you’re
wrong.
An old journal was also discovered in the
Catalyst Room, and if what is written inside
is to be believed, then we may finally have
some truth about who created the House of
the Worm, why it was created, and what horrible
events triggered its mysterious disappearance
and reappearance.
His true name has been redacted by the Foundation
and special efforts have been made to maintain
secrecy around the House, seeing as it’s
an anomaly of great interest to a cult known
as the Church of the Broken God, so we’ll
just call the one who made this place “The
Inventor.”
Before any of this, the Inventor was one of
the many Englishmen traumatized and almost
killed in the horrific trench battles of World
War One.
After a near death experience, the Inventor,
like many geniuses and madmen, was plagued
by surreal and nightmarish visions.
He saw a huge creature that he referred to
as “The Worm” - a gigantic, metal monstrosity
with dragon-like jaws full of gnashing gears
that rampaged through Europe, destroying and
devouring everything in its path.
These apocalyptic visions also presented him
with a solution, vague blueprints for a machine
that might be the salvation of him and any
others willing to take his new gospel to heart.
An escape from a world that the Inventor knew
in his heart was about to end.
He hired work-starved labourers from across
the country to help him make his visions a
reality and began a massive, secret construction
project beneath his isolated country manor
house.
For The Inventor, it was all a labour of love.
He wanted to protect his wife, son, and daughter
from the terrible jaws of the Worm.
But as the project stretched on, his wife
began to suspect that he’d lost his mind.
Many of his workers, however, felt just the
opposite.
They became infatuated by the Inventor’s
sermons on the nature of the Worm and the
coming apocalypse they hoped to escape.
Soon enough, they had become a bonafide cult,
constructing the elaborate sublevels underneath
the house in preparation for the fast approaching
day of reckoning.
Then came World War Two.
The Inventor saw Hitler, hungry for war, as
one of the avatars of the Worm.
Finally, knowing the time was right, he activated
the machine, and successfully trapped the
Worm in the bowels of his mechanized home.
However, as the Blitz raged and London’s
bombing began, the Inventor felt as though
he hadn’t stopped anything.
He realized once and for all that he was never
meant to stop the apocalypse, only escape
it.
And by throwing the final switch and setting
the machine he and his followers had built
into overdrive, he did just that.
This was the moment the House of the Worm
disappeared, transporting the Inventor, his
family, and his devoted staff to a different
world.
An empty grey world, devoid of war, but also
lacking all the comforts of regular life,
including food.
Things went downhill from there, as their
supplies quickly began to run out, and the
cult descended into cannibalism in order to
survive.
Things weren’t going much better in the
Inventor’s personal life.
His wife, fearing what would happen to the
family, took her own life and the life of
his daughter.
Though by this point, the Inventor’s mind
was so fractured that it’s possible he may
have killed them himself.
Either way, it was only the Inventor and his
son left, and more trouble was brewing.
Eudora, one of the staff trapped in the building
with the Inventor and his cult, started a
mutiny.
She claimed the Worm spoke to her from below,
and that their only path to salvation was
pleasing the Worm.
How would they please it?
A sacrifice, of course.
They would give it the son of the man who
had trapped it.
The mutineers took the Inventor’s only remaining
child, and descended into the lowest sub levels.
The Inventor followed, hoping to track them
down, save his son, and salvage something
from this nightmare.
As he ventured deeper, battling the members
of Eudora’s new cult, he found that they
were changing themselves, becoming the half-human
cyborg creatures that the Foundation would
later discover.
The Inventor would find Eudora herself in
the Speaking Tube Room.
Her body, still living, was wired into the
machinery, and she had sacrificed his son
to the Worm.
In a rage, the Inventor murdered Eudora, or
whatever was left of her, then heard a familiar
voice speaking out of a nearby speaking tube.
It said:
“I am what you have made me.
I am then and I am now.
I am choice and I am tyranny.
I am evil and I am flesh.
I am beauty and I am chaos.
I am the worm."
The voice was his own.
In that terrible moment, the Inventor realised
that the Worm wasn’t a giant, all-devouring
monster, it was him.
In trying to protect his loved ones from a
perceived apocalypse, he’d brought them
all to their horrible demise.
He’d trapped them with the monster he’d
hoped for them all to escape from, because
no matter what you build, you can’t escape
who you are.
Grief stricken and broken, the Inventor descended
into the Catalyst Room.
There was his son, stuck with the syringes,
drained of all life to fuel the mighty machine
his father created.
In his last moments, the Inventor decided
to do the only noble thing: He threw himself
into the machine, destroying both it and himself
in the process.
The house was transported back to our reality,
but the Worm, in a sense, was no more.
But who knows if the Worm is really dead.
Its thoughts and poisonous intent still lingers
in the caverns, and rattles through the speaking
pipes.
Whatever really happened, the Foundation is
still picking up the pieces today - and who
knows what lurks in the parts still hidden
from our knowledge.
It all started in 1983 with reports of human
trafficking in the heart of Sin City.
The FBI had gotten word of a potential trafficking
ring operating out of an abandoned department
store in Las Vegas, Nevada, and immediately
began organizing a secret raid on the building.
While they would indeed encounter something
horrifying within that abandoned department
store, it wasn’t criminals or human trafficking.
In fact, it wasn’t human at all.
This is the horrifying story of SCP - 847.
After weeks of planning, the raid on the department
store was conducted in the dead of night.
Agents covered all the exits and entrances
and a helicopter was stationed nearby in case
anyone attempted to run.
It should have been a perfect trap.
But things never go as planned when you don’t
know what you’re dealing with.
The agents breached the door, and began searching
the darkened building.
It didn’t appear that there was any power,
so the traffickers must have had great night
vision and a high tolerance for creepy locales.
Agents soon heard a faint humming sound coming
from below - a generator.
It must be located in the basement and be
the hub of this criminal enterprise.
Readying themselves for whatever they were
about to find, the agents descended into the
basement.
As they moved deeper into the building, they
found that lighting rigs had been set up - they
must be getting closer to something, but that
“something” was still a mystery.
A senior FBI Special Agent was leading the
charge, his pistol drawn and ready.
It was quiet.
Too quiet.
Did the traffickers already realize they were
coming and clear out?
He was ready to consider this bust a bust
when he heard a quiet mewling in the distance.
A persistent, whining whimper that was undeniably
human.
He gave the signal to his fellow agents to
follow the noise.
They proceeded forward towards the pained
sounds and found themselves in a wide, well-lit
room filled with department store mannequins.
All were broken to some degree - some were
totally smashed to pieces, some were chained
to walls and locked in cages, others were
wrapped in plastic.
The agent wondered whether this was some kind
of twisted joke, or a messed up avant garde
art piece.
That’s when he noticed Her: A single, crouched
figure in the distance, hunched over and whimpering
in a darkened corner of the room near a full-length
mirror.
He couldn’t fully make her out, but he got
the sense that something was wrong - she was
injured, bent over.
Was she even missing an arm?
Just what had these monsters done to this
woman?
He whispered a request for back up into his
radio, and pushed on.
When they got within 50 meters of the strange
woman, her demeanor changed entirely.
She jerked around - her movements forced,
erratic, and painful-looking.
The woman stared directly into the agent’s
eyes and began hobbling towards him., occasionally
stopping to strike a pose as if modelling
during a photo shoot.
Just then the agent made a horrifying realization
- this thing moving towards them wasn’t
a woman at all, it was a living mannequin.
As she got closer though, he also realized
that the mannequin’s broken left forearm
had been carved into a large shiv.
A female junior FBI agent had been one of
the many to pour into the room when the raid
leader had radioed for backup.
The second she entered the fifty meter range
of this strange mannequin, everything changed.
In an instant, its eyes and mouth began dripping
with a thick, viscous resin.
Its whimpering gasps suddenly became vicious,
earsplitting screeches, and it turned its
gaze from the senior FBI agent.
It was now focused on the junior agent who
had just entered the room and broke into a
terrifying run straight towards her.
The mannequin moved with a violent, single-minded
purpose.
Other agents began firing but it was running
freakishly fast and easily dodged most of
the bullets.
The few that actually hit seemed to do nothing
to slow the creature down.
It shrugged off the damage and kept running.
With a great leap, it landed on the terrified
junior agent, and began jabbing at her with
its bladed arm.
The other agents stopped firing, fearing they
might accidentally hit their colleague during
the panic.
The mannequin was ruthless, clawing and stabbing,
with the strange resin leaking out of its
every orifice.
Terrified and unable to reach her gun, the
agent remembered her training - she reached
into her belt and grabbed her stun gun, jamming
the two probes up against the creature’s
chest and giving it 30,000 volts.
The creature spasmed, fell backwards, and
collapsed in a heap on the ground - frozen.
This was the first recorded encounter with
SCP - 847 - a violent living mannequin with
a serious problem with women.
This terrifying report was passed up the chain
of command until it landed on the desk of
a Foundation Agent working in the FBI.
The Foundation quickly swooped in and claimed
the mannequin, delivered necessary amnestic
treatment to all who’d witnessed it, and
closely observed the female junior FBI agent’s
recovery in a private hospital with Foundation
ties.
As it turns out, they were right to do so,
as the junior agent was in for a gruesome
fate.
While the wounds she’d suffered at the hands
of SCP - 847 didn’t appear fatal, the fact
that the mannequin’s anomalous resin excretions
entered the open wound changed everything.
Several hours after being committed, the junior
agent began complaining of limb stiffness
and difficulty moving.
This quickly developed into full paralysis.
Over time, her skin and internal organs began
to harden, until the process - dubbed plastination
- came to a gruesome end.
The junior agent wasn’t just dead, she had
been transformed into a mannequin.
Foundation researchers were met with a truly
horrifying realization - This meant that all
the other broken mannequins found with SCP
- 847 were likely once living humans, attacked
and transformed by the anomaly, now a source
for new harvested body parts.
Now safely interred at a Foundation containment
facility though, the real tests on SCP - 847
to determine its behavior and physical attributes
could begin.
The most important detail about SCP - 847
is that its aggression is exclusively directed
towards women, as opposed to when it encounters
men and its instincts are more self-destructive.
Through a series of tests and observations,
researchers have been able to pin down three
different distinct patterns of behavior for
SCP - 847.
Pattern Z behaviors occur when there are no
humans standing within fifty meters of SCP
- 847.
The mannequin will seek out a full length
mirror, and pose in front of it, much like
a department store mannequin attempting to
show off its clothes.
It remains largely inanimate during these
periods, and will very occasionally use a
finger - or whatever appendage is available,
given its habit for self-mutilation - to scratch
messages on nearby surfaces.
Pattern Y behaviors occur when male humans
with XY chromosomes enter a fifty meter radius
around SCP - 847.
Just like its reaction to the male FBI agents
who found it, 847 will initially emit vocalizations
that seem like whimpering gasps, before making
eye contact and striking provocative poses
while approaching the subject.
It will then remain static, and allow the
male subject to pose its body.
However, after the male subject leaves the
area, 847 will enter a state of considerable
distress, and begin removing or shattering
parts of its body.
The Foundation has found that the parts removed
or shattered are often consistent with parts
that the male subjects found displeasing during
interactions, showing a masochistic desire
to impress.
These parts are then harvested back from plastinated
victims.
Which brings us to the most dangerous of its
behavior patterns.
Pattern X behaviors occur when female humans
enter a 50 meter radius around the creature.
847 will immediately become brutally aggressive,
switching its noises from whimpers to violent
screeches and growls.
847 also experiences enhanced physical capabilities
during Pattern X states - its speed has been
measured at 45 kilometers per hour, making
it as fast as the legendary SCP - 096.
It’s also been shown to exhibit extreme
physical strength.
It’s during this pattern of behavior that
it begins excreting its deadly resin, which
has been proven to only be dangerous to women.
In these states, the only thing capable of
reliably pacifying the being is a powerful
electric shock.
The shock causes the creature’s resin to
harden, temporarily incapacitating it for
roughly five minutes.
Other conventional weapons and damage has
no meaningful effect on SCP - 847.
After a number of incidents that had sad and
violent endings, the Foundation Ethics Committee
forbade the use of female D-Class personnel
in SCP - 847 testing.
When it came to female subjects, 847 always
slipped into a state of extreme aggression,
so instead the Foundation began testing with
male subjects in hopes of better understanding
the dynamics between human males and SCP-847.
Various misogynistic D-Class males were introduced
into the containment chamber, which was modelled
to look like a bedroom for the purposes of
behavioral study.
Each one, either during or after their interaction
with SCP - 847, was told to comment on some
aspect they felt dissatisfied with.
The mannequin shattered its own chest after
hearing it described as being out of proportion.
After another D-Class called its nose ugly,
the mannequin broke it off.
After another said that its hair was out of
fashion and commented on its inability to
drink, it tore out its hair and liver.
All parts were replaced after the experiments.
Things took their most violent and upsetting
turn yet with the introduction of D-7294.
A lot of the time, D-Class personnel are considered
to be as anonymous as they are expendable.
But D-7294 is an exception.
Before becoming D-Class, he was a successful
cello teacher who brutally murdered one of
his teenage students and her mother.
He’s typically employed in tests when the
Foundation wishes to see interactions between
anomalies and humans with confirmed psychopathic
personalities.
During his interaction with SCP - 847, he
belittled and humiliated the mannequin.
He forced it into uncomfortable poses, and
even snapped off one of its fingers before
being dragged from the room by Foundation
guards.
In the following debrief, he further berated
the mannequin as “useless” and “lousy”
at its job of being controlled by him.
In response, 847 extracted its own brains,
eyes, and clavicle before shattering its own
hands in dismay.
So why does SCP - 847 behave this way?
While it may appear monstrous, it seems that
the reason SCP - 847 does what it does is
all too human: It hurts women because it itself
is hurting, and it’s willing to hurt itself
even more for the approval of the objects
of its desire.
As a result, it’s an anomaly trapped in
an endless cycle of pain and violence.
Perhaps one day it’ll be able to free itself
from the loop, but that day is unlikely to
come for this murderous mannequin anytime
soon.
It’s the holiday season.
Outside, it’s cold and there's snow blanketing
the ground.
But inside, you’re warm, and gathered around
the light of a roaring fireplace and a glowing
Christmas tree.
This is what Christmas is all about – warmth,
joy, and togetherness.
But just because you’re comfortable doesn’t
mean you’re safe.
You were so busy opening presents and stuffing
yourself at dinner that you didn’t notice
the face pressed up against the window.
That long, gaunt face, with the staring eyes,
the wide mouth full of yellow teeth, and the
scraggly, white beard.
You don’t know it yet, but within a few
days, you’ll be dead.
You might be able to avert this horrible fate,
if only you knew what exactly you were dealing
with: SCP – 4666, also known as The Yule
Man.
A Keter-Class Christmas monster so violent,
sadistic, and terrifying, he makes Krampus
look like jolly Saint Nick.
And this year, just like every other, he’s
planning on being very, very naughty.
The SCP Foundation began cataloguing the Yule
Man in 1974 after a string of violent and
eerily similar home invasions during the holiday
season, but they have reason to believe that
this entity has been around for a whole lot
longer.
Over 2000 years in fact.
Stories that describe what look to be Yule
Man massacres date as far back as the First
Century BC in Scandinavia, and there have
been reports of similar clusters of events
happening around the same time every year
since.
This monster is prolific, and may have one
of the highest body counts of any creature
under observation by the Foundation.
The Yule Man’s trail of destruction became
clearer in the eighteenth century, as accounts
of the carnage it leaves became more detailed.
Later still, authorities even managed to find
physical evidence like the Yule Man’s fingerprints
– which are similar to human fingerprints,
but display a distinct double-whorl pattern
not seen in human fingerprints.
Much about the anomalous nature of the Yule
Man is still unknown though, and the Foundation
has yet to discover an effective way to contain
it.
Their only hope is intercepting it before
it can get its long, gnarled fingers on its
intended prey.
Maybe you’re feeling worried, or that you’re
being watched.
You have a good reason to be afraid, because
during his yearly active period – the twelve
days between December 21st and January 2nd
– he’s always searching for prey.
Nowhere is safe, because while it was initially
believed that he only appeared to those who
lived north of 40 degrees latitude, it’s
now believed that much like Santa Claus, the
Yule Man operates worldwide.
Anyone could be in his sights right now, blissfully
unaware of the nightmare coming down the tracks
towards them.
Thankfully, the SCP Foundation, through analysis
of these attacks which are known as Weissnacht
Events, they’ve been able to find certain
patterns.
But first, what does the creature known as
The Yule Man even look like?
Much like SCP – 096, the Yule Man is a long
and lanky humanoid standing about two meters
tall, who resembles an emaciated human of
European descent, and never wears any clothes
or other coverings despite the frigid temperatures
he operates in.
You might be sad if you’re spending Christmas
alone, but it at least guarantees you safety
from the Yule Man, as he only appears at the
homes of families with a child under the age
of eight present.
He also seems to favor isolated and rural
locations, and Weissnacht Events only occur
when there’s a healthy covering of snow
on the ground during the event – hence the
name which means “White Night” in English.
It’s also vital that you recognize the three
distinct stages of a Weissnacht Event, too,
or you won’t be seeing much of the New Year.
The first stage occurs during the space of
a week.
Children in the home might start to seem worried
or afraid.
They might tell you that they see something
strange in the distance.
The figure of a man they don’t recognize,
standing just far enough away that you can’t
fully make him out, except that he’s really
tall.
Of course, you probably won’t see anything,
and your instinct will be to tell them there’s
nothing to be afraid of.
Even when they tell you, through tears, that
there’s a man pressing his face up against
their bedroom window at night.
But they are right to be afraid, and you should
be, too.
Already at this point, your only hope is to
try and spread the word as soon as possible:
Report the incident to the local police, write
about it on Facebook, tweet about it.
Whatever it takes.
The SCP Foundation has operatives trawling
the internet and monitoring police reports
constantly during this period, especially
for reports of mysterious men in the snow
watching homes from a distance.
Getting the Foundation’s attention is your
best hope of stopping this thing.
And if you don’t?
Next comes stage two, taking place between
nights eight and eleven of the active period.
No longer will the Yule Man just be lurking
on the periphery.
Now he’s getting closer.
You’ll start to hear strange noises in your
attic or on the roof, noises that sound almost
like footsteps.
That’s crazy, you think, it’s probably
just an animal.
But then, the smell starts.
An awful, rotten stench that fills the house,
but no matter how hard you look, you can’t
find the source.
Finally, on the last night of December, you
tell yourself that you’ll take this matter
to the police.
But of course, it’s already too late.
The Yule Man is here for the twelfth night.
The Weissnacht is finally upon you.
At this point, one of two scenarios will happen.
In the first, you and your entire family will
be tortured and murdered, except the youngest
child, who the Yule Man will kidnap.
The SCP Foundation keeps files on a number
of notable instances of this kind of Weissnacht,
and the details are truly gruesome.
Reports of incidents have involved crucifixion,
the removal of tongues, burning, dismemberment,
post mortem bitemarks, and decapitation.
In all instances though, the entire family
was killed except the youngest child, who
simply disappeared.
The Yule Man is a merciless and sadistic beast.
You’re now probably wondering: If that’s
the first of two Weissnacht possibilities,
what’s the second?
In the second, if you’re tremendously lucky,
you and your family will survive – but that
doesn’t mean you won’t face a grisly experience.
In this scenario, which occurs during about
fifteen percent of Weissnacht Events, you’ll
hear footsteps throughout the night, but thankfully,
you wake up alive.
And when you do so, there are gifts waiting
for you.
The problem is, all these gifts are made out
of human body parts.
For example, in 1976 in Canada, one family
received the gift of a ball made from a severed
human head wrapped in skin.
In Kazakhstan in 1903, a family received a
flute made from a hollowed out human femur.
And in the Netherlands in 2003, a family received
a wooden hairbrush, covered in human teeth
ranging from 400 years old to a mere few days.
These gruesome gifts are referred to as SCP
– 4666 – A, and it was one of these gifts
that gave us the best insight yet available
into the true nature of the Yule Man.
Several gifts were dropped off at a family's
residence in Hoonah, Alaska, in 2018, but
most notable among them was the horrific SCP-4666-A-0960
– a life-sized doll made from a human body,
with its eyes removed and mouth sewn shut.
Worst of all though, was that the girl was
still alive.
The family who received this twisted gift
was given amnestics by the Foundation, and
the living doll was taken for medical treatment.
Before succumbing to her extensive injuries,
the girl was able to deliver some insights
into what exactly happened to the children
who were abducted during Weissnacht Events.
The children taken by the Yule Man are forced
into a large sack that seems much bigger on
the inside than it appears as he makes his
rounds, travelling from house to house, murdering
and kidnapping.
His victims are taken to a kind of underground
grotto and workshop filled with bones, like
a twisted Santa’s workshop, where they’re
forced to make toys out of the bodies of their
fellow victims.
During this time, the Yule Man will continue
to torture and torment his victims.
He’ll even take some of them away to cook
and eat whenever he feels like it.
When asked how she was turned into this human
doll, the girl told Foundation personnel that
her fellow victims were forced to turn her
into this by the Yule Man when she became
too weak to continue making toys herself.
Her chilling last words were, “When you
can’t make the toys, you become the toys.”
So if strange things happen to you and your
family between the 21st of December and the
1st of January, don’t ignore it.
After all, you never know who’s watching.
But if it is the Yule Man’s grinning face
pressed up against your window, it may already
be too late.
Happy Holidays…
In a remote part of Russia, a mysterious disease
outbreak was tearing through a tiny farming
village with terrifying side effects.
There was no cure, no clue to where it came
from, and worst of all, the disease’s terrifying
impact didn’t end with death.
No, it was after those carrying the disease
died, that the real horror started.
After an agonizing fever that leaves the victims
writhing in pain, they quickly succumb to
the disease, only to rise from their graves
to wreak havoc on the living.
The virus continues to spread, until the corpses
outnumber those trying to hide from them,
as the world spirals into almost certain ruin.
It sounds like the plot of a zombie movie,
but for the SCP Foundation this is anything
but fiction, and the terror that unfolded
in that little Siberian town is the first
recorded encounter with SCP - 610, also known
as, The Flesh That Hates.
First, livestock began to vanish from farms.
Theft or wild animals were suspected, but
no suspects could be found, and no mutilated
remains turned up.
The animals weren’t being stolen, and they
weren’t being eaten, so…what happened
to them?
With no more animals left to lose, the farmers
themselves then began to disappear, but the
authorities refused to take the missing persons
cases seriously.
The missing farmers’ families would contact
the police, make a report, and then the whole
thing was forgotten.
It was written off just as another unsolved
disappearance, which wasn’t uncommon in
the wild and unforgiving region.
Then the police themselves began to disappear.
The families of the missing farmers would
sometimes report strange sounds from the surrounding
woods, describing moans and inhuman screeches
of pain.
One young boy reported seeing a cow with what
he described as “tentacles” lurking around
the edge of the trees.
Regional police were dispatched to the location,
and ordered to investigate and report back
on their findings within 24 hours.
But the units sent to the area didn’t report
back, and were never heard from again.
Upon learning of the reports, the Russian
government grew increasingly concerned, fearing
domestic insurgency or foreign espionage of
some kind could be at play.
They sent a small team of special agents to
the area, and, one by one, those agents disappeared,
just like the others before them.
It seemed no one who went into the village
after the disappearances started ever came
out again.
They had all simply vanished.
Desperate for answers, the Russian government
contacted the only people in the world who
could help - The SCP Foundation.
What the Foundation found over the course
of their investigation would shock and unnerve
them, going beyond anything they had previously
discovered.
Before the investigation officially began,
the affected area was sealed off by the Russian
government.
Not knowing if it would be safe to send researchers
into the containment perimeter, the Foundation
set up a small camera mounted unit, nicknamed
Herbie, to capture footage of whatever remained
of the village.
The images captured by Herbie revealed what
exactly had become of the people in this doomed
village, and the true, nightmarish nature
of SCP-610.
SCP-610 is a Keter-class entity, meaning it’s
an anomaly that’s exceedingly difficult
to contain consistently or reliably, with
containment procedures often being extensive
and complex.
610 is a highly contagious skin disease that
initially manifests like an ordinary allergic
reaction, with symptoms including increased
sensitivity, itching, and a rash.
But within just three hours of those initial
symptoms appearing, the rash starts to turn
into masses of scar tissue on the chest and
arms.
These masses spread over the legs and back
of the victim, and completely consume them
in thick, rubbery flesh within five hours.
Once they’re covered, the victim will cease
all vital functions.
Unfortunately for them, and doubly so for
those around them, they do not stay dead.
About three minutes after expiring, the victim’s
vitals will restart at a heightened rate,
and the masses of flesh encasing their body
will begin to move and multiply, mutating
them into a form beyond anything resembling
the human they once were.
The specific type of mutation varies from
case to case, but has included the head becoming
massive and bulbous, the growth of extra limbs,
and, in especially gruesome cases, the victim’s
body splitting apart to allow extra tendrils
of flesh to sprout from the open wound.
Occasionally, an infected person will stop
moving and become rooted to the ground in
a set location.
Once it is settled, their flesh will spread
itself across the ground, encasing all nearby
objects in flaps of scar tissue.
The infected that maintain their mobility
are highly aggressive, even violent, and will
attempt to infect any living thing that comes
into their line of sight.
The disease does not only infect humans, and
can take over any living organism within a
matter of hours.
Due to the highly contagious and dangerous
nature of the disease, safe observation of
infected specimens and areas is only possible
with drones and mounted cameras.
This brings us back to Herbie, the first such
mounted camera to record footage of the infected
area.
Herbie was deployed into the infection site,
also known as Site A, without any damage.
It remained at the outside perimeter of the
village for two hours, observing several infected
humans, and fire damage to many of the homes,
before following an infected into an intact
house.
Herbie’s camera feed captured the infected
person entering the house and sitting down
at the table inside.
There were several other infected humans in
the house, and one unidentified infected creature
that remained immobile under the table.
After viciously assaulting one of the other
infected humans, the infected returned to
the table and began to lay out plates on top
of it.
Pieces of its flesh began to wriggle and tear
away from its body, before settling onto each
plate.
Once the plates were filled, the infected
sitting at the table began to grab at the
flesh and crush it into their mouths, in a
perverse imitation of a normal mealtime gathering.
After capturing this stomach-churning display,
Herbie left the house and continued to explore
the village.
It recorded footage of a large stack of bodies
that seemed to be made up of both Russian
military and civilians, with an infected sitting
on top.
As Herbie maneuvered toward the remains of
the town hall, an infected grabbed the rover
off of the ground.
Herbie’s camera was able to capture the
face of the infected that grabbed the rover.
The face was that of a young girl around ten
years old, strangely intact atop a large,
distorted body.
The final moments of Herbie’s camera feed
captured the infected girl’s face bursting
open, revealing tendrils of flesh that pulled
Herbie into the gaping maw.
Then, the feed cut to black.
Herbie was regarded as lost, but the video
feed briefly resumed five hours later, showing
the camera covered with an unidentified slime.
After this, the video feed was cut for good,
and Herbie abandoned in Site A.
The Foundation has sent several manned expeditions
into Site A, where many expedition forces
have fallen victim to the infected.
Several operatives were also lost in an earthquake
that revealed a network of underground tunnels.
A manned expedition into these tunnels was
attempted, and the video feed that was captured
by the researchers on the expedition was deeply
disturbing.
There were images of an abandoned church filled
with infected, and a mass of uninfected or
partially infected human captives.
The final moments of the video feed from this
expedition captured several operatives being
murdered by an infected human wielding a farming
scythe, indicating that the infected are capable
of using simple weaponry in addition to brute
force.
The use of this weapon, paired with the presence
of captives in the underground tunnels, paints
a terrifying picture of the kind of organization
the infected are capable of.
No more manned expeditions have been attempted,
or, if they have, they have been highly classified.
Ordinarily, once a new SCP is discovered,
it is placed in containment at the Foundation,
with special procedures in place, so that
it can be studied or even neutralized in the
rare occasions where it’s deemed necessary.
When it comes to SCP-610 though, containment
might just be impossible.
It simply covers too much area, and is too
dangerous to expose to human researchers.
Instead, all infected areas have been isolated
with the permission of the Russian government.
There is an official perimeter established
around these areas, and any civilians that
approach them are told to leave under the
pretense of ongoing military operations.
For once, a top secret military project is
the more innocent answer.
Armed guards are placed at the perimeter of
every infected area, and any living thing
with symptoms of SCP-610 spotted near the
perimeter is to be immobilized, killed, and
burned from as far away as possible.
Any living thing that comes in contact with
SCP-610, whether a soldier, a scientist, or
a civilian, is immediately terminated, and
their remains destroyed.
If someone comes within three meters of an
infected organism, they will be quarantined
and remotely examined to determine if they
have been infected.
While the spread of SCP-610 can be airborne,
it has been determined to be far less contagious
when spread through air particles as opposed
to physical contact.
The infection sites remain active to this
day, like modern day leper colonies.
Though they are isolated from the general
population, and the military is doing everything
in their power to contain the infected, SCP-610
is still very much alive.
It is rare for an entity to exist that the
Foundation cannot truly contain, but can only
try to guard against, and that makes this
infection all the more terrifying.
Who knows how much it has mutated over the
years, growing, spreading, hungry for new
hosts?
There is still so much that the Foundation
does not know about the Flesh That Hates,
such as how it works, what it can do, or even
where it came from, since the origin of the
first infection is still, at this point, entirely
unknown.
It has shown itself to be capable of learning,
planning, and protecting itself, so who is
to say that it couldn’t figure out a way
to escape from its isolated area?
It is so highly contagious, and spreads so
quickly, that just one tiny, infected rabbit,
and one inattentive soldier, could be enough
for SCP-610 to reach the general population.
If it did, its violent, destructive nature
and hatred for all life would mean that everything,
not just the people but animals, plants, and
the world itself, could be at risk.
And no one is ready for this kind of infection.
A disease that turns the human body against
itself, turns our skin into a weapon and a
tomb, stripping away identity, humanity, and
everything that isn’t made of that same
hateful flesh.
So, let’s hope that the perimeter holds,
and, the next time you feel a little itchy,
try not to think about what might happen next.
It was November 20th, 2019, and the helicopter
circled far above in the freezing wind of
the Antarctic.
SCP Foundation Site Director Jason Monroe
looked down at the isolated above-ground facilities
of Provisional Site-344-1.
Something about this place made him nervous.
Edgy.
And for good reason: Between 2003 and 2019,
twenty-nine Mobile Task Force units and seventy-three
members of D-Class personnel had gone missing
here and never been found.
Monroe thought he was here for a routine investigation
into negligence and mismanagement, but little
did he know, he was in for so much more.
This is the story of SCP - 5545, and one man’s
journey into his own worst nightmare.
Literally.
But this nightmare began a long time ago - 300
years, to be exact.
And like most nightmares, it started as a
dream.
That dream was one of expansion - national
powers across Europe wanted to be the first
to conquer the globe and expand into new territories,
and sent countless exploratory missions off
into the unknown to achieve this goal.
Any history book will tell you that the first
outsiders to lay eyes upon the continent of
Antarctica did so in 1820 - the reality is
that the first ones to get there actually
landed in the late 1700s.
The hapless explorers ventured into mainland
Antarctica and made base camps, before searching
and digging for any useful resources nearby.
They came upon a strange discovery: A hallway,
hidden beneath the ice.
Not a passage in the ice, but a true hallway
- complete with light fixtures.
The confused explorers ventured down into
these impossible hallways, and for many of
them, it would be the last thing they ever
did.
No matter how long they walked, it seemed
like the hallways just kept going.
As they continued to walk for hours, they
hoped they’d find something… anything.
And eventually, they did.
They passed from these hallways into somewhere
different altogether, and most of them were
never heard from again.
Those who did manage to escape often died
or took their own lives soon after.
Whatever it was they’d discovered down there,
they didn’t want to live with it on their
minds.
It’s believed that over seventy colonial
explorers disappeared or died this way and
that most who found these endless hallways
beneath the Antarctic ice never returned.
The multiple anomalous objects and phenomena
that make up SCP-5545 came into the Foundation’s
hands several centuries later on September
18th, 2003, when during an expedition into
the Antarctic, they too found the endless
hallways.
The Foundation built Provisional Site-344-1
around them, hoping to safely seal them off
from any other unwitting Antarctic explorers
or researchers.
But there was something else lurking beneath
the ice in Antarctica.
Something dangerous.
The hallways were designated as SCP - 5545
- 1 and were thought to be the extent of the
anomalous activity at the site, but soon SCP
- 5545 - 2 was discovered, which resulted
in the deaths of sixteen researchers.
So what exactly is 5545 - 2?
It’s an entity so volatile that even knowing
about it is considered to be a containment
breach, and - as a result - it’s kept in
Provisional Site-344-2.
Unlike Site - 344 - 1, 344 - 2 isn’t a physical
space.
It’s conceptual, accessible only through
the endless hallways, created with the express
purpose of keeping 5545 - 1 and 5545 - 2 separate.
Why?
Because whenever the two come into contact,
the result is 5545 - 3: The network of endless
hallways expanding.
If they remained in contact, the hallways
would continue to expand and the entire planet
could be filled with endless hallways in just
four to six hours.
While the two are apart though, 5545 - 3 reverses,
but it always would take just a few hours
to throw the whole world into a chaos of infinite
hallways.
SCP-5545 has been given the classification
“Safe”…
Wait, we’re dealing with a mysterious and
volatile anomaly that’s claimed a huge number
of lives and still somehow eludes true Foundation
understanding, yet the official SCP Foundation
classification is “Safe?”
How could this be?
Monroe was the Director of Site - 58, and
was the definition of no-nonsense.
Prior to taking the Site Director position,
he was a decorated member of Mobile Task Force
Eta-10 and helped contain numerous Keter-Class
anomalies.
He’d been around the proverbial block when
it came to anomalous activity, and something
about SCP - 5545, and the management of Provisional
Site 344, seemed awfully suspicious to him.
And he had questions.
Like how such an unpredictable anomaly could
be declared “safe”?
And why had there been such a lapse of communication
between the Foundation and Doctor Gabriel
Reed, who’d been running the facility for
the past two decades?
And most of all, just what exactly was the
mysterious SCP - 5545 - 2?
Monroe started to believe that something terrible
had happened at the site, and Reed was covering
it all up.
But to find out for sure, he’d need to go
to Antarctica and investigate it himself.
Information around this supposedly “Safe”
anomaly was highly classified - those without
O5 clearance could face termination for snooping.
But that didn’t scare Jason Monroe.
He’d dealt with Keters before, he could
deal with this.
Or so he thought.
Monroe submitted a request and was granted
unanimous approval by the O5 Council to travel
to Provisional Site 344 and get to the bottom
of this mystery.
He took a chopper to the base soon after,
armed with a concealed firearm and a Hostile
Meme Detector - or HMD - to test whether the
base and its staff had somehow fallen under
a hazardous memetic effect from SCP - 5545.
He’d find the answers, or die trying.
The moment Monroe arrived, he couldn’t help
but notice the strange way the staff behaved.
They seemed listless; almost depressive.
When he showed his credentials to a researcher,
they simply said “SCP-5545-2 is contained
in Site-344-2.”
His request to see Dr. Reed that night was
denied.
Dr. Reed was busy, he was told.
Wait until tomorrow.
The next day, Monroe met with Dr. Reed, but
the results of the meeting were underwhelming
to say the least.
Just like the rest of the staff on the site,
he seemed exhausted, as though he hadn’t
slept in days.
His responses were quiet and evasive, and
he refused to tell Monroe anything that wasn’t
in the official files already.
Monroe ran the conversation through the HMD
and found nothing out of the ordinary.
What was going on here?
Monroe was irritated, but not deterred.
Nothing would stop him from finding out the
truth.
The next day, he flexed his O5 credentials
and hacked into the base’s security system.
This gave him access to cameras around Site
- 344 -1, but more importantly, there was
a single camera inside the mysterious Site
- 344 - 2.
Jackpot.
But when he looked at it, the feed was an
entirely black screen with the words “SCP-5545-2
is contained in Site-344-2.”
The footage of the staff in 344 - 1 was equally
strange: The eighteen employees on site all
sat at computer banks, with nothing but static
playing on their screens.
Monroe kept digging though, and was able to
hack into the security footage of Dr. Reed’s
office.
As he watched, he discovered a fifteen minute
period where Reed left the office each day.
He could use this brief window to break in
and collect more intel on SCP - 5545 - 2.
Monroe was so wrapped up in the investigation
that he almost forgot the more immediate danger
around him, and nearly wandered into one of
the endless hallways of 5545 - 1 by mistake.
He made a note to be more careful in future...
His first attempt at breaking into Dr. Reed’s
office didn’t produce many answers - one
piece of evidence was a blurry picture of
what looked like a Mobile Task Force entering
a 5545 - 1 hallway in the dark.
Another was a spreadsheet featuring all the
personnel, living or dead, who’d worked
at the site - but one name, and the details
of whether this person was alive or dead,
was completely redacted.
Anything particularly juicy was hidden behind
O5 clearance.
If Monroe wanted the answers, he’d need
to break through.
That night, he had a horrific recurring nightmare,
one that had plagued him since he joined MTF
Eta-10.
He dreamed he was in a fancy dining room with
a grand fireplace.
The room was full of statues of men and women.
The men looked angry, and the women looked
afraid.
As he approached the fireplace, the ceiling
extended infinitely up into the darkness.
Suddenly, the zombie-like body of a teenage
girl appears in the fireplace, hanging from
a long thread.
Her eyes look furious and full of rage, and
Monroe somehow knows that he’s the reason
for her hate.
When he steps into the fireplace in this dream,
she attacks him, the two intertwine, and they
burn forever.
The one difference was that in this new iteration
of the dream, he blinked upon entering the
fireplace, and suddenly, he was in a hallway.
He awoke sure that something was terribly
wrong here, but he couldn’t give up now.
The next day, Monroe broke into Dr. Reed’s
office and made a horrifying discovery.
He found files indicating that Dr. Reed was
knowingly sending Mobile Task Forces and D-Class
personnel into the infinite hallways of 5545
- 1 to their doom.
He also found evidence that Reed and the researchers
had been spying on him, somehow intercepting
copies of the notes he had been taking.
That’s when Dr. Reed entered the office
and interrupted him.
Monroe panicked and drew his weapon, holding
the doctor at gunpoint.
He was breaking so many Foundation rules,
but right now, he feared for his life.
The doctor seemed unbothered by Monroe’s
threats though.
He told Monroe that everything was going to
plan, and that he should go back to his room.
Monroe was becoming increasingly paranoid
- he felt that, at any moment, guards might
burst in and execute him.
Nothing about this place made sense.
He worried he was going insane.
Perhaps the only way to find answers was to
go even deeper: To risk it all, and venture
through the endless hallways to find SCP - 5545
- 2 himself, and finally discover what this
thing actually was.
Monroe left his room and stepped into one
of the endless hallways of 5545 - 1 that was
located just across from his dorm.
He found that it was a hallway like all the
others on site - Plain concrete, worn with
age, with simple light fixtures on the walls.
He walked for hours, recording with a concealed
device.
The lights suddenly went out, leaving him
in complete darkness.
When they flicked back on, he was in a very
different environment: A grand, old carpeted
hallway, the kind you’d see in an old mansion.
He broke into a cold sweat.
What was so familiar about this place?He kept
walking, wracked with terror, until this new
hallway finally led him to the place he’d
been seeking: Site 344 - 2, the domain of
5545 - 2.
It was a large, poorly-lit room, filled with
grimacing statues and a large fireplace at
the far end.
It was the exact same room from Monroe’s
dream - with one horrifying difference.
Monroe noticed a single white thread hanging
down from the infinite ceiling, and when he
looked up to find its source, he screamed.
There were hundreds of bodies hanging and
swinging from the ceiling above him - everyone
who SCP - 5545 - 2 had ever killed, including
MTF members, D-Class Personnel, and even the
colonial explorers from hundreds of years
before.
And all of them were him.
Every single one.
They had his face.
And there, hanging in the middle of the room
at ground level, was the body of a teenage
girl, the one from his dream.
In that moment, he finally recognized her:
She was the girl he killed.
The first him.
Hundreds of years ago.
Much like Monroe, you’re probably wondering:
What is going on here?
Thanks to declassified communications between
Dr. Reed and the O5 Council, we can tell you.
Jason Monroe is a man who’s been reincarnated
hundreds of times over the last three hundred
years, ever since he murdered a teenage girl…
A girl named Emily… his daughter.
This murder sparked the existence of SCP - 5545
as an eternally recurring punishment for his
crimes.
Since figuring this out, the Foundation has
kept tabs on Monroe’s reincarnations - whether
they’re MTF members, D-Class personnel,
or even Site Directors.
They see to it that these reincarnations always
find their way back to 5545 - 2 to take his
punishment, and prevent the infinite hallway
expansion that threatens to destroy the world.
It’s a plan everyone is in on - everyone
except him.
But every time he enters that nightmare-haunting
room, it all comes rushing back.
In that moment though, he knew his crime,
and he somehow knew how many times this punishment
had unfolded for him.
He now had two choices: Repent and accept
the punishment again, or leave and activate
5545 - 3, potentially allowing the endless
tunnels to expand across the world.
Like his many predecessors, Monroe made the
decent choice.
He accepted his punishment and allowed his
own string to coil around him as the lights
in the room went off, one by one, leaving
only darkness.
Jason Monroe - that version of him, at least
- was never seen again.
But The SCP Foundation is already eyeing up
his next reincarnation, and preparing to let
this twisted cycle play out all over again.
Stop me if you've heard this one before.
A young man was driving home from work late
one rainy night when he spotted a woman in
a white dress and a red sweater walking along
the shoulder of the road.
Concerned for her safety, he slowed down and
rolled down the window so he could talk to
her.
When he asked where she was going, she said
she was walking to her parents' house.
The man pulled over and offered her a ride
that she accepted.
The woman gave him the address of her home,
hopped in the backseat, and the man drove
off.
He sensed that she must've been cold from
walking in the rain, so he cranked up the
car's heater to help her dry off.
Soon she removed her heavy red sweater and
placed it on the seat next to her.
The man tried to make friendly conversation
- asking if the woman had a job, what she
was studying at school, where she'd been that
day - but she remained quiet, staring out
the window.
Until they drove past an old graveyard.
The woman began pounding on the glass of the
car as if she desperately wanted something.
Unsure of what to do, the man pulled over,
but before he could ask her what was happening
she had gotten out of the car.
He exited the car to try and find her but
the woman was nowhere to be seen.
She must have somehow ran off.
Confused, the man got back in his car and
drove away.
He went on his way and didn’t think of it
again until the next day, when he noticed
her sweater was still in the back of his car.
He decided to go to the house she had originally
given him the address for and give it back
to her.
He found the home without any trouble, but
when he knocked on the door the old woman
who answered it was confused by his story.
She told him that her daughter couldn't have
possibly left her sweater in his car, because
she'd died in a car accident 30 years ago.
The vanishing hitchhiker is a classic ghost
story, with the details varying from place
to place and storyteller to storyteller.
In Chicago, she goes by Resurrection Mary,
named after the graveyard she asks for rides
to.
In Okinawa, Japan, she's known as the Nightwalker
of Nago, and she only appears to taxi drivers.
In Kent, England, she's Suzanne, a bride killed
in a car wreck on the way to her bachelorette
party.
In North Carolina, her name is Lydia, and
in Hawaii she's believed to be the goddess
Pele in human form.
But as far as our friends at the SCP Foundation
are concerned, the vanishing hitchhiker's
name is Mary Talish, also known as SCP-1337.
On the 19th of May, 1952, college sophomore
Mary Talish was abducted on her way to class
in her hometown of Muncie, Indiana.
When police found her body 2 weeks later,
her eyes and heart had been torn from her
body in a ritualistic fashion, and she had
scrapes and bruises that suggested she'd been
beaten before her murder.
Her killers were never caught, and her body
was returned to her family for burial in Tomlinson
Cemetery.
Starting on the 19th of June that same year,
someone matching Mary's description - a caucasian
woman with blonde hair, standing 150 cm tall
and wearing a red sweater - was spotted trying
to flag down passing vehicles along Mayflower
Road.
Since then, every month, on the 19th, Mary
has been sighted along that stretch of road,
and every month, the same scenario plays out.
Mary gives anyone who picks her up directions
to her parents' house, then on the way, she
instructs the driver to stop at the graveyard
where she was buried.
She vanishes from the car, leaving her sweater.
The driver of the car tries to return the
sweater to her parents' house, only to be
told that Mary Talish was dead.
When the SCP foundation was made aware of
Mary Talish's pattern of haunting in the late
50's, they set up a system where agents would
patrol Mayflower Road at hourly intervals
with the intention of picking Mary up.
Agents were sent on their own in non-Foundation
cars and instructed to stick to the accepted
script of the vanishing hitchhiker legend,
without attempting to engage Mary in further
conversation.
Mary's parents were also given E-class Agent
status to keep them from speaking out about
the haunting, and told that the Foundation
was working on a way to set the spirit to
rest.
Early attempts to study the apparition were
inconclusive - it proved impossible for the
Foundation to relocate her or trigger her
manifestation outside of the 19th of every
month, and attempts to analyze her sweater
were fruitless, since if the sweater wasn't
returned to the Talish family home it would
simply vanish from containment at or around
sunset on the next 19th.
For 20 years, SCP-1337 events continued to
happen as normal.
D-Class personnel under the instruction of
the Foundation would pick Mary up, drive her
past the cemetery, and return her sweater
to her parents.
It was business as usual, and in fact, it
was one of the more sedate recurring apparitions
the Foundation had to deal with.
But, as you might have guessed, that peace
wouldn't last forever.
Enter Dr. Lawson - who, in 1972, was placed
in charge of all resources regarding SCP-1337.
Dr. Lawson was getting sick of all this phantom
hitchhiker business, and while most of the
Foundation was happy to keep this routine
going, Lawson thought that the continual picking
up and dropping off of Mary Talish and her
red sweater was a waste of the Foundation’s
valuable time.
After all, it was the early 70's - the price
of oil was at an all-time high, so the expense
of sending car after car up and down the same
road for a solid day once a month just to
pick up a ghost was more trouble than it was
worth.
So, Lawson started developing a plan, one
that he didn't go through the proper Foundation
channels to approve.
He reasoned that the reason Mary's ghost kept
coming back was because she wanted something.
Since always asked for a ride home, then it
must mean that she wanted to return back to
her parents.
So, logic followed that if she had nothing,
or no one, to go back to then she'd stop appearing.
On 18th June, 1973, Lawson went ahead with
his plan without his superiors' knowledge
and ordered the execution of Mary Talish's
parents, as well as the immediate demolition
of their family home.
According to his journals, Lawson had hoped
that his attempt at decommissioning 1337 would
significantly cut the Foundation's gas bills,
freeing up valuable funds, at which point
he'd surely be promoted in 'recognition of
his brilliance'.
But that wasn't what happened.
Lawson was demoted from team leader to junior
staff, and only kept on 1337 detail out of
the belief that, without a family to return
to, Lawson would become the new focal point
of the haunting should Mary Talish ever return.
Though Lawson's actions weren't at all above
board, even by SCP Foundation standards, they
did seem to have worked.
The 19th of June came and went without a single
Mary sighting.
And she wasn't seen the next month either.
A full year went by without any sign of the
Mayflower Road apparition.
Satisfied with this turn of events, the Foundation
made the decision to officially reclassify
SCP-1337 from “Safe” to “Safe Decommissioned”
and the gas money that was budgeted for the
Mayflower Road patrol was redirected to the
SCP-682 tank acid fund.
But even though everything seemed to have
been sorted out, Lawson wasn't entirely satisfied.
And just because of his demotion.
Whether it was intuition or merely guilt-induced
paranoia is unclear, but he suspected that
Mary was still out there somewhere.
At first he thought that she might show up
on the anniversary of her parents' deaths,
but then that date came and went, as did eight
more anniversaries after it.
Finally, on the 19th of June, 1983, Lawson
decided he had to see for himself.
Fitted with recording equipment, he drove
alone, in a non-Foundation standard car, down
that lonely stretch of road where so many
before him had stopped to pick up that mysterious
blonde woman with the red sweater.
He had to prove to himself that she wouldn't
show up, that he had really and truly gotten
rid of her for good.
It was about 5 o'clock in the evening when
he reached Mayflower Road.
At first, he didn't experience anything strange.
He scanned the roadside, looking for the phantom
hitchhiker walking along it, but there was
nobody there.
Dr. Lawson breathed a sigh of relief - he
may have orchestrated the deaths of two innocent
people, but at least it hadn't been for nothing.
He turned on the recorder he'd brought with
him and logged that nothing had happened.
SCP-1337 had been permanently neutralized.
As he approached the t-intersection and prepared
to turn onto Marsh Avenue, he looked up to
adjust his rear view mirror.
To his horror, he found that he wasn't alone
in the car - someone was in the seat behind
him, someone with blonde hair and a red sweater.
His last transmission consisted only of “Wait,
who the hell are yo-“, before the recording
abruptly stopped.
Lawson's car was found soon after by Foundation
agents.
Lawson was dead in the front seat, bruised
and bloody, with his eyes and heart ripped
out in a ritualistic fashion.
Just the way Mary Talish had been found all
the way back in 1952.
It turns out that Mary hadn't been neutralized
after all.
She'd just been waiting for a chance to get
revenge on the man who killed her family.
And Mary didn't stop with Dr. Lawson.
No longer does she appear, walking along the
road waiting for someone to offer her a ride
before disappearing without incident.
Now, should someone pass by without offering
a ride, she will appear in their backseat
before re-enacting the method of her own death
upon the driver.
And her physical appearance has changed too.
Whereas before she looked like the image of
the pretty young woman before her tragedy,
now recordings show that she appears with
the wounds of her death present, her eyes
gouged out of their sockets and a massive
hole in her chest where her heart should be.
The same wounds she inflicts on her victims.
The SCP Foundation has tried closing off and
even destroying the road, but that has only
resulted in Mary manifesting at other locations
in and around Muncie.
Foundation documents reveal that any back
road in the city can potentially serve as
host to a 1337 event, and all attempts to
contain the apparition have failed.
The only way someone who has seen Mary can
avoid her wrath is by stopping to pick her
up, at which point she will de-materialize
before reappearing on another road.
Mobile Task Forces have been unsuccessful,
as Mary only appears to those driving alone,
and all agents who have been sent on solo
missions to apprehend her have resulted in
the death of the agent.
SCP-1337 was reinstated, this time as Euclid
class.
Currently, the foundation's method of managing
SCP-1337 is to dispatch a security team on
the 19th of every month to monitor all of
the places where a potential sighting could
take place.
As soon as signs of a manifestation are identified,
a remotely controlled vehicle containing a
single D-class is driven to the location.
Once Mary appears in the car, the car is piloted
to the empty lot where her home used to stand,
and the remains of the D-class are then disposed
of.
Like a lot of stories that get passed down
as urban legends, the story of SCP-1337 has
a lesson that can be taken away from it.
This SCP started off as an ordinary local
haunting, no more deadly than Lydia, Suzanne,
Resurrection Mary, or any of the countless
other local versions of the vanishing hitchhiker
story.
But, thanks to one rogue Foundation doctor
and his desire to rush to what he thought
would be an efficient solution, the spirit
not only became harder to control but also
much more violent and bloodthirsty than anyone
was prepared to deal with.
So, if there's anything we can learn here,
it's that no matter if you're a student, an
office worker, or a researcher with the SCP
Foundation, think twice about cutting corners.
It might save you a little bit of time and
money in the short term, but in the long term,
the results could be fatal.
It was 1965 and the Chicago PD was investigating
a meatpacking plant reported to be the home
of a devil worshipping cult, complete with
allegations of human sacrifice.
There the cops were met with heavy resistance.
A firefight broke out between the police and
the occult worshippers who flooded out of
the plant’s basement.
The cops were pinned down, and in trouble,
but they had a secret weapon - heavily armed,
decked out in sophisticated ballistic armour,
and covered in strange insignia.
Mobile Task Force Epsilon-9, also known as
the Fire Eaters, here to assist the cops on
behalf of the SCP Foundation.
As always with the Foundation, they had no
interest in some mere human cultists.
Those were a dime a dozen in the world of
anomalous monsters.
What the Foundation had taken an interest
in was who or what these cultists were worshipping.
It’d all begun a few weeks back, near Danforth
Meatpacking, an abandoned meat packing plant
just outside of Chicago.
No one had given the place a thought in decades,
that is until people started going missing.
Rumors spread of people being snatched in
the surrounding woods by figures dressed in
robes.
Mysterious voices and noises were said to
be coming out from the cavernous belly of
the plant.
Some even reported seeing smoke rising out
of the building - thick, black, noxious smoke.
Something was terribly wrong here.
Something was...anomalous.
The Chicago Police Department Strike Force,
in association with the Fire Eaters from the
Foundation, mobilized at Danforth Meatpacking.
While the police were initially reluctant
to work with these mysterious figures they
turned out to be indispensable for the raid.
There were forty-seven cultists holding out
in the basement of the plant, many of them
heavily armed and all of them hopped up on
zealous devotion to their unknown master.
All except one of the cultists fought to the
death during a tense firefight with Chicago
PD and the Fire Eaters.
The single survivor was still heavily injured,
and was taken to a secure Foundation facility
for emergency treatment and debriefing.
Typically, the Foundation would need to perform
extensive tests on the Danforth Meatpacking
plant to discover the source of the anomaly’s
activity, however, this time, it was a Chicago
detective who asked the question that busted
the case wide open:
“The hell’s with the giant pig?”
And while it would turn out to be a whole
lot more than that, there was indeed a giant,
iron furnace shaped like a pig in the center
of the facility.
Measuring 15m by 25m by 20m at its widest
points, the thing was a behemoth.
It had an internal furnace despite no apparent
fuel source, and a five centimeter slot of
unknown purpose on the side of the machine’s
immense, rusted hide.
Naturally, all the police officers involved
in the raid had their memories wiped and restructured.
And they were lucky, because they’d remain
forever ignorant of the true horrors about
to unfold in the confines of that godforsaken
factory.
As is standard procedure, the plant was isolated,
and a Foundation research team - led by Lead
Researcher Westrin, under the authority of
Regional Director Caleb - was installed on
the new provisional site to conduct tests.
Other than everyone feeling somewhat uneasy
around it, this new anomaly, dubbed SCP - 4511,
didn’t seem to exhibit any strange activity
save for its perpetually burning fire, but
during the initial research period, a small,
white card suddenly popped out of the slot
in SCP - 4511’s side.
A researcher carefully approached and looked
at the card, there was writing.
It said, “CURRENT DEMAND: A flock of my
own.
- SATISFIED.”
Though nobody on the team had any idea what
this meant.
After going through a shoot out with a considerable
death toll to get to it, having a giant metal
pig shaped furnace spit out a cryptic card
was strange.
But at the secret medical facility where the
surviving cultist was being held, things were
about to get a whole lot stranger.
As he lay in a bed suffering from his injuries,
he pulled one of the medical staff close and
uttered cryptic, dying words: “Give it whatever
it demands, or your suffering will be beyond
measure.”
He expired seconds later, less than 72 hours
after the raid.
Back at the meat packing plant, at the exact
same time, another white card was produced
by the machine, reading “CURRENT DEMAND:
The metal teeth that endlessly churn.
PERIOD: One Week.”
Perhaps this entity was a little more intelligent
than they thought.
A number of researchers on the team, invigorated
by this new development, were eager to press
forward with experiments.
Lead Researcher Westrin, however, did not
share their enthusiasm.
Something about this entire situation felt
like a grim omen to him.
This entity had a plan far beyond their understanding
- and on some deep, animal level, he knew
that helping this thing see its plans through
would lead to disastrous results.
On this first gut impulse, he denied the request
for further experiments.
But Regional Director Caleb had other ideas.
Caleb overruled Westrin’s command, and the
experiments began shortly after.
The entity, jokingly nicknamed The Swine God
by researchers, had made its demand: The metal
teeth that endlessly churn.
But what could that mean?
It wasn’t long before the entity began to
produce more cards, each with their own strange
and esoteric demands.
However, on some instinctual level, the researchers
at the site understood the demands perfectly.
The next card’s demand was "The metal of
this suffocating prison."
Upon receiving this demand, researchers collected
scrap metal from around the new site, and
tossed them into the furnace beyond the Swine
God’s jaws one by one.
Inside, they heard the sound of metal crunching.
Hours later, all the other metal in the site
began to rapidly oxidize and rust - though
SCP-4511 itself remained unaffected.
The card that came after delivered another
simple request: "Oil to slicken my frozen
joints."
The researchers understood and procured three
large barrels of oil and tossed them into
the furnace.
The entity let out a deep gurgle, before shaking
violently and expelling excess oil, rusted
metal, and two domesticated pig femurs.
It turns out that the Swine God had an appetite
for pigs, as the next card that rumbled out
of the machine bore the request, “Two of
my children, made in my image, made in flesh."
In response, the researchers provided the
entity with two adult pigs.
Just like the previous requests, they too
were tossed into the fiery depths of the giant
pig’s mouth, from which came the horrible
sounds of pigs squealing, and then a low,
guttural gurgling.
Next, the request was, “The hooks used to
hang my children's corpses."
To satisfy this request the researchers provided
seventeen meat hooks.
In response, 4511 spat out a metal sphere
at an extremely high velocity, killing observing
Foundation Agent McHenry.
For reasons that weren’t apparent at the
time, rather than giving Agent McHenry a proper
burial, his body was also fed into the hungry
machine.
Lead Researcher Westrin’s concerns were
mounting, but that didn’t amount to much
now.
4511 had developed a taste for flesh, and
the researchers were all too eager to obey
its command.
On the Swine God’s order, it was fed a German
shepherd.
An hour later, the entity spat out some teeth.
Six of which came from a dog, and one from
a human.
More than once, it released a card with the
blunt request “A worker for the line.”
The researchers knew exactly what this meant:
It required a human sacrifice.
SCP-4511 was given two D-Class personnel.
One was flung back out seconds later, crunched
and burned to death with several internal
organs missing.
The other had a more mysterious and altogether
upsetting fate.
The second D-class was heard screaming in
the belly of the furnace for roughly two hours.
Thirty four minutes later, a strange liquid
was excreted by the machine.
When the liquid was tested, they found trace
amounts of chemicals like pig urine and motor
oil - but most disturbing of all, human genetic
material that was identical to that of Lead
Researcher Westrin.
It seemed that the Swine God had finally taken
an interest in him.
After some final requests for large quantities
of coal, and even human children, to fuel
its fires, it made the request that sent the
whole thing crashing down...
“The false foreman, delivered to my maw
to prove your faith."
Lead Researcher Westrin knew what this meant.
They all did.
The Swine God was demanding him in sacrifice.
Lead Researcher Westrin tried to shut down
the entire project, but the Swine God was
faster than him.
One of his own researchers shot Westrin in
the leg, as the others gathered round and
forcibly restrained him.
He tried to reason with his subordinates,
but it didn’t do him any good.
The Swine God had crawled into all their minds
and corrupted them - they were His servants
now, and Westrin was doomed.
Despite his protests, the servants forced
him into the mouth of SCP - 4511, and after
a little over four minutes of screaming, Westrin
was devoured just like all the other sacrifices.
Upon receiving news of the horrors unfolding
in the Danforth Meat Packing Plant, Regional
Director Caleb declared the security of the
site compromised, and sent in Mobile Force
Epsilon-11, aka the Nine-Tailed Fox.
The four elite MTF soldiers were given the
simple instruction to figure out exactly what
had happened, and to eliminate any potentially
compromised Foundation staff members who’d
fallen under the Swine God’s power.
When the team arrived, they realized just
how far gone the whole place was.
Almost everyone was dead, having been sacrificed
to the machine, and the ones that were left
were completely insane.
They attacked the task force, shouting in
their madness about how no matter what the
Foundation does to them, it would be nothing
compared to what it would do.
It had them all under its rusty, iron foot.
The team was forced to fend off repeated attacks
from the pig’s devotees, and even found
the powers of the Swine God starting to affect
their own minds.
The beast was more powerful and dangerous
than anyone had imagined.
The trained Foundation researchers and guards
had been transformed into the same cultists
they’d fought to gain control of the building
by the mind-bending power of the Swine God.
The MTF were forced to retreat and return
with reinforcements to truly clean the place
out.
Once a slaughterhouse, always a slaughterhouse.
At this point, Regional Director Caleb took
personal responsibility over the casualties
since he’d been the one who signed off on
the experiments in the first place.
He gave up his Regional Director rank, and
deemed himself the new Lead Researcher on
the 4511 case.
Now that he fully understood the scope and
danger of the entity they were dealing with,
he wanted to lead the charge in discovering
more about the anomaly, and hopefully someday
negating its deadly effects.
This may sound like a happy ending, in spite
of all the violence, bloodshed, and human
sacrifice that brought us here.
But beware of the premature celebration.
Despite investigation, the Swine God retained
no evidence of the objects, animals, and people
it’d consumed and burned.
Perhaps it’d burnt them down to their very
atoms, if those even still existed.
What we do know is that not long after, after
Lead Researcher Caleb and his subordinates
installed themselves into the facility, SCP
- 4511 produced one more little, white card.
It read, “CURRENT DEMAND: A flock of my
own.
- SATISFIED.”
And if we’ve learned anything today, it’s
that the Swine God gets whatever it demands.
A brutal truth that Lead Researcher Caleb
is likely to understand much sooner than he
thought...
It was just a job.
You were meant to be mopping floors and cleaning
toilets at the Johnston Labs and Pharmaceuticals
Research Center for minimum wage.
And you were happy about it, grateful for
any kind of employment - you didn’t even
know that the company signing your checks
was the SCP Foundation, an organization dedicated
to securing and containing anomalies and protecting
humanity from their negative effects at any
cost.
And today, you’re going to find out exactly
how steep that cost can be.
The Johnston Labs and Pharmaceuticals Research
Center isn’t actually a research center
at all: It’s a Foundation front business,
with a building solely dedicated to the containment
of a single anomaly: SCP-3280.
But again, you’re just the janitor, it’s
not like they would bother telling you what’s
being contained here.
If it breaks out, you won’t even know what’s
killing you until it’s too late.
It begins, like most classic horror stories,
on a dark and stormy night.
You’re mopping up a silent hallway, whistling
a little tune to yourself, when rain starts
hammering down on the window next to you.
Not long after, you see a bolt of lightning
split the distant sky followed by an immense
thunder crack.
Soon after you hear screaming and panicking
from below.
Frantic footsteps.
Then, the flashing lights and sirens.
You think back to your employee orientation.
These flashing lights and wailing sirens can
only mean one thing: Containment breach.
You run for it, not even knowing what you’re
running from.
You bring your mop and bucket with you, perhaps
just out of habit.
You seek refuge in the only place in the facility
that truly seems to belong to you: The broom
closet.
The alarm blares as you lock yourself in the
You’re shaking with terror and can hear
the screaming of your colleagues.
You hear more noises - running, scrambling,
a wet dripping sound, gunshots, and then…
silence.
All this time, you can’t help but wonder,
“Why isn’t anybody coming to help us?”
After a while, the only thing you can hear
is the rain and the distant thunder.
It’s been hours.
You’ve only managed to stave off dehydration
by drinking the filthy water from the mop
sink.
But at least it seems like the chaos outside
has died down.
Carefully, you open the door and peek out
of the closet.
Darkness, but no detectable movement.
Now’s your chance and you make a break for
it, creeping down the hall.
The dark hallway is suddenly lit up by lightning
and you can see that there are bodies everywhere.
You step over the corpse of Dr. Cawthrone,
one of the few scientists working here who
actually knew your name.
If you can make it to the security office,
you might be able to radio for help, or maybe
access a computer terminal.
On the way to the office you hear another
horrific scream start to echo through the
complex before it’s cut off by a thunderclap.
You have to ignore it though and push on.
When you enter the security room, you see
that the head security officer, Nichols, is
already dead.
His body has been cut open from neck to groin;
gutted.
The anomaly, whatever it is, has already been
here.
You access the computer terminal and open
the file for SCP-3280.
You’re warned that, as Janitorial Staff,
you have Level 0 Clearance, and as a result,
information will be omitted from the files
you access.
It doesn’t matter.
You press on and open up the file.
Both the object class and the description
have been redacted.
You can only see the Special Containment Procedures.
They dictate that 3280 is to remain contained
at the Johnston Labs and Pharmaceuticals Research
Center until long term Containment Procedures
can be drawn up.
If the entity ever reaches beyond Sub-Level
2, the facility enters full lockdown mode.
Not even information is allowed in or out
of the facility, as this could result in an
XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
In other words, nobody is coming to save you.
The only other information on the page is
a picture of a lightning storm, much like
the one you find yourself in right now.
Lightning flashes in the hall.
You dart around, paranoid, knowing the anomaly
could be anywhere.
All you can hear now is a quiet drip, drip,
drip of blood coming from the body of Security
Officer Nichols.
Whatever this thing had done to him looked
painful.
You try to remember him as he was in life,
and then, a revelation hits you.
A security officer probably has a lot better
clearance than a janitor.
You feel around Nichols’ mutilated torso
until you find his key card.
Thankfully, Nichols was the kind of guy who’d
write his password on the underside of the
card so he wouldn’t forget it.
You easily gain access to the Foundation servers
with his login credentials.
You now have Level 2 Security Clearance.
The terminal gives you the option to view
security footage taken throughout the site.
You’re given access to every camera still
working after the containment breach and the
subsequent carnage.
You select the camera feed for the Second
Floor Barracks.
There, you see Researcher Jenson hanging from
a makeshift noose attached to his bunk.
There’s a puddle underneath his corpse.
You access the feed from the Second Floor
East Wing.
There, you see Doctor Emmanuel stumbling down
a dark corridor.
His movements are oddly listless, like he’s
in a trance.
Suddenly, there’s another flash of lightning
and a crack of thunder.
Doctor Emmanuel clutches his gut in pain and
crumples to the floor.
You access the camera feed from the First
Floor Entrance.
It seems that the whole area is flooded, is
this because of the storm?
In a panic, many lower-tier staff members
had tried to escape, defying the lockdown
protocols in the special containment procedures.
Now, they’re floating face down in the water,
all dead.
You access the camera feed from Sub Level
2, and see another corpse lying in the corner.
He’s wearing an orange jumpsuit - D-Class,
no idea why he was down there.
The only other notable thing in the basement
was a burst pipe, leaking and spraying more
water everywhere.
With trembling fingers, you select the camera
feed for the First Floor Cafeteria.
The whole room is practically underwater - the
only evidence of the massacre that must have
taken place are the fragments of clothing
floating on the surface of the water.
That, and the fleshy, pink slurry forming
at the bottom of the windows.
It reminds you of the gooey meat runoff in
chicken nugget factories.
You close your eyes and try to center yourself.
It’s violent chaos.
Looking at more of it isn’t getting you
anywhere.
Instead, you decide to put those new Level
2 Security Access credentials to good use,
and hop back onto the file for SCP-3280.
You think to yourself, “There has to be
something I can use on here...”
But even as you wait for the file to load,
some part of you knows that time is running
out for you.
Perhaps it’s the stress, or the fear, or
the filthy mop water you drank, but you’re
feeling the pressure start to mount, physically.
Your stomach is beginning to ache.
You can see blurry shapes moving in the corners
of your eyes.
It’s getting harder to focus your vision,
and harder still to quiet the terrified voices
in your mind.
But you can’t get up - not without knowing
what is doing this to you.
The containment class for SCP-3280 is now
declassified.
“Euclid.”
And what’s more, the Special Containment
Procedures have altered, too.
They now explain that every week, a new member
of D-Class personnel is to be deposited into
the entity’s lair in Sub Level 2 through
Subterranean Access Point Gamma.
The D-Class- or more accurately, the sacrifices
- are to be told lies about why exactly they
need to descend to the lowest point in the
facility.
They’re even given a working flashlight
and a defensive nightstick to create the illusion
that the Foundation expects them to ever return
from the depths.
Little do they know, they also have a tiny
transmitter sewn into their jumpsuit.
This broadcasts a frequency that will attract
an eager SCP-3280 to the D-Class’ location,
like a dinner bell only it can hear.
The file specifies that SCP-3280 always prefers
live prey.
“Well, at least that explains the dead D-Class
in Sub Level 2,” you think, hoping that
it’ll somehow overwhelm the dizziness you’re
feeling, or the nagging pain in your gut.
You read on.
Somehow, the file’s tone becomes even more
severe.
It says that failure to maintain the containment
of SCP-3280 will not only trigger a lockdown,
it will always call in the intervention of
two different Mobile Task Forces: MTF Iota-12,
“The Silencers”, and Tau-4, also known
as “Water, Water Everywhere.”
If twelve hours pass from the point of initial
containment breach, and the O5 Council hasn’t
been given the “all clear” signal by one
of these teams, preparation begins for an
imminent XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
Just reading the words sends you into a cold
sweat.
“End of the World?
What on Earth is this creature?”
Finally, you reach the description.
You get to find out what this horrifying entity
actually is.
But the last thing you expect is for the first
sentence in the file to read, “SCP-3280
is a sapient entity composed of a fluid physically
identical to water, capable of traveling roughly
two and a half kilometers per hour.”
It’s water.
It’s literally a living, thinking blob of
water.
As you read on, the concerning details pile
up: Any water that the anomalous SCP-3280
water touches, it integrates into its own
mass.
But any time water is separated from this
mass, it remains anomalous, and continues
to act independently.
When the creature was first discovered, it
was a mere 66.4 liters in volume.
Now, it’s around twenty five hundred.
The water infected by SCP-3280 is hostile
to all humans, and not just in a defensive
manner.
SCP-3280 will actively seek out human prey.
And when it finds them, it forces its mass
into any available bodily orifice, including
the victim’s pores.
This can happen in such a subtle manner that
you may not even notice yourself being infiltrated.
But below this, the file has a list of symptoms
for those experiencing 3280 infiltration:
loss of motor control, weakening of the micturition
reflex, visual hallucinations, and abdominal
pain.
As you read the words, your stomach gives
another painful churn.
Almost like something is moving around inside
you.
It’s all coming together.
You read on.
The file states that SCP-3280 is so difficult
to contain because it exhibits claustrophobic
tendencies.
Any time it’s placed inside a container,
whether organic or inorganic, it escapes with
pressurized water jets that travel at over
255 miles per hour.
If the water is inside a human, it may literally
explode out of them, killing them in the process.
Your jittering eyes turn to the gutted body
of Security Officer Nichols.
It all makes sense now.
Everything is becoming clear as the pain in
your stomach builds in its intensity.
The file goes on to say that if ever SCP-3280
escapes Sub Level 2, it may be impossible
to contain again.
If 3280 ever escaped the site proper, it would
indeed cause an XK-Class End of the World
Scenario to unfold, as 3280 merged with our
water cycle and destroyed all of humanity
on a global scale.
It would become truly impossible for anyone
to escape.
You can’t read any more.
The pain in your stomach is unbearable.
You jerk from your seat and stumble out into
the hall, doubled over in agony.
You can feel it pulsing in there.
Fighting its way out.
It must have gotten in through the filthy
mop water you were drinking.
You didn’t even know it, but your fate has
been sealed for hours.
You’ve been a dead man walking.
The hum of pain builds in your ears and renders
you almost deaf.
All you can hear is the patter of rain and
the distant thunder.
You collapse against the glass, feeling the
coolness of it against the skin of your face.
And in that moment, you see the water droplets
on the window pane reverse direction.
They’re slithering up the glass towards
your face in defiance of gravity.
Then, you realize it’s already over, and
not just for you.
SCP-3280 has escaped.
It’s out there, and it’s going to drown
the entire world.
As you collapse to your knees and prepare
to be torn apart from the inside, your final
thought is that at least you won’t be alive
to see it.
Have you ever had a nightmare that you’re
running down a long, dark hallway, getting
chased by something you can’t see?
The thing behind you isn’t fast, but that
doesn’t matter.
You can’t run forever, and the thing knows
it.
It is a patient predator.
It toys with its food.
At first, you move with speed and rhythm.
The metallic scraping noise behind you grows
quieter.
You run and stumble through the dark.
Your muscles start to ache and your lungs
burn.
Your pace slows.
It’s still coming.
You can hear the scraping getting louder.
You start to panic.
It’s completely dark.
You don’t know where you’re running or
even what you’re running from.
All you know - as you bump against the walls
and the sharp corners that rush towards you
- is that you can’t run forever.
You trip, fall, and pain explodes through
your leg as your knee shatters on the concrete
ground.
That scraping is getting louder.
You can barely breathe.
You can’t run anymore with your injury.
There’s no way to stop what’s coming.
There is no escape.
The scraping is right behind you.
You scream.
And then… you wake up.
Your heart is pounding like thunder in your
chest and your sheets are soaked with sweat,
but you’re safe.
You’re out of those awful, dark hallways.
But what if this wasn’t just a nightmare?
What if this scenario was real, and there
was no escape from the horror chasing you
in the darkness?
That’s what it’s like to have a close
encounter with SCP-1918, a sadistic, sentient
object that loves playing twisted games with
its prey.
But this monster never plays fair, and even
worse, it’s always just a simple door away.
It might even be hiding behind a door near
you, right now, waiting to start a game with
its new playmate.
But soon you’ll understand why some doors
should never, ever be opened, and why some
games are better left unplayed.
x
SCP - 1918 is an anomaly with two parts: SCP-1918
itself, and SCP-1918-2, the monster’s underground
lair.
The duo are a match made in hell, as the chambers
and hallways of 1918-2 are perfectly tailored
to 1918’s violent hobbies.
Nobody knows how long this anomaly has been
operating, but it’s probably behind countless
disappearances.
After all, 1918 has a habit of breaking its
toys...
The nightmare began in a small town in Maine,
with a population of only 226 people.
But that population was about to get lower.
People in the town began to report strange
noises at night, a droning, metal-on-concrete
scraping noise, like someone dragging a lead
pipe along the ground.
At first, people just ignored the sound.
It was all in their heads, or maybe just a
faulty oven or a washing machine on the fritz.
Anything that would allow them to forget about
the noise and get on with their daily lives.
But the noises were coming from below.
They could be heard out on the streets, most
audibly near manholes and sewer grates.
People started feeling unsafe in their homes.
The noises were spooking animals and children.
People were losing sleep.
That scraping they all tried to ignore was
beginning to get to them all.
Letters, emails, and angry phone calls to
the town council were piling up.
Something had to be done before the whole
town went crazy with fear.
The mayor authorized four utility workers
to investigate the source of the noise at
a local sewage treatment facility.
Considering the scraping was loudest near
the sewer grates, everyone just assumed that
whatever was causing all this must be connected
to the sewers.
Four utility workers were sent to investigate
the facility, only to find that the machinery
on site was working just fine.
The source of the problems must have been
coming directly from the underground sewer-lines
themselves.
The four workers, equipped with headlamps,
descended into a long service tunnel that
fed into the sewer system.
As they passed deeper into the tunnel, the
darkness around them became thicker.
It was a tangible presence that drowned out
the light of their headlamps, similar to the
anomalous phenomenon exhibited by SCP - 087.
When the utility workers tried to turn back,
they discovered another impossibility: It
seemed that the tunnel behind them had become
a solid concrete wall.
They were trapped, but where?
It was too dark to tell.
Confused and terrified, the four men stuck
together, attempting to find a way out.
It was too dark to see their hand in front
of their face, so all they could do was navigate
slowly by feeling the walls around them.
These walls felt oddly...crusty.
There was a kind of faint, metallic stench
hanging in the air, too, like old blood.
Something horrible had happened here, and
something horrible was about to happen again.
All they could do was keep moving and try
to stay calm.
Eventually, after hours of pawing at walls
in the dark, they found an open doorway.
One by one, they filed inside, only to feel
blinded when bright, white ceiling lights
suddenly switched on.
The room was all white, and filled with pipes,
large and small, running from wall to wall.
Just then one of the utility workers let out
an ear-splitting scream and pointed towards
the doorway.
His colleagues turned, and gasped in shock.
There was something outside the door, and
it was staring at them.
The object filled up almost the entire doorway.
It seemed like a demonic hobby horse, made
from a black-and-white, candy-striped metal
pole with a crude plastic head on top.
The head looked like a clown’s, with a wide,
toothy grin, but no visible eyes.
It was SCP-1918.
The utility workers were frozen as the object
leaned forward slightly, and slithered into
the room, the bottom of the metal pipe scraping
against the ground.
It was the exact same scraping noise that’d
been haunting the concerned townsfolk up above.
This was the thing behind it all.
And as the object moved, its metal pole started
to scrape words into the ground: Tik Tak Tow
None of the four utility workers were ever
seen again.
It didn’t take long for the SCP Foundation
to descend upon this quiet Maine town and
pick up the pieces.
All relevant officials were provided amnestics,
and cover stories were created for the disappearances
of the four utility workers.
The Foundation also commandeered the sewage
treatment facility that held the entrance
to SCP-1918-2, replacing all key roles at
the facility with undercover Foundation personnel.
SCP-1918 was given a Euclid' classification
due to the fixed nature of its hunting grounds,
and then the real research began.
The Foundation soon made some disturbing discoveries.
Entrances into the SCP-1918-2 area didn’t
follow any kind of logic.
The hunting ground of SCP-1918 can be entered
from almost any location, if you’re unlucky
enough.
There are currently 9 known entrances, including
5 sewage grates, 3 utility shafts located
in a sewage facility, and 1 toilet.
And these are just the ones the Foundation
knows about.
There are a huge number of ways to enter SCP-1918-2,
but to this day, nothing has ever been able
to leave.
SCP-1918-2 is contained twenty meters below
the streets of this unassuming Maine town.
Personnel, aside from Foundation-approved
D-class guinea pigs. are refused entrance.
Researchers have mapped out the layout of
1918-2 through seismic imaging of SCP-1918’s
movements.
There are 18 identical room pairs in SCP-1918-2,
or 9 compound rooms.
Rooms are differentiated between a '1' room
and a '2' room by crude carvings on the floors
outside of the individual rooms.
SCP-1918-2 is symmetrical, with half a meter
wide paths circling each compound room.
The only deviations to this construction are
the location of entrances on the sides of
each individual room, which vary randomly
while the location is “active.”
What exactly does SCP-1918 do in this private
little maze?
It plays games, of course.
Its two favorites - as indicated by the words
it scrapes onto the ground - are “Tik Tak
Tow” and “Memoree”
In Tik Tak Tow, 1918 moves to each “1”
room, leaving behind "X" markings on the floors
if the room is not already marked with an
"O" in a manner similar to a game of "Tic
Tac Toe''.
How a victim is meant to accomplish making
a mark or understand this process is unknown,
as no aides are given.
Blood is commonly used by victims to make
their markings, hence the rusty smell in many
of the rooms.
In Memoree, the trapped victim is rendered
unconscious by blunt force, presumably from
SCP-1918.
The subject regains consciousness in a random
section of the facility.
Success is marked by finding a “1” room
identical to the central room.
This event seems to possess a time limit,
as the subject is pursued by SCP-1918 throughout
the halls of the facility.
The subject "wins'' by marking the correct
room with an "O".
What happens if you win or lose these games?
It’s important to note that SCP-1918 is
very competitive, and doesn’t play fair.
If you win, the object will merely accuse
you of cheating, and start a new game.
This will happen again and again, until eventually…
you lose.
And when you do?
Well, take the horrifying encounter D-Class
personnel member D-2934 had with SCP-1918.
Wearing video and audio equipment, D-2934
was led into SCP-1918-2 by Foundation researchers.
When he eventually found his way to the central
room, 1918 challenged him to a game of Tik
Tak Tow.
And, against all odds, D-2934 won the game.
But 1918 didn’t take kindly to that.
It accused D-2934 of cheating, carving its
accusations into the ground before challenging
him to a deadly game of Memoree.
After hours of chasing, D-2934 eventually
lost his mind and was backed into a corner
by 1918.
As the object made its way towards him, he
panicked, ripped a pipe from the wall, and
began smashing 1918’s head.
As the plastic cracked under the force of
the blows, Foundation scientists could see
real brains inside.
D-2934 screamed, and the video feed cut off.
When the video turned back on some time later,
1918 stared into the camera with a different
head mounted atop its metal pole.
One that, just a few hours earlier, had belonged
to the unfortunate D-2934.
If there’s one lesson to be learned from
this terrifying anomaly, it’s that there
truly is no escape from SCP-1918.
Imagine this - it’s summer vacation and
you're a kid.
You and your friends are playing in the woods
near your neighborhood, just like you've been
doing most days during the break from school.
One day, you spot a treehouse.
It’s not that high off the ground and it's
very simply built from leaves, grass, and
scraps of wood.
You and your friends are curious, so you decide
to check it out.
Upon investigation, you find a kid in there.
He says his name is Billy, and this is his
treehouse.
You don't recognize him from school, but you
figure he must just be new in town.
He asks if he can join your group, and, wanting
to be nice to the new kid, you tell him “okay.”
You spend the rest of the day playing with
him - games like hide and seek, tag, and red
rover, until it's time for everyone to go
home for dinner.
Strangely, Billy doesn't seem to leave, he
just stays in his treehouse.
For the rest of the week, playing with Billy
and his treehouse become a regular fixture
of your daily routine, but oddly enough, he
never comes to hang out at any of your houses,
and you never seem to see him anywhere else
but in the woods.
One day, however, he decides to invite one
of your friends, Amy, to hang out with him
at the treehouse alone.
You think nothing of it, but after that point,
you never see Billy again.
It’s a couple of weeks before you and your
friends see Amy again, and when you do, she
appears off somehow.
She seems to be spending a lot of time in
that treehouse.
Billy has disappeared, but you and Amy and
the rest of the kids keep meeting up to play
together in the woods.
One day Amy pulls you aside, she wants you
to come meet with her tomorrow at the treehouse…
alone.
This is typically how an SCP-974 infestation
begins - with a mysterious new kid inviting
a group of friends to hang out in his crudely
made treehouse.
But as you might have guessed, this kid isn't
a kid - he's SCP-974, a carnivorous monster
that only looks like a human child.
It can live on small woodland animals, but
its preferred prey… is kids between the
ages of 6 and 12, taking the phrase 'you are
what you eat' to the next level.
The entity will install itself in an area
with a sufficient amount of trees, in proximity
to a decent population of children.
It will then construct a crude treehouse to
serve as its nest, and begin befriending groups
of between 2 and 5 children.
The creature will engage in normal outdoor
games and allow its new 'friends' to come
and go as they please, building the trust
of its newfound playmates.
But then, after about a week, it will select
its victim.
SCP-974 will single out one member of the
group and invite them to the treehouse alone.
Whether they accept or deny the invitation
is irrelevant, because this is the point where
SCP-974 will strike, subduing and then devouring
that child.
After doing so, the creature will disappear
from the area, going into a state of hibernation
for roughly 12 days.
During that time, it goes through a period
of metamorphosis, transforming from whoever
it looked like before into an exact likeness
of the child it just consumed.
SCP-974 will continue this cycle of selecting
and catching prey until there are no children
left in the surrounding area.
While it's initially friendly to children,
SCP-974 has an intense fear of any older human
beings.
The mere presence of a person older than 13
is enough to trigger the creature's fight
or flight response, and it will run away if
it sees any adults coming.
When running isn't an option, SCP-974 will
resort to violence to defend itself.
Despite its looks, SCP-974 is much stronger,
faster, and more resistant to damage than
a child, and it has been known to completely
rip adults apart in situations where it felt
threatened and cornered.
SCP-974 does not appear to be affected by
bullets or striking weapons, and the only
reliable way to put down an instance seems
to be with fire.
When infestations are discovered in the wild,
the normal SCP foundation protocol is to attempt
to capture the creature, but if deadly force
is required, agents will set fire to the creature's
nest and a portion of the surrounding area
until it has been confirmed dead, before covering
up the destruction as the result of a regular
forest fire.
The SCP foundation was able to capture one
instance of SCP-974 and place it in containment,
hoping that having one in captivity would
provide insight into the creature's origins.
It was placed in a lightly wooded enclosure
at Zoological Reserve Site 16, where it immediately
started constructing multiple treehouse nests
from the plant life it found.
Initially, the containment of SCP-974 involved
offering the creature live human prey.
Once every 3 months, a group of 4 children
would be brought in, in accordance with Protocol
12.
The children would be given room and board
in on-site barracks, and encouraged to explore
the enclosure and play with SCP-974.
If 974 had not selected a victim within 5
days, the group of children would be sent
away and a new group would be introduced.
This system worked for a few years, but as
you might expect, the Ethics Committee had
a problem with the practice of offering up
live children to a deadly anomaly.
Now, as of January 1st, 2015, the team at
Zoological Reserve Site 16 are no longer able
to evoke Protocol 12 in order to acquire children.
Attempts to use another SCP - SCP-1680, a
collection of clones of a missing 8-year-old
boy - failed, as SCP-974 refused to eat them.
The procedures then changed to only allow
small animals to be introduced into the enclosure
as prey.
While it might seem like this was a good idea
that would stop SCP-974 from killing any more
children, like a lot of seemingly good changes
to containment procedures in the Foundation,
this well intentioned move would ultimately
have deadly consequences.
SCP-974 at first seemed to behave normally
despite being denied its favorite food.
But then, on August 16th, 2015, while on their
weekly sweep of the enclosure, patrol teams
found that 974 had destroyed all of the treehouses
it had built in its time in containment.
The SCP itself was also nowhere to be found.
There was something new in the enclosure though,
a small oval of disturbed soil.
A geological team was called in, and through
ground penetrating radar, it was found that
there was a humanoid figure buried there,
curled up in a fetal position.
This couldn't be SCP-974, could it?
The figure was much too long and thin to be
anything resembling a human child.
But it had to be SCP-974 - it was the only
living thing in the enclosure.
The scientists were intrigued, and they theorized
that the SCP might have been entering a new
life stage.
Further scans were conducted over the next
10 days.
During that time, the creature never moved
from its position, though it did continue
to grow.
It seemed like it was absorbing nutrients
from the surrounding soil.
The team decided to exhume the creature to
examine it.
When they dug it up, they found that SCP-974
had stretched out, now measuring 220 cm in
length and weighing just 37.4 kilograms.
It had no features or orifices of any kind
anywhere on its body, and its now pale white
skin was covered in some kind of sticky mucus
that, when examined, was found to contain
a previously undiscovered enzyme.
The creature was alive, but barely.
It wasn't breathing, and its heartbeat was
extremely slow, almost to the point of being
undetectable.
SCP-974 was examined for an additional four
weeks, after which it died, and was sent for
dissection.
Some of the scientists and researchers at
Zoological Site 16 were disappointed to hear
about 974's death.
As vicious and feral as the creature was,
they'd developed a certain fondness for it,
and its many little treehouses.
Luckily, it wouldn't be too much longer until
a new specimen was obtained.
On October 16th, 2016, a group of no less
than 7 instances of SCP-974 were discovered
near a major American city.
The containment team was forced to kill 6
of the anomalies in the attempts to capture
them, but one instance survived and was taken
to Zoological Site 16.
As was mandated, the area was burned and Foundation
counterintelligence disseminated a cover story
about a forest fire caused by an improperly
extinguished campfire.
The new SCP-974 was, like the original one,
placed in the enclosure and denied human prey.
Also like the first one, this 974 buried itself
after being denied its preferred meals for
several months.
The decision was made to leave the SCP underground
longer than in the first instance, to see
what it might become if this developmental
stage wasn't interrupted.
On January 25th, 2017, the creature finally
dug itself free from the earth.
Now designated SCP-974-A, it was far more
aggressive than any instance of 974 had ever
been before.
As soon as it was free from the dirt, it made
a beeline straight for the nearest monitoring
station.
It ripped the roof off and tore the 6 team
members stationed there to shreds in just
90 seconds.
When the response team arrived 15 minutes
later, only 12% of the human remains were
able to be recovered.
But, strangely enough, it at first seemed
that one of the team had been spared.
Georgia Stone, one of the monitoring team,
was severely injured, but apparently in a
stable condition.
Disoriented, she approached the response team,
begging for assistance and urging them to
take her out of the enclosure.
But the team was skeptical - they knew that
SCP-974 could become an exact copy of any
child it consumed, so it followed that the
fully-grown SCP-974-A might be able to copy
adults.
They asked Georgia questions in order to confirm
her identity, but she was unable to answer
them.
Having been found out, SCP-974, still mimicking
Georgia, attacked the response team.
They'd been armed with flamethrowers, but
unfortunately, on top of its resistance to
damage, the adult form of 974 didn't seem
to be afraid of, or harmed by, fire.
The team was at a loss for how to kill this
thing, or even subdue it long enough to get
out safely.
SCP-974-A was tearing through the members
of the team like they were made of paper.
Thinking quickly, one member of the response
team, a guard named Emilio, pulled out one
of his standard issue Foundation hand grenades.
When SCP-974-A came at him, he pulled the
pin and, holding the grenade, shoved his arm
into the creature's open mouth.
While the explosion destroyed Emilio's arm,
it didn't even break the skin of SCP-974-A.
However, it did result in serious damage to
its internal organs, which finally killed
it.
Following its death, an autopsy was conducted,
revealing enough about the creature that a
new file of effective methods of extermination
was able to be created.
After this event, the protocols for SCP-974
containment were completely overhauled.
Any instances of SCP-974-A seen in the wild
are to be killed as quickly as possible.
More disturbingly though, the ethics committee
rescinded their previous decision, and any
instances of 974 that are brought into containment
are to be provided with human prey again.
Letting SCP-974 kill children might not be
a very humane way of keeping it contained,
but given how much more aggressive and hard
to kill this SCP's adult form is, any option
that stops the creature's metamorphosis from
happening is likely the best option in the
long run.
So remember: If ever you’re out in the woods
and see a crudely constructed treehouse, perhaps
think twice about how innocent it is.
There could be something hungry lurking inside…
The
first thing that tipped the Foundation
off to SCP-087’s presence were the reports
of numerous unexplained disappearances on
campus.
There were plenty of rumors about what might
be behind them, but Field Agents suspected
that the true source of the vanishing would
be something beyond civilian imagination.
All anyone knew for sure was that everyone
who had gone missing was last seen in a certain
administrative building on the university
grounds, and that the disappearances only
seemed to happen when the elevator was out.
The campus was soon flooded with Foundation
agents, creating a barrier around the administrative
building, and the presumed habitat of SCP
- 087.
Nobody else could get in, and hopefully, whatever
was inside couldn’t get out.
One of the Foundation’s lead scientists
was flown in to consult on the investigation.
What could have been behind all those students
disappearing?
The doctor’s preliminary interviews with
university staff who worked in the building
yielded some interesting details: Strange
noises, like banging and even a faint, shrill
crying, would be heard from a door that lead
to a no longer used stairway in Hallway 3B.
Staff in the building had no reason to ever
take these stairs, especially considering
how many of them reported a strange sense
of unease when just standing outside the door.
The only reason someone might take those stairs
is due to…Elevator malfunctions.
In that instant, the doctor had put it all
together.
The staff they interviewed had their memory
wiped with Amnetics – special chemicals
used by the Foundation with the power to delete
human memories.
The Foundation only used them for staff or
civilians who had confirmed contact with an
SCP, and the doctor knew that they had a live
one on their hands.
The staircase.
There was something terribly wrong with that
staircase, and it was the SCP Foundation’s
job to find out what – before it made anybody
else disappear.
This is the story of SCP – 087, otherwise
known as The Endless Staircase, and the three
doomed journeys down into its murky depths.
The doctor was more than eager to begin research
into the staircase, and its frightening, anomalous
properties.
After all, you don’t claw your way up to
being one of the Foundation’s key researchers
without being brave, and perhaps just a little
bit deranged.
As was standard, once a perimeter was secured
around the staircase, the good doctor requested
a selection of D-Class personnel for testing.
For those not in the know, D-Class is the
Foundation’s polite way of saying “cannon
fodder.”
The doctor was sent three D-Class prisoners
for use in his investigation of SCP – 087.
The first, D-8432, was – according to official
documentation on the incident – a “43-year
old male of average build and appearance and
unremarkable psychological background.”
This man once worked for the Foundation in
a more official capacity, but he was given
the often-deadly demotion to D-Class due to
a dangerous mistake handling SCP – 682 that
lead to the deaths of several other agents.
Now, it looked like it would be his turn.
The doctor explained his mission to him: Explore
the staircase, gather data, help us find out
exactly what we’re dealing with here.
If you come back alive, there may even be
a promotion in it for you.
And with that promise, D-8432 was given his
load-out: a 75-watt flood lamp with battery
power capable of lasting 24 hours, an audio
headset, and a handheld camcorder fitted with
a transmission stream.
D-8432 was then pushed through the door in
Hallway 3B, and out onto the staircase.
According to declassified Foundation files
describing the staircase, “SCP-087 is an
unlit platform staircase.
Stairs descend on a 38-degree angle for 13
steps before reaching a semi-circular platform
of approximately 3 meters in diameter.
Descent direction rotates 180 degrees at each
platform.
The design of SCP-087 limits subjects to a
visual range of approximately 1.5 flights.”
But in D-8432’s mind, “unlit” really
didn’t seem like the right word.
He would have chosen “all-consuming darkness.”
Despite carrying a powerful 75-watt lamp,
D-8432 was only capable of partially lighting
the platform he was standing on – and the
illumination only stretched down nine of the
thirteen steps to the next platform.
When D-8432 observed how little help his lamp
was giving him, he was instructed to shine
it out of the doorway into Hallway 3B.
When he did so, the light seemed to shine
far further than it ever could in SCP – 087.
Already, the beginning of anomalous activity
was obvious: Everywhere else, darkness is
just the absence of light.
In SCP – 087, darkness eats light.
It was like a tangible, black mass that only
a certain amount of light could survive, while
the rest just wouldn’t show.
D-8432 swallowed hard over a lump in his throat.
The door to Hallway 3B was closed behind him,
and he was ordered to descend.
Surviving to see that promotion was feeling
unlikely, but it’s not like he had a choice.
If he tried to escape SCP – 087 before he
was permitted, he’d be shot by SCP Foundation
Field Agents on the spot.
So he followed the high-ranking doctor’s
orders and began to descend the steps to the
next platform.
Nothing about the physical makeup of the staircase
itself seemed abnormal – the base and walls
were a very plain, dull concrete, with a metal
handrail.
The only thing that seemed unique about it
so far was the strange light-bending properties.
That was, until he reached the second platform
down and he heard it, a soft, echoing cry.
A child’s cry.
It was shrieks of panic, or maybe even pain,
echoing up from below.
He was asked why he had stopped, and he explained
the crying sound he’d been hearing.
It sounded like it was coming from far down
the stairs, maybe 200 meters below him.
He could just make out the words “please”,
help”, and “down here” coming from the
darkness.
But the team outside the stairwell couldn’t
hear anything, so they asked him to descend
further.
Another platform down, and they could hear
it too, the unmistakable cries of a terrified
child.
“Please”, “help”, and “down here.”
D-8432 was ordered to keep going and only
stop if he noticed changes to the visual environment
or in the sounds he was hearing.
D-8432, knowing his life was on the line,
had to keep going, and descended another twenty
flights of stairs before stopping to remark
that the sounds of the child hadn’t gotten
any closer.
They still sounded just as far away as when
he’d first heard them.
He was told his observations were noted, and
pressured to continue.
Within half an hour, D-8432 had descended
a full fifty floors, with no sign of a bottom
in sight.
Somehow the volume of the child’s crying
had remained consistent throughout, as if
it was moving away from D-8432 at the same
rate he was descending.
At this point, D-8432 reported that he was
feeling uneasy.
The doctor said that this was understandable,
given the circumstances.
He’d been watching what little there was
to see over a live video feed the entire time,
and something about the truly bottomless nature
of the staircase, and the ever-elusive crying,
was undeniably eerie.
But things were about to really take a turn
for the worst.
As D-8432 stepped forward towards the next
set of stairs, he froze.
There was something on the platform below
him, barely illuminated by the light of his
75-watt bulb.
It was a face.
Vaguely human in size and shape, but with
a few terrifying differences: it had greyish
skin, and no mouth, nostrils, or pupils.
And yet, D-8432 could feel that this thing
was making eye contact with him.
He couldn’t move, trapped in this thing’s
piercing gaze.
In an instant, the face jerked forwards, suddenly
only about a foot away from D-8432’s face
– eyes staring into his own.
D-8432 screamed and ran, scaling all fifty
flights in an astonishing eighteen minutes,
before charging out into Hallway 3B.
There, he collapsed from the exhaustion and
the fear of what he’d just seen.
Upon reviewing the footage, the strange face
was designated “SCP-087-1.”
Fascinating.
It was time for a second experiment.
The doctor just had to know more.
The second test subject was D-9035, a 28-year-old
male with a history of aggravated assaults
against women.
He was given the same loadout as his predecessor,
except this time with an even more powerful
100-watt bulb.
He was also given 100 small LED lights that
had adhesive backs and a battery life of approximately
3 weeks, with which they intended to permanently
illuminate SCP – 087.
However, despite the extra wattage of his
bulb, he still couldn’t illuminate beyond
the ninth step.
SCP – 087 wouldn’t allow it.
Having no idea of the horrors that lurked
below him, he descended on the doctor’s
orders, and began fixing the LEDs to walls
of each platform he passed.
The LED always illuminated the landing, but
the light couldn’t pass the first step on
either side.
The flights of stairs themselves would remain
in perpetual darkness.
After the second flight, D-9035 noticed the
same crying D-8432 had heard and became uneasy.
Just like before, as D-9035 descended, the
volume of the crying didn’t seem to increase,
as if for every step he descended, the source
of the crying descended one, too, keeping
them at a constant 200 metres apart.
Still, he was ordered to continue his descent
and the placing of LED’s even as his paranoia
grew.
When he reached the 51s floor, he observed
damage to the wall and steps – sections
appeared to have been smashed to rubble by
an extreme force.
As he descended past the broken step, he only
felt his fear, anxiety, and paranoia grow.
The doctor made a note of the fact that SCP
– 087 seemed to cause instances of anxiety
and terror in its occupants, even before they
encountered SCP – 087 – 1.
As D-9035 reached platform 89 – a full 350
meters under the initial platform – he stopped
dead in his tracks, and saw something staring
up at him from the platform below.
That same terrible, grey face, with those
dead, white eyes.
He was encouraged to stay calm and try to
get better footage of the face, but it charged
for him and D-9035 ran for his life.
He ascended the staircase at a staggering
pace, even passing out from exhaustion and
remaining motionless for 14 minutes half way.
When D-9035 finally gathered the strength
to get up, he scrambled back to Hallway 3B
and fell into a state of catatonia.
He remains unresponsive to all external stimuli
to this day, just staring off into the distance
with a haunted expression.
Almost like he’s still there in the hallway.
The doctor wanted to conduct one more test
before he ordered SCP – 087 shut off from
the world forever, and it was the most terrifying
of all.
The final subject was D-9884, a 23-year-old
woman with a history of depression and the
use of excessive force.
The doctor had hoped that D-9884 would travel
the deepest yet, and so, he gave her the additional
supplies of a backpack containing 3.75 litres
of water, 15 nutrient bars, and 1 thermal
blanket.
As far as the Foundation was concerned, she
was in this for the long haul.
But none of them had any idea quite how right
they were.
When D-9884 entered SCP – 087, all the lights
from the previous expedition had disappeared.
Still, she was ordered to go deeper.
She heard the crying of the mysterious child
– if it was even a child at all – and
again she was ordered to go deeper.
At the 496th landing, even as D-9884 seemed
to slip into a state of mortal terror, once
again she was ordered to go even deeper.
Every moment, he was hoping to get a better
look at the face of SCP – 087 – 1.
And when D-9884 finally broke, and fled back
upstairs, he did.
The face appeared but this time it was mere
inches behind her, staring directly into the
camera with its blank eyes – startling even
this veteran of the supernatural.
The face appearing caused D-9884 to panic
and flee, but instead of going back up the
stairs to safety, she went deeper down the
staircase in an attempt to escape it.
Deeper, and deeper, and deeper, until her
video feed cut out.
D-9884 was never seen again.
In the aftermath of the tests, the SCP was
classified as Euclid – it may have been
dangerous, but at least it was easy to contain.
The door to Hallway 3B was replaced with one
made out of reinforced steel, with an electro-release
lock mechanism.
It has been disguised to resemble a janitorial
closet consistent with the rest of the building.
The lock won’t release unless a classified
number of electrical volts are applied, while
the key is turned counter clockwise.
And after a few inches of foam insulation
were applied to the inner side of the door,
staff at the building never again reported
hearing strange noises.
As for the fates of those lost within the
endless turning flights and platforms of SCP
– 087, we may never know.
But one can only assume it isn’t pleasant.
Every neighborhood has a house like it.
You can probably picture it: That old, decrepit
building on the very end of the street; it
was there when you moved in, and it’ll still
be there when you move out.
All sorts of salacious rumors spread about
houses like this - “it’s a drug lab”,
“it’s a hideout for fugitives”, “it’s
haunted” - but these are all just stories...right?
Some of these houses contain real nightmares,
though.
Nightmares like SCP-136.
There’s a grain of truth in every story,
and even lies can reveal certain facts about
their tellers.
That’s why the SCP Foundation takes reports
of so-called neighborhood “haunted houses”
seriously, and performs regular checks on
such buildings to see if any of them are actually
the real deal.
Children can have wild imaginations - but
when children living on the same street, years
apart, with no reason to have been in contact
with one another, all start reporting an eerily
similar apparition in that creepy, old house.
And when the stories go beyond just getting
freaked out, and delve into truly life-altering,
traumatic, paralytic terror… then the Foundation
really can’t afford not to look into it.
One otherwise-quiet morning in a sleepy American
town, a convoy of fumigation and asbestos
removal trucks pulled in, surrounding that
creepy old house at the end of the street.
Residents were probably thinking, “It’s
about time someone tore that old death-trap
down”, as people in protective suits spilled
into the building.
These were, of course, Foundation Field agents,
who would perform a routine sweep around every
room, and fully catalogue the place.
It looked like a pretty typical abandoned
house.
Peeling wallpaper, dusty, rotten furniture,
all the trash and rubble that seems to appear
in the absence of human life.
The full sweep took little more than an hour,
but towards the end of the observation period,
Agent Sims - a field agent posted in the former
children’s bedroom - began acting strangely.
He posed a question over the team’s shared
radio frequency.
“Hey, can anyone else hear that laughter?”
Confused, the other people on the team responded
that no, they could not hear any laughter.
A few other agents came to check on the room,
but they didn’t hear any laughter in there
either.
Even though Agent Sims appeared visibly uncomfortable,
there was no identifiable source for this
discomfort.
The other agents left him so they could continue
investigating the rest of the house.
Other than one agent’s fraying nerves, there
didn’t appear to actually be anything anomalous
about the house.
Then Agent Sims screamed, and jumped out of
the second story window of the house, sailing
down towards the ground and fracturing his
spine on impact.
What could have made him do that?
We’re talking about an SCP Foundation field
agent here - a highly-trained individual,
hand-picked by the Foundation, to observe
and track terrifying and potentially deadly
anomalies out in the field.
What could he possibly have seen in that decrepit
old house that would lead him to believe leaping
to his death was a preferable alternative
to facing it?
This was a question that the Foundation absolutely
had to get an answer to.
They intensified their search on the child’s
bedroom as the body of Agent Sims was carted
away.
That’s when they found the object that they
would later deem as SCP-136-1, a little rag
doll made of old cloth.
The kind of thing you could easily imagine
getting carted around by some ragamuffin child
at the turn of the last century.
This was the only object of interest in the
entire room, so it was tagged, bagged, and
taken back to the nearest Foundation containment
facility for further testing.
They had no idea what they were about to unleash.
When the doll was first brought into its containment
chamber, one particular scientist on the research
team - Dr. Meyers, a headstrong young researcher
freshly farmed from a prestigious university
- took a morbid interest in the doll.
Something about it, even in the absence of
readily apparent anomalous effects, made her
feel oddly uncomfortable.
The doll seemed to carry a vague aura of doom.
Was this what made Agent Sims act the way
he had?
Or was this only the beginning?
A D-Class was brought in for the first wave
of testing.
The unfortunate former-arsonist was forced
to simply stand around in the room with the
doll and wait until something interesting
happened, and for twenty minutes, no anomalous
activity was reported.
Then, the D-Class began frantically looking
around the room, like a frightened animal.
Dr. Meyers, who had been observing the test,
radioed in and asked what was happening.
“It’s this laughter.
This weird, freaky laughter, like some crazy
lady is in here.
I can’t see her, though.
Can any of you see her?
Can any of you hear that?”
They couldn’t see or hear anything.
According to all their monitors, it was just
a lonely D-Class, standing around in an otherwise
empty room with nothing but the ragdoll.
Five minutes after the D-Class reported hearing
the eerie laughter, he collapsed to the ground,
shrieking like a maniac and crawling away
from something he couldn’t see.
He was emitting the desperate screams of a
man who truly believed something was about
to take his life, but nothing was there.
He backed into the corner of the room, gibbering
incoherently and scratching desperately at
the walls until his fingernails were ripping
off, leaving bloody traces behind.
In the end, a pair of guards entered the chamber
and had to drag him out.
The D-Class had urinated in fear, and seemed
to have temporarily lost the use of his legs
from sheer panic.
He was out of commission for several hours
afterwards, breaking into on-and-off screaming
fits whenever someone approached him.
Upon reviewing the footage of the experiment,
Dr. Meyers noticed something strange: The
moment that the D-Class had begun screaming,
the doll had disappeared from the room.
It only rematerialized in its previous position
when the D-Class was finally dragged from
the room.
Eventually, the D-Class became lucid enough
to be properly interviewed about his experience.
He said that after first hearing the laughter,
a sense of overpowering dread had begun building
within him.
Five minutes later, that was when the entity
- later dubbed SCP-136-2 - first appeared.
The vision that appeared to him could generously
be described as human, but it was a little
too tall to really qualify.
The monster appeared to be female, but like
a freakish, carnival-house-of-mirrors exaggeration
of what one thinks of being female - long,
flowing hair, large breasts, and a Barbie-Doll-Thin
waist.
She looked like the nightmarish doodle of
a hormonal teen boy come to life, with a face
twisted into a rictus grin somewhere between
arousal and agony, showing way too many teeth.
The creature was nude, and posed provocatively,
but it was anything but appealing.
The D-Class reported that just seeing it was
the most frightening experience of his life…
and then it started moving.
It was slowly floating through the air towards
him like a vengeful ghost, that painful smile
getting wider as it drew closer to him.
The D-Class could only describe the whole
experience as feeling like death itself was
coming towards him.
When the creature was finally looming over
him as he cowered in the corner, it opened
its tooth-lined jaws and let out a long, piercing
shriek, before disappearing.
In the following weeks, the D-Class was kept
for testing.
He experienced severe night terrors every
single night afterwards - all of them related
to SCP-136.
Further tests looked into the doll itself,
but there didn’t seem to be anything anomalous
about its construction.
It appeared to be made from the kind of plain,
non-anomalous materials you’d expect from
any doll of this variety.
Though occasionally, the exact materials would
change, even between observers.
In addition to the most common “cloth”
variety, witnesses have reported the doll
being made of clay, wood, and metal, with
10% viewing the doll as male, with the rest
all agreeing that the doll is female.
The Foundation conducted a battery of tests
on the doll, just to make sure that the results
were largely consistent across all subjects.
Over 25 different subjects were tested on
SCP-136, all reporting roughly the same results:
Laughter after twenty minutes of observation,
a few minutes of silence, and then - according
to subject testimonials - the appearance of
the same grinning, naked apparition, inducing
a state of truly primal terror in its victims.
Interestingly, not all of the subjects were
D-Classes: Some were volunteering scientists
who were aware of the potential effects, but
let their morbid curiosity get the better
of them, thinking they would be prepared to
face whatever terrifying vision would manifest
from the doll.
But in every case, they were reduced to the
same screaming, traumatized wrecks.
But when a Foundation researcher named Dr.
Simon, the 25th subject of the SCP-136 experiments,
volunteered for testing, things took an even
more horrifying turn.
During the testing period, Dr. Simon had the
unusual experience of not actually seeing
the SCP-136-2 entity.
After being told how terrifying it was by
coworkers, he was a little disappointed that
he didn’t get to share their fears.
Later that day he went to get himself a warm
cup of coffee from the site’s employee break
room.
His coworkers became concerned when his coffee
mug dropped to the ground and shattered, as
Dr. Simon pointed into a nearby empty hallway
and began screaming.
He claimed that he could see her floating
down the hallway towards him, her face twisted
into that menacing grin.
As none of the other scientists could see
what Simon was seeing, they surrounded him
and attempted to calm him, assuming that he
was perhaps the victim of some kind of sudden,
psychotic break.
But minutes later, every scientist in the
break room collapsed and fell unconscious.
Not long after, they all began to wake back
up...Except Dr. Simon.
He had fallen into a coma, and died while
still on life support three days later.
It was the first report of SCP-136 causing
a death since Agent Sims’ unfortunate fall.
Dr. Meyers immediately requested that SCP-136
be reclassified from Euclid to Keter Class
so more resources could be allocated for its
containment.
Administration denied any changes to the containment
procedures of SCP-136, frustrating Dr. Meyers,
but little did she know that it was because
site administration had ulterior motives for
SCP-136.
No matter who they were, whether they were
the hardened killers of D-Class, the trained
soldiers of the Foundation field agent corps,
or jaded scientists who see any number of
horrors each week as part of their normal
jobs, SCP-136 had the unique ability to reduce
its victims to terrified wrecks.
In a move that feels decidedly more in line
with the Chaos Insurgency, site administration
had started using SCP-136 to assist in enhanced
interrogation with detained people of interest.
Even the toughest nuts to crack soon became
very talkative after the appearance of SCP-136-2
traumatized them for life.
Essentially, the administrators were making
a kind of deal with the devil: Allowing SCP-136
more free reign, in exchange for them gathering
valuable intel from these victims.
But as always, the problem with making deals
with the devil is that the devil is always
going to collect his due in the end.
Dr. Meyers’ warnings would continue to fall
upon deaf ears though, even as the creature’s
power seemed to grow.
Tests on D-Classes continued, with the entity
traumatizing a whole group at once during
one of these experiments.
However, when Dr. Meyers herself, along with
a few agents, entered the testing chamber
to drag out their twitching bodies, they all
fell unconscious.
When Dr. Meyers woke back up, three of the
D-Classes had fallen into comas like Dr. Simon,
and died shortly after.
Dr. Meyers pleaded with the administration
to terminate the doll, but her requests were
denied.
It was proving to be too valuable in its various
interrogations.
And besides, nobody was sure if the doll even
could be terminated.
Whenever it was damaged, it simply disappeared
and reappeared within a one meter radius.
The only thing that hadn’t been tried was
full vaporization, which Dr. Meyers’ superiors
refused to sign off on.
SCP-136 was here to stay.
Unfortunately, the same could not be said
for Dr. Meyers herself.
After one more unfortunate testing incident
where a D-Class disappeared entirely in what
seemed to be clear evidence of SCP-136’s
growing power, Dr. Meyers implored site administration
to reclassify the anomaly and slate it for
termination.
It was getting more powerful, more unstable,
and more dangerous.
But rather than terminate the anomalous ragdoll,
in the end all they did was remove Dr. Meyers
from the SCP-136 case.
With her gone, there was one less thing for
them to worry about as they gave more and
more victims to SCP-136, using its dark powers
to torture detained people of interest into
telling them everything they wanted to know.
But with the entity seeming to grow more powerful
with every victim, it seems very likely that
Dr. Meyers’ worst fears will come true,
and one day those controlling the terrifying
anomaly will find that they’re the ones
hearing a strange, evil laughter coming from
nowhere at all.
It was a beautiful September day, but Shaun
Taylor was trapped in his car in one of the
worst cases of gridlock he had ever seen.
He tried to look on the bright side though,
and while he was stuck in an unmoving car,
at least he had a pleasant view of the wide,
shimmering lake just off the road next to
him.
He was admiring the scene when tiny drops
of rain started landing on his windshield.
That’s funny, there wasn’t a cloud in
the sky a moment ago.
There was something off about the rain though.
It looked dirty, a rusty red color.
Was that… blood?
He didn’t have time to think about it, because
just then a thick, dense mist began to roll
over the lake.
A fog of blood.
Just off the side of the road, he could see
a huge silhouette rising out of the water.
Is that an old submarine?
What Shaun didn’t know was that he was about
to have an encounter with SCP - 1861, also
known as The HMS Wintersheimer - a ghostly
submarine with strange and terrifying effects.
Shaun and the other drivers stuck in traffic
that day were far from the first people to
have a dangerous brush with this legendary
vessel - according to SCP Foundation records,
the HMS Wintersheimer has been appearing since
as early as 1916.
The first recorded incident occurred in the
British seaside town of Innsmouth-On-Sea.
You won’t find this town on any maps, or
in the history books, and you’re about to
find out why.
The 500-person population of the town, which
had already reduced by the wartime draft into
the currently-raging Great World War, awoke
to red skies on February 6th, 1916.
Citizens left their homes to investigate,
only to find their entire town had been enveloped
in a thick, red mist.
The swelling, crimson clouds up ahead began
to rain, showering the town in a hail of viscous,
red goop.
Anyone unlucky enough to taste it would say
that this strange rain was a dreadful mix
of salt and copper.
This was because, as the Foundation would
later determine, the rain and fog was a disgusting
combination of saltwater, human blood, and
human cerebrospinal fluid.
But the real threat was rising, just beyond
the beach.
Technically speaking, the HMS Wintersheimer
vessel is designated as SCP - 1861 - A. It
appears to be a World War One-era British
B-Class Submarine, designed by Vickers for
the Royal Navy in 1904.
By 1916, this particular type of boat was
already on its way to being obsolete, and
were largely deployed in Malta, far from the
active fronts.
So one of these vessels appearing on an otherwise
unremarkable stretch of English coastline
should have been a clue that something was
terribly wrong - but the poor residents of
Innsmouth-On-Sea didn’t know the half of
it.
Soon, figures in what appeared to be archaic
diving gear began emerging from the Wintersheimer,
and made their way into the township.
They seemed terrified, running up to and frantically
screaming at any local they could find.
“Please listen to me, something terrible
is about to happen here.
We need you to come with us or you’re all
going to die.
You must believe us!”
The locals were frightened by what they heard.
They’d been listening to news reports of
the Great War unfolding across the globe for
two years now.
Had it finally come to them?
They pictured shells raining down from the
sky, decimating their defenseless little town
in a rain of fire.
The Navy must have been brought in to save
them before the German bombardment began.
While some took more convincing than others,
the men in diving suits - known as SCP - 1861
- B - eventually managed to persuade the entire
town to join them, and lead the townspeople
down to the water.
One by one, they were all boarded onto the
submarine.
Hundreds of them.
Many couldn’t believe their eyes as they
watched scores of people disappear in front
of them into the dark bowels of the Wintersheimer.
Where were they all going?
How would they all fit in there?
But it was too late for any of them to back
out now.
The vessel submerged once more, and everyone
was gone.
The entire population of Innsmouth-On-Sea
had disappeared in a rain and fog of blood,
never to be seen again.
The Foundation wiped all records of the town
from existence and delivered appropriate amnestic
treatment to anyone who still mentioned or
remembered Innsmouth-On-Sea.
The fate of those who board the HMS Wintersheimer
is always the same - vanished from the face
of the earth, explained away by the Foundation
as “accidental death by extreme weather
event.”
There have been hundreds of documented sightings
of SCP - 1861, and the anomalous weather event
can occur near any body of water wide enough
to accommodate SCP-1861-A’s comms tower
and topmost platform.
Depth does not seem to be any hindrance to
the submarine appearing and it can even manifest
in water that’s just a few inches deep.
As Shaun and the other unfortunate victims
of the rush hour traffic were being showered
in thick, red droplets from above, a crimson
mist rolled in between the cars.
Shaun had heard of so-called freak weather
events before - like raining frogs and fish
- but this was something different, and it
frightened him.
He could see now that the silhouette rising
from the lake really was an old submarine,
and he watched as a legion of mysterious figures
disembarked from the vessel and began spilling
onto the road.
The men in ancient-looking diving suits walked
among the cars and one of them approached
Shaun’s car.
He began tapping frantically on the window
and Shaun could tell he was yelling something.
Shaun was scared and more, but more than anything
else, he was confused.
Against his better judgement, he rolled down
the window, just a crack, to hear what the
man was saying.
His British accented voice muted by the diving
suit, the man frantically told him “Sir!
Please listen to me!
I’m Lieutenant Samuel Ramsey of the HMS
Wintersheimer.
We're evacuating the area.
Please, you've got to come with me.
You're in danger out here.”
“HMS?”
Shaun thought, “isn’t that what they call
British ships?
What was a British submarine doing in the
middle of a lake in the United States?”
Through his windshield, Shaun could already
see other men in diving suits leading people
from the cars out towards the submarine.
Something had to be going on here.
Something big.
Lieutenant Ramsey was still banging away at
the glass of Shaun’s window, becoming increasingly
agitated.
“Sir, if you won’t comply with my orders,
I’m within my rights to take you by force
- for your own safety.”
Shaun could feel the fear setting in but he
didn’t know what else to do.
He turned off the car and took off his seatbelt.
He was just about to open the door when there
was a tap on the passenger side window of
his car.
It was a soldier in what looked to be advanced
tactical gear.
There were several soldiers directing cars
to drive on the shoulder to get around the
mess of stopped automobiles.
Shaun looked to his left and the man in the
diving suit was gone.
The soldier tapped again and Shaun didn’t
need to be told twice.
He followed his directions and drove around
the traffic jam and out of the mist.
A half mile down the road, Shaun was stopped
by another group of soldiers and given an
amnestic.
He drove away never knowing how close he had
come to vanishing in the bowels of SCP-1861-A.
Shaun was lucky that one of the SCP Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces had taken over the situation,
but they were too late to help those who had
already complied with SCP - 1861 - B’s orders
and boarded the Wintersheimer.
The Task Force made it their business to save
whoever they could, but that wasn’t their
only directive: The Foundation had recorded
a huge number of SCP - 1861 instances since
1916, and now, they were finally going to
figure out what was going on inside.
The Foundation had already discovered that
those taken onto the Wintersheimer don’t
simply disappear - once on board the submarine
they are forced into a diving suit of their
own, which transforms them into new instances
of SCP - 1861 - B. Upon realizing this, Foundation
scientists devised an ingenious plot.
Six months before this latest instance of
1861, the Foundation dispatched two members
of D-Class personnel who were familiar with
one another into the red mist.
One was instructed not to interact with SCP
- 1861 - B, while the other, named Sal, was
ordered to enter the submarine.
His mission was to report back all findings
to Foundation researcher Dr. Klutch during
the next 1861 event.
The D-Class who remained on shore was brought
in once more by the Mobile Task Force during
the September event that Shaun witnessed.
They checked each diving suit-wearing anomaly
until they heard a familiar voice, muffled
by the mask: It was Sal, and he’d been transformed
into an instance of SCP - 1861 - B. The human
D-Class, receiving questions from Dr. Klutch
via a remote broadcast, commenced the interview
of his former friend.
It is from this vital interview that much
of the Foundation’s knowledge of the mysterious
HMS Wintersheimer is drawn.
According to Sal, the interior of the Wintersheimer
- which is a long, narrow, passageway - is
a spatial anomaly that seems to stretch on
forever.
This explains how vast numbers of people,
like the entire population of Innsmouth-On-Sea,
can disappear into the submarine at once.
Sal reported that, about an hour after entering
the vessel, the hatch closed and the interior
began rapidly filling with water as the submarine
descended.Prisoners of the Wintersheimer were
faced with two choices: Suit up… or drown.
Few chose the latter option, and as soon as
the suit was on, the transformation had begun.
As soon as everyone was suited up and the
submarine had fully descended, causing the
1861 weather event to dissipate on earth,
the Wintersheimer had effectively entered
an alternate dimension.
The airlock opened, and the new recruits were
instructed to step outside and take a look
around.
The Wintersheimer veterans informed the new
sailors that everyone on land was likely already
dead by this point.
When Sal first exited the submarine, he commented
on everything around him looking eerily similar
to how it’d looked on land before the mist
descended.
But with one key difference: It seemed as
though everything was underwater.
Well, not quite that: It was almost as though
everything was water.
Like the world had taken on a kind of flowing,
liquid state.
Sal and the others existed in this otherworldly
land of living water for six months, and as
the months passed, things only got stranger.
They found that they neither needed to eat
nor sleep.
According to Sal, all they did was breathe
- and passed the time by exploring and talking
to one another.
Anyone who attempted to take off their suit
would dissolve and diffuse into the same liquid
that surrounded them.
Dr. Klutch asked Sal about the other inhabitants
of this alien realm and this was when things
got truly disturbing.
There were dead humans and animals floating
all over the place - missing their eyes, as
though they’d been scooped out, and missing
their mouths, as though they’d been bitten
out of their face by some kind of huge predator.
Their empty eye sockets bled constantly, and
Sal theorized that this may have something
to do with the anomalous blood mists of SCP
- 1861.
When asked to provide more information on
why all the corpses were mutilated in this
way, Sal said that one of his superiors on
the Wintersheimer told him “the watcher
of eyes and biter of teeth deemed them worthy.”
Whatever this mysterious being was, it seemed
to be a powerful figure within 1861’s water
world, and Sal felt lucky that he had never
had a direct run-in with the creature himself.
For his final request, Dr. Klutch asked Sal
to attempt to remove his suit.
The Foundation had learned in previous instances
of 1861 that the diving suits have anomalous
durability, and it was impossible for anyone
other than the wearer to remove them - hence
why the Foundation could never deal with 1861-B
by using brute force.
Naturally, Klutch was interested in finding
out what was going on underneath.
Sal expressed fear and anxiety at first, wondering
if after all he’d been through whether he
could even be considered human anymore.
Eventually, he was convinced to remove the
suit, and his worst fears were confirmed.
The second Sal removed his helmet, gallons
of seawater poured out and the now empty suit
collapsed to the ground.
Sal’s body was ever found - only some teeth
and a pair of eyes were recovered.
The eyes were later confirmed as belonging
to a young girl, and the teeth were identified
as having come from European red deer.
And so the dark mystery of the HMS Wintersheimer
continues.
Because of the unpredictable nature of its
appearances, and the resulting difficulty
of containing it, the Wintersheimer has earned
a Keter Classification.
The only containment procedure currently employed
by the SCP Foundation is for Mobile Task Forces
to try and intercept the submarine when appearances
are reported, and hopefully prevent or at
least reduce the kidnapping of civilians.
With so many questions left unanswered.
All we can say for certain is that if a red
mist ever descends on you and a stranger in
a diving suit tells you that you’re in grave
danger - he’s absolutely right.
If you have ever taken a trip to Suntop Mountain
in the Mount Baker-Snoqualmie National Forest,
Washington State, then you may have come across
an old wooden structure - The Suntop Fire
Lookout.
Built in the early 1930s, the building was
used by the US Forest Service to keep watch
for any fires in the nearby woodland.
At one point, Suntop Fire Lookout would have
been manned 365 days a year, complete with
a bed for staff who were stationed there on
rotation.
The single story lookout house overlooks the
scenic valleys of the White River and Huckleberry
Creek, but you’re not here for an informative
tourist guide.
You probably don’t care about the frankly
fascinating history of the lookout and how
it was used as part of the Aircraft Warning
Service during World War 2, watching for enemy
planes.
No, you’re here because something much darker
lurks inside the Suntop Fire Lookout.
And even though it appears to be a simple,
one-story-tall wooden structure, it certainly
is not short on space.
SCP-3333 refers to an anomaly that the Foundation
discovered inside the Suntop Fire Lookout
house.
The building’s interior is a single, square
room, measuring fourteen feet by fourteen
feet, with large windows on all four sides.
When standing inside Suntop Fire Lookout,
looking up at the wooden ceiling, one will
immediately notice a trapdoor.
No big deal, right?
A lot of places have a ceiling entrance to
a small crawl space, there is probably nothing
behind the trapdoor, apart from a dusty, old
attic.
There’s a latch that maybe once had a padlock
there, but not anymore.
Opening the trapdoor will reveal a collapsible
ladder.
Should anyone be brave, or indeed foolish
enough, to begin to climb, then they’ll
soon find themselves right back where they
started, inside Suntop Fire Lookout.
Or so it will seem.
The thing about being in a place like the
Mount Baker-Snoqualmie National Forest that
surrounds Suntop Fire Lookout is that woodland
areas are teeming with life.
Not just plants and trees, but birds and other
animals of the forest.
You can never truly be alone in a setting
like that, there is always life everywhere
around you.
So, when you ascend the ladder, and climb
out right back into the Suntop Fire Lookout,
that is the first, most noticeable difference
you will find.
It may take a while at first, but the nagging
absence of something usually so abundant in
a forest will eventually become obvious.
It’s quiet, far too quiet.
No birdsong, or the sound of distant calls
from woodland critters.
Just silence, all around.
Anyone ascending the ladder will find themselves
in a copy of Suntop Fire Lookout’s interior,
one story higher than the ground level of
the small wooden building, with the stairs
leading up to the front door getting taller
each time to reach up to the higher and higher
building.
Now, you know the SCP Foundation and the types
of bizarre, inter dimensional anomalies they’re
used to dealing with.
Perhaps SCP-3333 is a mirror dimension, or
a plane of existence where sound doesn’t
travel.
It certainly seems to be identical to the
Suntop Fire Lookout, save for the lack of
any organic life outside.
Of course, it’s what you’ll find living
inside SCP-3333 that you may want to worry
about.
Climbing higher, up the next ladder and through
the next trapdoor, every time with the same
result.
You appear at another copy of Suntop Fire
Lookout, each one higher up than the last.
What first seemed to be an innocuous, unassuming
wooden building is now an endless ascension
up into the heavens, towards the unknown in
silence, without a shred of plant or animal
life outside.
As you climb, perhaps you start to think how
much higher these copies go.
This might even be the biblical Jacob’s
Ladder, connecting Heaven and Earth.
That would be nice, wouldn’t it?
If you were gradually climbing your way up
to paradise, it might make it worth the trip.
But SCP-3333 is nothing that pleasant.
You wouldn’t be the first to attempt this
long climb.
When the SCP Foundation first discovered SCP-3333,
a research detail set up an onsite base camp
to examine this spatial anomaly.
Their first exploration involved sending a
member of D-class personnel, designated D-4f68a,
up the ladder.
His D-number is a hexadecimal code that, when
translated to text, reads ‘Oh’, so we’ll
call him that for brevity’s sake.
During the first day’s exploration, Oh was
able to climb 184 iterations of SCP-3333,
communicating with head researcher Doctor
Williams below.
On the second day, Oh could see a pair of
figures standing motionless on a nearby ridge,
but the pair could not be seen by Doctor Williams
and the other researchers at the base camp.
Both figures disappeared shortly after Oh
spotted them with the camera he had been issued,
and he felt uneasy, almost certain that he
saw them point at him.
The next day, at the 345th copy of Suntop
Fire Lookout, Oh’s behavior started to noticeably
change.
Previously, he had been anxious about the
long climb, and hadn’t questioned directions
given to him by Doctor Williams.
Now, he seemed to speak more casually, resisting
instructions, asking Williams to climb back
down and even calling her ‘Doc’ instead
of ‘Doctor’.
Oh also reported seeing writing on the walls,
but there was no evidence of this on his camera.
It appeared that something had started to
affect him.
It was when Oh reached level 527 that things
seemed to change more dramatically.
Rather than SCP-3333 continuing upwards, the
copies of Suntop Fire Lookout no longer had
a trapdoor or ladder.
They seemed to be arranged side by side, in
a grid-like pattern.
Stepping out of the main doorway, Oh remarked
on the lack of sunlight, and a walkway that
connected directly to the front door of the
next iteration of SCP-3333.
Oh complained about the lack of natural light,
and again requested to be allowed back down.
Doctor Williams instructed Oh to use the flashlights
he was provided, but they wouldn’t activate
and their spare batteries had vanished.
Oh then noticed a sudden movement, and just
then his microphone and camera feed went dead,
almost as if someone had turned them off.
It appeared that SCP-3333 had something else
lurking up there.
Doctor Williams oversaw the second expedition
into SCP-3333.
This time members of Mobile Task Force Mod-0,
also known by the codename “Characteristic
Eigenspaces”, were sent up the ladder.
Their ascent through the various copies of
Suntop Fire Lookout were not as eventful as
Oh’s, with no signs of mysterious figures,
or anxious feelings that Oh seemed to feel
as he climbed.
When they reached level 527, where the copies
of the lookout stop progressing upwards and
spread out in a pattern instead, their lights
and equipment all seemed to be in working
order.
However, as the MTF team split up, one by
one they encountered some sort of anomaly,
or an effect of SCP-3333 that caused each
of them to vanish into the dark.
Either that, or something took them.
These MTF units reappeared confused, and Mod-5,
the team’s leader, Graham Purcell, issued
an order to retreat and the entire squad went
back down the ladders for several days until
they finally reached the base camp again.
The members of Mod-0 were adamant they did
not wish to climb SCP-3333 again, but Doctor
Williams was beginning to understand more
of the anomaly’s effects.
It appeared to cause abrupt changes to people’s
personalities, along with some sort of phenomenon
that caused things to appear and disappear
the higher one climbed.
Assuming these were the results of a memetic
effect, Doctor Williams dispatched a ‘counter
memetics specialist’ for the next expedition.
This specialist was a blind, deaf, and mute
woman known as Annette or the ‘Nullwalker’,
who communicated via a signaling system embedded
in her hand, but was otherwise immune to any
memetic influences.
Observed by Doctor Williams and Graham Purcell
at base camp, Annette made her way to the
top of SCP-3333, reporting that she was aware
of someone watching her from outside the copies
of Suntop Fire Lookout.
On her body camera, a flicker of motion occurred,
something looking through the windows that
ducked out of frame when the camera passed
in its direction.
At the apex of SCP-3333, Annette kept her
flashlight off, but reported that she could
detect blood, following it to what she assumed
was a body.
Sounds of movement surrounded her, and as
Annette switched on her flashlight, Williams
and Purcell saw that it wasn’t a body in
front of her.
Instead, it was a pile of rotting organs,
decomposing muscles and discarded bones.
And among the pile was a metal dog tag, that
read ‘MTF Mod-5: Graham Purcell’; the
same man who was sitting next to Doctor Williams
at base camp.
Well, the same man on the outside at least.
The explanation for everything going on inside
SCP-3333, all these strange occurrences and
disappearances, finally came in a video sent
from Doctor Williams’ cell phone.
In it, a panicked Williams, covered in blood,
was fleeing from something at the top of the
recursive stack of SCP-3333.
There was no memetic effect at the apex of
the Suntop Fire Lookout copies.
Nothing was causing the people that the Foundation
sent up to act unlike themselves.
They simply weren’t themselves anymore.
According to her frantic video, Doctor Williams
had discovered the truth about what else was
hiding within SCP-3333.
With just the right amount of vagueness and
intrigue, the research team had been drawn
in.
It was as if they’d been lured in by the
lights of an anglerfish, realizing their grim
fate only too late.
The D-class ‘Oh’, the MTF team, even Annette
had been replaced.
An unknown group of entities on the top level
of SCP-3333 had been carefully observing them,
waiting until they would not be seen to slip
in and switch places.
These entities had been creating imagined
anomalous effects, like Oh seeing figures
that weren’t really there, as a way of luring
more bodies further up the stack.
They wanted the Foundation to keep sending
expeditions into SCP-3333, to keep them coming
back.
The mass of organs, musculature, and bones
that Annette had stumbled across, revealing
the ruse, had once belonged to Graham Purcell,
before he was replaced.
You see, the entities residing in SCP-3333
weren’t just copying people.
They weren’t possessing them or mind-controlling
them, or even shape shifting to steal a person’s
likeness.
They were taking skin.
These creatures hollowed out Graham, Oh, Annette
and the MTF team, pulling out their innards
and crawling their way inside, filling these
fleshy puppets and leaving their internal
organs to rot.
These hollowed out people become vessels for
the entities of SCP-3333 to hide in.
The whole thing had been a trap, intentionally
exploiting human weaknesses, intrigue, unanswered
questions.
You know what they say about curiosity, and
these entities used it to bring more potential
vessels to the top of SCP-3333.
They pretended to be the people who they had
replaced, imitating them so the Foundation
would send more personnel to explore the tower,
increasing their supply of skins.
Graham’s dog tag had revealed the deception,
and Doctor Williams had escaped up SCP-3333.
The members of the research team that had
already been replaced were hot on her tail,
determined to catch and hollow her out too,
and by the end of her video, they had succeeded.
A month later though, a team delivering supplies
realized what had happened and the trapdoor
was sealed.
Suntop Fire Lookout was put under permanent
guard, but at least fifty personnel were killed
or replaced by one of the entities.
A new Mobile Task Force, Lamda-1 “Maxwell’s
Demons” was created to hunt down and neutralize
any of the entities that escaped SCP-3333,
but it’s still unknown how many left the
tower and are still out there somewhere, waiting
to use someone’s curiosity about the strange
and unknown against them.
Jay and Michael were a pair of urban exploration
YouTubers looking for their big break.
You might remember their video exploring the
dead mall on the outskirts of your town, or
the supposedly “haunted” 1950s insane
asylum out in the styx, but you certainly
won’t find these videos anywhere online.
After The Incident at SCP - 823, all of their
content was scrubbed away from even the most
comprehensive internet archives.
“Why?” you ask.
Because these unfortunate urban explorers
decided that their big break would be exploring
a certain abandoned theme park.
And it would be one of the last decisions
they ever made.
Michael and Jay had heard rumors about the
theme park.
Its name was lost to time, as was the date
of its opening and closing, and the reason
it was even abandoned in the first place.
Even some of the most hardcore urban explorers
didn’t dare to tread there.
Something about it, a good friend had once
told Jay, just didn’t feel right.
Sometimes, if you dare to venture into the
forest near the theme park at night, you can
still hear music.
The jolly, piping tunes of rides and carnival
stands still beckoning.
As if to say, “We’re still here.
Come and play.”
Of course, none of this frightened Jay and
Michael.
They could already smell the sponsorships
from headlamp and compact camera companies.
No amount of anxiety would stop them from
making their doomed trip to the so-called
“Carnival of Horrors.”
It’s a terrible shame - if they’d listened
to the stories of this place about how unnatural
and evil it could be...They might still be
alive today.
Like all the best urban explorers, they arrived
at the woods near the abandoned theme park
in the dead of night.
They ignored the signs warning them about
everything from structural instability, to
dangerous wild animals, to asbestos.
Nothing would keep them out.
Nothing.
They reached the abandoned theme park not
long after, though it was a mere shell of
its former self.
During the several decades of abandonment,
nature had reclaimed it.
The ferris wheel was covered in overgrown
ivy and the carnival stands were blanketed
with mold.
As the duo swept through the grounds with
their flashlights and cameras, they saw a
faded sign that bore the words “Thriller
Chiller” - next to the rusty skeleton of
what had once been the park’s most popular
roller coaster.
They also took their time to marvel at the
exceptionally creepy-looking Tunnel of Love,
the broken down House of Mirrors, and a huge,
grinning statue of the park’s former mascot,
Happy Hippo.
This theme park was like something out of
a nightmare, which, naturally, made it potential
video gold.
But as the excited duo wandered further into
the park, they couldn’t help but notice
the quiet, tinny carnival music.
Music that seemed to be drawing them closer.
Michael asked Jay if he could hear the strange,
impossible music, and felt a chill creep in
when he answered that he did.
Could all of the stories be true?
They were lost in thought, but their legs
kept moving.
They were getting closer to something now.
They could feel a presence.
And was that music getting louder?
An instant later, though, another sound cut
through the silence - BANG!
BANG!
It echoed out through the still night air.
Birds flew from their perches in the trees.
Jay and Michael both fell to the ground, dead,
their heads taken off by the fifty caliber
rounds of a highly-trained Mobile Task Force
Sniper on the payroll of the SCP Foundation.
Their recording equipment, along with their
bodies, were taken and destroyed.
Any trace of them was scrubbed from the internet.
It may seem a little harsh, but a bullet to
the head is a much kinder fate than what would
have awaited these two if they’d kept walking.
That’s because the Carnival of Horrors is
no dark fairytale.
The rumors are all true, and something really
is waiting in the dark.
That’s why this abandoned theme park is
known to the SCP Foundation as SCP - 823,
a Euclid class anomaly with a violent history.
What’s even more unnerving is that the researchers
studying 823 have repeatedly implored the
O5 Council to increase the park’s classification
to Keter and allocate more resources for containment,
only to be denied.
But after you’ve heard about the horrors
that unfolded there, and the danger it poses,
you’ll probably take the researchers’
side.
The park is divided into two different zones:
The Yellow Zone and the Red Zone.
There are to be at least six members of Foundation
personnel present in the Yellow Zone at all
times to ensure that no civilians wander in.
Our two urban explorers earned themselves
a death sentence not just by wandering into
the Yellow Zone, but passing dangerously close
to the Red Zone.
This is the true epicenter of the park’s
dangerous, anomalous activity.
It’s a place so hazardous that anyone entering,
whether they’re a civilian or a member of
Foundation staff, is to be executed at a distance
by sniper fire without hesitation.
Once upon a time, though nobody knows exactly
when, there was a theme park that seemed no
different to any other.
Eager children and thrill-seeking teens arrived
by the busload, ready to stuff their faces
with cotton candy and corn dogs, and then
reverse the process on a vast array of rollercoasters.
But even then during these good times, there
was something dark lurking behind the cheerful
facade.
Little by little everyone, visitors and employees
alike, started falling victim to strange and
horrific accidents around the park.
Of course, when it comes to theme parks, accidents
come with the territory, but none like this.
Here are just a handful of the horrific and
mysterious deaths that occurred while the
park was open.
So strap in, because just like a roller coaster,
this isn’t for the faint of heart.
A pair of young lovebirds decided they wanted
to enjoy the romance of the Tunnel of Love.
The two sat in a swan-shaped boat as they
were ferried through darkened passageways.
Anyone would assume that they were having
a great time, but at some point, terrible
shrieks of pain and fear began to echo through
the ride.
Attendants, confused and terrified, stopped
the ride and found that the screaming persisted.
Just some stupid teens playing a prank, they
figured, and started the ride again.
But when the swan-shaped boat finally exited
the Tunnel of Love, the park employees were
greeted to a horrifying sight: The two teens,
dead, their bodies somehow fused together
at multiple points.
Another unlucky customer met a gruesome fate
inside the House of Mirrors.
They entered, but while inside, they were
stalked by a mysterious, carnivorous, humanoid
entity known as Subject 79.
The customer was pursued and eventually caught
by Subject 79, and brutally dismembered.
Some parts of the body were fused to the House
of Mirrors’ interior while others - like
the right arm - were never found.
This customer actually survived their ordeal
- and whether that’s a happy ending is up
to you.
But it wasn’t just the customers at the
park who were in danger.
A 23-year-old park employee working a summer
job collapsed while entertaining children
dressed as the park’s cheerful mascot, Happy
Hippo.
It wasn’t uncommon for people to get overheated
and collapse in the heavy suits on hot days,
but one thing was different here: He was screaming,
crying, and trying desperately to remove his
mask.
People rushed to help, but nobody could get
the suit off, and he was declared dead soon
after.
When he was eventually cut out of the suit,
coroners found that the employee had choked
to death.
His mouth, trachea, and lungs were filled
with a fibrous substance later determined
to be identical to the stuffing of his costume.
An intense roller coaster known as the Thriller
Chiller was a magnet for horrific accidents,
which became more violent and intense over
time.
The first accident seemed like a typical theme
park tragedy - A safety harness failed dropping
a rider fifteen feet during an inverted loop.
They landed on the track below, breaking their
neck and skull, causing instant death.
While this was a tragedy, it wasn’t exactly
anomalous.
But the next major accident on the ride was
an entirely different story.
This time, fifteen people met with disaster
while riding the Thriller Chiller roller coaster.
Starting from the front and moving back one
car at a time, each group of riders was decapitated
by blunt force trauma.
A new pair of decapitations appeared to happen
at every turn and loop on the ride.
Forensic scientists still have no idea how
this could have possibly occurred.
Despite all of these disasters, the park was
only finally abandoned after a day known as
“Bloody Sunday”, when the anomalous powers
of the location reached a twenty year peak.
It’s believed that 231 people were killed
during the carnage of that day, and another
seven were horribly maimed.
The SCP Foundation contained the Carnival
of Horrors not long after, but the mysterious
deaths didn’t even end there.
Foundation Mobile Task Force Rho-71, also
known as the Origami Toads, were sent in to
assess containment procedures and discover
the source of all the anomalous deaths.
They were unsuccessful though, and instead
they merely added to the list, in exceptionally
horrifying ways.
One agent was found dead, surrounded by empty
grenades and bullet casings.
It appeared he’d removed the explosive propellant
from all of his ballistics and consumed it,
dying in the process.
Another was found with his jaw broken, having
apparently pulled out and inhaled his own
teeth, and dying of the resulting internal
damage.
The commander got the worst fate of all - so
horrifying, in fact, that we can’t tell
you the full details.
All you need to know is that something was
shoved into his brain that really didn’t
belong there.
The Foundation considered having the entire
park destroyed with a massive airstrike, courtesy
of the Mobile Task Force Nu-7, aka Hammer
Down.
However, the O5 Council denied this request,
on the basis that the park was too close to
populated land, they’d have no plausible
cover story for the bombing, and they don’t
even really know if blowing up the park would
prevent anomalous activity from occurring.
The Carnival of Horrors is here to stay, folks,
the Foundation just hopes to keep it from
getting new visitors.
So then back to why the researchers want this
place upgraded to Keter.
After all, these classifications aren’t
about how dangerous an anomaly is - they’re
about how difficult and complicated they are
to contain.
But here’s the problem - according to researchers,
the Red Zone - where the dangerous, anomalous
activity is at its peak - isn’t bound to
one fixed position.
It’s changed position at least three times
already, and even worse, it appears to be
growing.
Not seeming so Euclid class now, is it?
After all, you might not even need to visit
the Carnival of Horrors to be in grave danger.
If it keeps growing then someday soon, the
Carnival of Horrors may be visiting you…
It’s a perfect day for a wedding.
On a warm spring afternoon, a beautiful bride
and a handsome groom are exchanging the special
rings they had custom designed and made for
each other.
As they take turns placing the rings on each
other's fingers, a man standing at the end
of the wedding party steps out of position.
He approaches the groomsman next to him and
reaches into his jacket, taking out a pair
of pliers that he hands to the groomsman.
The groomsman happily takes the tool and then,
without any hesitation, shoves the pliers
into his mouth and begins removing his teeth
one by one.
When he is finished, he hands the bloody teeth
to the man along with the pliers.
The man then goes to the next groomsman who
repeats the same process.
He continues going down the line until all
of the groomsmen and bridesmaids have removed
their teeth, seemingly without pain or resistance.
The man then approaches the bride and groom.
He hands each of them half of the pile of
teeth, which they gladly accept.
They then begin to eat the teeth without delay,
seemingly not bothered by the intense damage
they’re causing to their own teeth and jaws
by doing so.
The man watches as the groom moves the priest
who was officiating the wedding aside.
As the entire church looks on in joy, the
groom opens his mouth and the deafening sound
of cicadas are heard.
This is only the beginning of what the SCP
Foundation has labeled an SCP-2852 event,
a terrifying and little understood phenomenon
that is better known by the nickname of the
anomalous creature responsible for them…
Cousin Johnny.
The Foundation had been trying to contain
Cousin Johnny for decades - not that it’d
ever done them any good.
Johnny is a Keter-Class anomaly that’s thus
far proven impossible to contain.
This is an entity so dangerous and volatile
that three different Mobile Task Forces are
devoted to detecting and disrupting its activities
- MTF Upsilon-36, aka The Party Crashers.
MTF Upsilon-52, aka Cater Duty.
And MTF Upsilon-99, aka The Altar Boys.
But so far all the Foundation has been able
to really do is swoop in afterwards and do
their best to pick up the pieces of people’s
shattered lives.
Cousin Johnny has so far been observed to
only operate in the North American subcontinent,
and only seems to appear at Anglican or Catholic
baptisms, weddings, and funerals.
However, Foundation operatives charged with
keeping a lid on Cousin Johnny harbor the
hidden fear that he may one day expand his
hunting grounds, and wreak terror worldwide.
If Johnny became multinational or multi denominational,
his violence, insanity, and pure evil may
truly become impossible to minimize, so compatible
communities are constantly monitored for increased
levels of juvenile delinquency, sterility,
domestic violence, and divorce.
After all this, you’re probably wondering:
Who or what actually is Cousin Johnny, and
how does he cause so much horrific tragedy?
At face value, nothing about the appearance
of Cousin Johnny would suggest an anomalous
nature, or even any sort of danger.
He appears to be a middle-aged white male,
often with scruffy hair and a beard.
On a cellular level too, Cousin Johnny appears
all too human, but when you look at his physiology
it’s a whole different story.
Cousin Johnny has no identifiable organs whatsoever
- his body is made out of a fibrous muscular
tissue.
The only exceptions are his teeth and hair,
which are made of a kind of chitin - a key
component of insect exoskeletons, such as
those possessed by cicadas.
Johnny’s eyes are the first clue that something
is off about him.
From a distance they appear perfectly normal,
but up close, they’re glassy and dead.
This is because his eyes aren’t actually
attached to any nerves inside his head.
With no nervous system or vocal chords, Johnny’s
ability to see, move, and talk defy any kind
of logical explanation.
His speech will seem completely normal to
the people under his spell, but to anyone
else, it comes out as complete nonsense, often
described as word salad.
If people in attendance are briefed in advance
about this phenomenon, whatever hypnotic ability
causes them to hear his sounds as intelligible
words won’t work, and they’ll be aware
of how nonsensical it all sounds.
But of course, that doesn’t mean they’re
safe.
Cousin Johnny appears at family gatherings
and religious rituals, and immediately, he’ll
be treated as though he’s always been there.
You know your Cousin Johnny, right?
You go way back.
Or at least, you’re pretty sure you do.
Nothing will appear unnatural about his sudden
presence.
In fact, if you’re one of the victims of
one of his incidents, chances are, you’ll
actually find yourself taking a shine to Cousin
Johnny.
Sure his sense of humor is a little crude
and raunchy, but you can’t help but enjoy
his company.
He’s a fun guy to be around, and after all,
he’s family!
As previously mentioned, he’ll only appear
at three different kinds of events: Baptisms,
Weddings, and Funerals, and only at those
that are affiliated with either the Catholic
or Anglican religions.
The SCP Foundation has classified baptisms
that Cousin Johnny attends as Blue Level Events,
Weddings are known as White Level Events,
and Funerals are Black Level Events - with
each one escalating in severity, violence,
and horror.
First, Baptisms - the Blue Level Events.
In these events, Cousin Johnny will appear
and begin to act as a third godparent, despite
there traditionally only being two.
As the infant is lowered into the holy water,
the entirety of their top layer of skin will
come off, like a molting snake.
Despite looking horrific, this apparently
causes no harm to the child.
The godparents will then eat this discarded
skin, as though it’s the most normal thing
in the world.
After this, the family will leave the church
together, and Cousin Johnny will leave with
them.
He won’t appear at any subsequent celebrations
of the child’s baptism.
If this is where it ended, it’d be extremely
gross - but not exactly a living nightmare.
Of course this is just the beginning of the
terror.
Following Cousin Johnny’s appearance at
the baptism, the child’s risk of dying in
the next six months skyrockets, and if they
survive, they’re at an increased risk of
becoming unstable and violent later on in
life.
Their parents and godparents will both become
unable to conceive any further children, and
are likely to be found dead from drowning
within five years of the event.
Those who were only tangentially involved
in the baptism ritual have a massively increased
chance of failed pregnancies, or - if they
do conceive - they may become a danger to
their offspring.
Children who live through Blue Level Events
and survive past adolescence, will experience
adverse side effects when encountering the
songs of cicadas well into adulthood - from
experiencing physical sickness to going through
dangerous psychotic episodes.
Weddings, or White Level Events, are more
complex and severe.
In this case, Cousin Johnny will insert himself
into the wedding as a groomsman, and the most
horrifying events will begin to take place
after the vows have been exchanged.
Johnny will provide various implements that
allow the bridesmaids and groomsmen to remove
their teeth, which are then given to the bride
and groom to eat - which they do, causing
severe damage to their own teeth in the process.
The groom will then vocalize an unknown cicada
call at an incredible volume, as loud as 140
decibels in some instances, rendering the
bride and everyone else near the altar completely
deaf.
At the wedding reception, where everyone is
continuing to behave as if northing out of
the ordinary is happening, Cousin Johnny will
ruin things further by giving the best man’s
speech.
The speech is more of his typical complete
nonsense, though if you’re there you’ll
never realize this, and think that this is
the best speech you’ve ever heard, with
some in the audience laughing hysterically
while others cry uncontrollably.
Once his speech is done, he’ll present a
gift to the newly married couple…
3.5 kilograms of human hair in various colors,
13 deceased specimens of a certain cicada
known as Linne's cicada, and 23 human teeth
in a cardboard box.
DNA tests on all gifts have been inconclusive
as to their origin.
Much like many celebrity marriages, unions
that occurred during White Level events never
last, and all end up divorced within two years
- often as a result of domestic violence,
and any children born during their brief marriage
will be violent and unstable.
But it’s not just the wedding party that
gets to experience the fun of a visit from
Cousin Johnny.
All married individuals who attended the wedding
will find that they are unable to conceive
children, despite no biological indicators
of infertility.
Any children present at the White Level Event
will show no interest in romance throughout
their life, and often die tragically before
reaching the age of eighteen.
Finally, and most horrifying of all, are funerals
- or Black Level Events.
While Blue and White Level Events can potentially
be disrupted before they are completed, lessening
or preventing the horrific results, there
is as yet no way to stop or prevent a Black
Level Event at any stage.
Any attempts to prevent Cousin Johnny from
entering the church or funeral home will lead
to him simply manifesting inside.
Once in the room where the funeral is taking
place, Cousin Johnny will first take up the
role of eulogizer and begin speaking his standard
nonsense to the attendants.
The person who was emotionally closest to
the departed will then open the casket, if
this was not already an open casket funeral,
and will then produce a large knife.
It’s unknown where the knives come from
as they’re not present before the event
and they disappear after.
The funeral attendees will then use the knife
on their wrists and sometimes throats, draining
their blood into the coffin.
Many lose more than enough blood to result
in death, but none ever die from this, nor
do they seem to feel any pain from their wounds.
As the attendees take turns bleeding into
the coffin, Cousin Johnny continues his eulogy
which eventually evolves into a cicada song,
the kind sung by Linne’s cicada males.
The attendants sing the same song back to
him in a kind of call and response.
Cousin Johnny will then approach the coffin
and vomit in a mixture of blood, wood pulp,
and dead cicadas.
The funeral will then proceed as normal, and
the blood, vomit, and cicada filled casket
is then taken to the cemetery and buried.
Black Level Events will usually end with the
body being interred in the ground, but if
there’s a wake after the funeral, the horrors
of the Black Level Event will continue.
At the wake, Cousin Johnny will climb on top
of a table, lie down, and encourage the other
attendants to devour him, which they do - all
while he continues to talk his nonsense.
Until there is nothing left.
Much like Blue and White Level events, being
in attendance leads to horrific after-effects.
All participants who experience this event
will separate from their family through either
suicide, moving, or divorce.
Every individual present at the event will
also find that they are no longer able to
produce offspring, and couples present may
also fall victim to incidences of domestic
violence, often involving cannibalism, that
usually leave one or both participants dead,
while six out of ten children involved will
attempt to murder one or both of their parents
before they turn eighteen.
These Black Level Events are so horrible for
all involved, that any members of the specialized
Cousin Johnny Mobile Task Forces that happen
to witness such an event are treated with
Class-A amnestics before they are transferred
to another task force or retire, to ensure
that they don’t have to live with the memories
of what they saw.
Prior to that, they are closely monitored
for any strange or anti-social behavior to
make sure they weren’t affected by the event.
And they aren’t the only SCP Foundation
staff at risk of having been impacted by Cousin
Johnny.
It is theorized that as many as a third of
Catholic and Anglican D-Class personnel were
involved in a Black-Level event at some point,
and were driven to madness and violence by
their fateful brushes with the strange relative
that no one knows.
So next time you’re at a baptism, or a wedding,
or a funeral, stay vigilant.
Keep an eye on the other guests.
And always ask yourself: Do you really have
a Cousin Johnny?
It was July of 2004, and Bill Murray was enjoying
the peak of an extremely successful career.
Not only had the iconic actor starred in some
of the most beloved comedies of the 20th Century,
including Ghostbusters and Groundhog Day,
he’d voiced the main character of the recently-released
live action Garfield movie.
It’d been a financial success, but it was
a critical flop.
Not that this bothered Bill – he was happy
with the performance... and the paycheck.
What he wouldn’t be quite as happy about
was the horrifying encounter he was about
to have with SCP – 3166.
On July 8th, Bill was enjoying a cold drink
on the porch of his luxurious Beverly Hills
home.
The sky was beginning to darken as the sun
set in the west.
It was a blissful evening.
His wife, Jennifer, was inside, watching TV.
Nothing seemed particularly out of the ordinary,
until he noticed a quick flash of orange in
the distance.
It was almost too fast to register, this large,
orange shape darting past the corner of his
eye.
For a second, he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escaped tiger, but it
was gone too fast to really tell.
Bill finished his drink and headed inside.
He’d had enough for one night.
The next morning, he got up to read the paper,
and found the Garfield movie getting slaughtered
by the critics.
One review stated “no one can accuse Garfield:
The Movie of infidelity to its source: It
faithfully conveys the banality of Jim Davis's
cartoon” Another called it“a film without
energy and without spirit.”
He put the paper down and ate his breakfast.
A few blows to the ego were worth it for the
paydays that came with big budget family films.
Just then his wife came to him with a strange
question: Were you walking around downstairs
in the middle of the night?
No, he hadn’t, he’d been sleeping like
a baby.
Why did she ask?
“Well…”
Jennifer said.
“I heard some rustling downstairs last night.
It sounded like something big.”
He hadn’t heard anything though and told
her it was probably just her imagination.
He put it out of his mind and continued about
his day.
He decided he would keep his eyes peeled for
that orange blur again though.
Bill didn’t see anything peculiar the rest
of the morning and went to a local café for
lunch.
He ordered a coffee and a cream cheese bagel,
then made a quick trip to the bathroom while
his food was prepared.
When Bill returned to his table though, he
was something strange.
Instead of a bagel, there was a large heaping
of lasagna on the table.
What was going on?
This café didn’t even serve lasagna.
Bill knew something was terribly wrong.
Things only got stranger when Bill came home
to find a small tuft of orange fur snagged
on the frame of his front door.
And it wasn’t synthetic fur like you see
on plush toys or stuffed animals.
No, this was real animal fur.
Maybe someone was just goofing off or trying
to play some weird prank on him, but it didn’t
feel like it.
Deep down, Bill Murray knew that he was in
grave danger.
Whoever, or whatever, was behind this… it
wanted to hurt him.
That night, his worst fears were realized.
Bill’s wife had left town for the week and
he was heading to the kitchen in the middle
of the night for a glass of water, when he
saw something - A huge figure moving up against
the glass door leading to his backyard.
The thing was huge, nearly seven feet tall,
with a bloated, fur-covered, misshapen body
that was pressed up against the door.
Its fur was bright, garish orange – a cartoon
orange.
Strangest of all though was the sound it was
making.
It sounded like it was purring.
Bill backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide.
The whole night, he sat cowering as he heard
scratching against the walls, like something
was trying to get in.
He was terrified and too scared to do anything,
even move.
Finally, as morning broke, the noises seemed
to stop.
Bill had to do something.
He couldn’t let this nightmare go on another
night.
What if things got worse?
What if that thing managed to get inside?
He called the local police and when they arrived,
he explained the incredibly strange situation
as best he could.
He told them he was being stalked by some
kind of huge cat, or at least someone dressed
like a huge cat.
Also there was lasagna involved.
The officers interviewing him could barely
contain their laughter as he told them his
story.
A giant orange cat?
Perhaps, one of them theorized, he’d angered
some kind of obsessive Garfield fan through
his involvement in the live action movie.
After all, the original comic had been running
for years and had been extremely popular.
Who knows what kind of nut jobs were obsessed
with seeing only a faithful adaptation of
the source material?
As the officers departed, Bill was confident
that they weren’t taking him seriously.
He couldn’t rely on any of them for protection.
Thankfully, from a multi-decade movie career,
he had plenty of disposable income, and decided
to hire a private security team to protect
him while he looked into this mystery.
He had two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month.
They were armed, and given the cryptic orders
to fire on anything orange.
Meanwhile, Bill began to fall down a Garfield
rabbit hole.
He felt strangely compelled to research all
the Garfield media he could find, as though
the answer to his terrifying situation was
somehow hidden between the lines.
Bill explored the entire backlog of thousands
of comic strips.
He read the books and interviews with Jim
Davis.
He watched the cartoons and straight-to-DVD
animated movies.
Ironically for a guy who’d recently portrayed
the lasagna-loving orange cat, Bill had never
felt quite so immersed in the character before.
He found a strange pathos in the routine of
Garfield and his friends.One particular comic
really piqued his interest, though.
Originally published in October of 1989, the
comic began with Garfield being woken up by
a strange chill, an almost eerie sensation.
The character observed aloud that he didn’t
feel like he was in his own home.
He explored his little home further, trying
to find his owner Jon or his housemate and
sometimes nemesis, Odie, but found nothing.
As Garfield remarked on feeling alone, a purple
speech box delivered the sinister message:
“You have no idea how alone you are, Garfield.”
He then finds that his home looks like it’s
been abandoned for years.
The “For Sale” sign outside is practically
ancient.
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying revelation:
Everyone really is gone, and his adventures
and friends now exist only in his imagination.
He’s trapped in a prison of his own creation,
trying to stave off his endless loneliness,
in denial about the reality of his situation.
The comic ended with a quote directly from
Jim Davis himself, saying “An imagination
is a powerful tool.
It can tint memories of the past, shade perceptions
of the present, or paint a future so vivid
that it can entice... or terrify, all depending
upon how we conduct ourselves today...”
As he read those words, Bill Murray felt a
chill down his spine.
Why had he wanted to get involved in the Garfield
movie in the first place?
What had he gotten himself into?
Before he could slip any deeper into his own
mind, Bill heard a faint, choked scream downstairs.
He felt his breath catch in his throat.
He was terrified but he needed to see what
was happening.
He carefully and quietly began to creep down
the stairs.
At the bottom, he poked his head around a
corner, and that’s when he saw a member
of his security detail lying dead on the floor.
His face was blue from asphyxiation, his mouth
was stuffed with lasagna.
It looked like he had been force-fed to death.
Bill wanted to scream but he couldn’t, or
maybe knew he shouldn’t.
Just then he heard a soft, meaty thumping
noise coming from the nearby living room.
He didn’t know why, but he felt compelled
to approach as if by forces beyond his control.
He made his way to the living room, and when
he got there, he saw where the noise was coming
from.
Bill’s jaw dropped in pure horror.
There was the other member of his security
detail, lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure.
It was a grotesquely huge creature, wearing
what looked to be a kind of crude Garfield
outfit made of sewn-together cat pelts.
It stank of pasta and rotten meat.
In its giant paw, it held a golden trophy,
which it was using to pound the security guard’s
head into mush while making quiet, cat-like
purring noises.
The creature suddenly stopped and looked up,
locking eyes with Bill.
The fear of death came over him.
He froze, as the giant, freakish Garfield
stepped over Donny’s corpse, and began to
come towards him.
Bill turned and ran, but Garfield was gaining
on him.
Before he could make it to the front door,
the creature knocked him over.
He was laid out on the ground, looking up
at it, as it reached into its own body cavity
and began to pull out handfuls of lasagna.
He was just about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill’s mouth, when suddenly,
a DING was heard and the creature stopped.
It looked up, as if sniffing the air, and
then suddenly turned and lumbered towards
the kitchen.
Bill watched as the Garfield monster entered
the kitchen where, somehow, there was a steaming
hot fresh lasagna sitting in the open oven.
The creature had sensed the presence of external
lasagna, and felt the compulsion to integrate
it into its body, grabbing fistfulls and shoving
it into itself.
Just then, a group of highly trained SCP Foundation
personnel burst into the room and subdued
the creature.
It had been an ambush.
The Foundation had been tipped off to the
presence of the creature by monitoring the
local police department dispatches, and the
report of a seven foot tall comic book cat
terrorizing a Hollywood actor was definitely
worth looking into.
The monster that had almost taken Bill Murray’s
life was SCP – 3166, a deadly pataphysical
being that tends to manifest around people
somehow involved in the Garfield intellectual
property.
It appears whenever the public perception
of Garfield falls out of favor, and because
Bill had starred in the critically-panned
Garfield movie, he was currently at the very
top of SCP – 3166’s hit list.
Thankfully, he managed to survive his terrifying
ordeal, and was administered amnestics by
Foundation personnel so he could return to
his normal life.
This frightening and mysterious creature has
been around since 1989, appearing after the
publication of the haunting Garfield comic
that Bill had read that very night.
It appeared in the office of United Media,
who were the publishers of the Garfield comic
strip at the time, and began wreaking havoc.
Since then, the creature’s manifestation
has been a constant threat whenever Garfield
loses its popularity or audience.
As a result, the Foundation has spent years
as the funding source behind all Garfield
media, and even planting hypnotic memetics
into the comic strips to ensure that there
is always a loyal fanbase.
The fur is indeed real, organic cat fur, albeit
an unnaturally orange color, and instead of
organs, the creature is filled with lasagna.
Worst of all though, is that testing has revealed
that the meat in the lasagna is genetically
identical to the flesh of Garfield’s creator,
Jim Davis.
How did this thing come into existence?
Perhaps it was Jim’s sheer force of imagination
that dragged it into being.
As he himself said, “An imagination is a
powerful tool.”
All in all, it’s lucky that Bill Murray
was able to survive his encounter, and return
to his normal life – well, as normal as
life can be for Bill Murray.
And if you see Bill Murray, don’t bother
asking him about SCP – 3166.
The amnestics were quite effective, and just
as he’s fond of saying himself, no one will
ever believe you.
Cast your mind back to the height of the Cold
War.
The ever-accelerating nuclear arms race brought
us closer than ever before to making the nightmare
of nuclear armageddon a terrifying reality.
The two main parties in this conflict are
the United States and Soviet Union, each amassing
huge amounts of nuclear warheads and jumping
on any available advantage they can over their
enemies.
What you may not know is that, in order to
detect an impending attack from the United
States, the Soviets developed what would become
known to the West as the “Dead Hand.”
But this experimental piece of technology
also has another name: SCP-1984.
It is no secret that the Soviet Union feared
the threat of US nuclear strikes and invasion
just as much as the US feared an attack from
them, so SCP-1984 was created to act as a
deterrence mechanism, specifically against
secure second strikes.
Secure second strikes were both a deterrent
and overwhelming concern during the Cold War,
referring to a country’s ability, after
suffering an initial nuclear attack, to still
retaliate, firing on their enemy and causing
untold damage with their own arsenal of nuclear
weapons.
The Soviet Union knew that any action they
made that could be perceived as an attack
on United States soil would be threatened
with nuclear retaliation, and that if they
fired first, America would return fire and
potentially annihilate them with a second
strike.
SCP-1984 was to be an automated system that
would activate in response to the destruction
of the Soviet’s main command and control
structure.
Given that the Dead Hand was created during
the eighties, you might be forgiven for expecting
a nuclear detection system built at this point
in history to consist of various sensors connected
to a computer network.
But you have also probably already realized
that, if that was the case, then the Foundation
wouldn’t be so interested in it.
In actuality, SCP-1984 is a fully autonomous
entity rather than a network of sensors for
detecting incoming nuclear attacks or a computer
capable of initiating a second strike.
Perhaps what makes the Foundation more interested
in the Dead Hand is that it is both self-aware,
and linked simultaneously to every single
one of Russia’s nuclear launch sites.
Not only this, but SCP-1984 also has direct
access to every single one of the atomic weapons
stockpiled by the Soviet Union during the
Cold War, and is capable of launching Intercontinental
Ballistic Missiles at a moment’s notice.
In short, SCP-1984 could very easily and horrifyingly
quickly, trigger an all-out nuclear war, resulting
in the extinction of all life on Earth.
No wonder the Foundation considers the Dead
Hand such a massive threat.
SCP-1984 itself actually consists of the preserved
remains of a Russian soldier by the name of
Sergeant Marat Chernikov, who was killed during
the Soviet-Afghan War in 1982.
Most of the official documentation of Chernikov’s
existence has been expunged by the Russian
Federation, and he is only referenced in fragmented
documents recovered by the Foundation that
refer to a ”Project December.”
These remains serve as the location of a semi-sentient
consciousness that has been classified as
SCP-1984-01.
When it remains dormant and is not interfered
with, SCP-1984-01 has the ability to receive
and process any signal broadcast to it, and
is able to decipher information contained
in any signal it picks up.
However, when global military tensions start
to climb, especially when those tensions affect
the Russian Federation - or what were once
the satellite states of the former Soviet
Union - the entity begins to manifest itself
in the physical world, and usually in various
strange and differing ways.
SCP-1984-01 has been known to appear in the
real world in forms such as a humanoid outline,
or a bright-red specter, taking the shape
of a child with its legs cut off.
Regardless of which shape it appears in, it
is when the Dead Hand manifests in a more
physical form that the wider scope of its
abilities become clear.
As mentioned previously, it can influence
and even launch nuclear weapons, overriding
their command systems and bypassing launch
sequences.
After appearing fully, SCP-1984-01 will travel
at speeds of up to 140 kilometers an hour,
directly to the nearest military installation
capable of launching Intercontinental Ballistic
Missiles.
Once it reaches its destination, SCP-1984-01
will immediately attempt to override the necessary
systems to initiate a launch.
After firing missiles at their pre-determined
targets, SCP-1984-01 will hastily travel to
another facility housing nuclear ordnance,
repeating the process until it has successfully
launched all of Russia’s atomic weapons.
When engaged, the physical manifestation of
SCP-1984 is highly aggressive, and will lethally
defend itself against anyone that it observes
trying to interfere with it or stop it from
causing a nuclear launch.
The entity has displayed the ability to disrupt
the nervous system, causing excruciating pain
and debilitating damage to human beings.
Its only known weakness, if any, is a susceptibility
to microwave radiation.
Although, exposure to this doesn’t seem
to cause any lasting damage to SCP-1984, instead
only temporarily disorientating its physical
form.
As for the origins of SCP-1984, the Soviet
Union’s official liaison with the SCP Foundation
offered some clarity on this, ironically,
during early 1984.
The liaison, a doctor named Sergei, described
information regarding the Dead Hand as being
of “grave importance to the continued survival
of the human race”.
Seeing as he was referring to an entity that
could single-handedly launch the Soviet Union’s
entire nuclear arsenal, he certainly had a
point.
A top-secret conference was held in Sarajevo
between the Foundation’s O5 Council and
officials from both the USSR and United States,
using the 1984 Winter Olympics as cover, avoiding
too many questions about several nations’
high-ranking state officials being in the
same place at once.
The O5 Council was then given full, in-depth
information about the Dead Hand, something
they had previously assumed was a more conventional
form of nuclear deterrence.
SCP-1984 was far more, and worse, far out
of the control of the Russian government.
It was revealed that the entity had been designed
outside the original specifications given
to those who developed it.
Initially, the Soviets had intended for the
Dead Hand to be solely used as a secure second-strike
response.
If the leaders of the Soviet Union were killed,
SCP-1984 would react in-kind to Russia’s
enemies, launching back all the USSR’s nuclear
missiles in retaliation.
This is most likely where the “Dead Hand”
nickname comes from, hearkening to the idea
of a “dead man’s switch.”
Picture that you had been mortally wounded
by your worst enemy - shot in the stomach
and laying on the ground, rapidly bleeding
out.
You know that there is no chance you will
survive, but you cannot afford to let your
enemy get away.
What they don’t know is that you rigged
the entire building around you both with explosives.
With your dying breath, you activate the detonator,
assuring your own and your enemy’s mutual
destruction.
Kaboom, then curtain for both of you.
The pressing issue, and reason this secret
summit between the USSR, USA and SCP Foundation
was held, was that SCP-1984 was no longer
interested in just waiting for Russia to be
attacked and only reacting after the fact.
Instead, the entity’s physical form was
trying to preemptively strike at the enemies
of the Motherland, attempting to activate
nuclear launches and send atomic weapons to
destroy the United States, France, West Germany,
and the People’s Republic of China.
In other words, the Dead Hand was eager to
get a head start at causing total nuclear
annihilation, not to mention potentially killing
millions and reducing target countries to
little more than irradiated craters awash
with deadly nuclear fallout.
Both the Soviet Union and United States begged
the SCP Foundation to intervene and contain
SCP-1984, and under the direction of the O5
Council, they stepped in to take direct control
of the situation, establishing new containment
procedures in the hopes of keeping SCP-1984
from hitting as many launch buttons as it
could find.
The embalmed remains that seemed to create
the manifestations of the Dead Hand entity
were held securely in an Armed Containment
Complex, near Verkhoyansk, part of the Sakha
Republic within the Russian Federation.
SCP-1984 was placed within a standard humanoid
containment cell, which was itself held within
a Faraday cage - a type of enclosure constructed
with or covered in conductive material, designed
to block electromagnetic fields.
This was done to block any external broadcast
signals from reaching SCP-1984, and thus causing
it to manifest its other form if it learned
of an impending attack on Russia - even a
fictional one, perhaps as part of a television
broadcast.
As part of the Dead Hand’s containment,
all signals broadcast near its cage are to
be monitored, and only broadcasts featuring
doctored information would reach the entity.
Thanks to the work of the SCP Foundation’s
Information Control Team, SCP-1984 is drip-fed
a stream of carefully-fabricated information.
Using on-site equipment and facilities, a
team of military historians, economists, actors,
and Soviet media specialists, the Information
Control Team have created an ongoing narrative
wherein the Cold War never ended.
Through falsified radio and television broadcasts
made to look like era-appropriate news organizations,
they manage to keep SCP-1984 convinced that
the nuclear stalemate between the Soviet Union
and United States is still ongoing.
Unfortunately, sometimes information from
the real world is able to bleed through.
An incident involving SCP-1984 occurred on
August 8th, 1984, and almost brought forth
a full-scale nuclear war.
While preparing for a campaign speech, the
fortieth President of the United States Ronald
Reagan uttered the following joke: “I'm
pleased to tell you today that I've signed
legislation that will outlaw Russia forever,
we begin bombing in five minutes.”
Naturally, thousands of media outlets reported
on this, but signals of those broadcasts,
including recordings of the President’s
remark, made their way to SCP-1984.
Foundation researchers were both unsure of
how these transmissions breached the Faraday
cage surrounding the Dead Hand, and were unable
to prevent what happened next.
Hearing what it could only assume was a genuine
declaration of war, the manifestation of the
SCP-1984-01 entity happened immediately after
Reagan’s words reached its containment cell.
This time, the entity appeared as a semi-transparent
woman, withered and blue, wearing traditional
Pashtun dress.
Armed personnel guarding SCP-1984’s cage
engaged the entity, causing it to retaliate,
lashing out and attacking any that stood in
its way.
One captain and two privates that suffered
the brunt of SCP-1984’s offensive capabilities
began bleeding heavily from their ears, seizing
violently.
Most gruesomely of all, a liquid leaked from
their eyes and nose, believed to have been
cerebrospinal fluid.
While armed personnel attempted to utilize
microwave emitting weaponry to slow the entity
down, the Information Control Team was frantically
trying to record a new falsified broadcast
in the hopes that SCP-1984 would cease its
hostilities and the entity would dissipate
before it was able to travel at high speed
to any nearby Soviet nuclear facilities and
begin bombarding the United States.
Their first attempt to record a new broadcast
that would result in a cessation of SCP-1984’s
slaughter of its guards was interrupted when
a nearby wall collapsed.
Desperate to re-contain the creature, Information
Control Team tried to film the broadcast a
second time, and succeeded, although one of
the actors portraying a newsreader suffered
a stroke and had to be edited out, to convince
the Dead Hand of its supposed authenticity.
What followed was a short news clip, clarifying
that Russia’s Politburo was in on President
Reagan’s joke, including old footage of
the USSR’s General Secretary Konstantin
Chernenko confirming that the Soviet Union’s
nuclear forces were not on high alert.
Miraculously, after fifteen more minutes of
sustained fighting with guards, SCP-1984’s
physical manifestation began to disappear,
gradually dematerializing while it seemed
to attack with far-less intensity.
Eventually, containment was re-established,
at the cost of the deaths of seventeen members
of Foundation staff, both guards and researchers.
A further eight, however, suffered traumatic
brain injuries that left them all permanently
disabled.
The one upside is that this incident remains
the only time SCP-1984 has ever breached its
containment and caused harm to others, and
considering that it could very well have launched
Russia’s nuclear arsenal, the casualties
could easily have been much higher.
So remember, folks, don’t joke about nuclear
weapons, especially if you’re the president.
You never know what anomalies lurking in the
bodies of dead Russian soldiers might be listening,
and if they are, you better hope they have
a sense of humor.
You’ve been walking for days.
Your body aches, you’re dripping with sweat
from the heat of the sun bearing down overhead.
And yet, you’re wrapped up in layers upon
layers of clothing - even your face is covered,
and you’re wearing thick, black goggles
so that not a single centimeter of your body
is exposed.
Your journey has been long and you feel like
you might die from exhaustion, or from overheating
due to these multiple layers of clothes.
But dying is better than being exposed.
You saw it happen when your entire team...changed.
The light can’t be trusted.
Not even for a fraction of a second.
It’s been like this for years.
You’ve learned and survived through painful
experience.
Many of those you used to know cannot say
the same.
You’ve been alone for so long.
You might have given up all hope, if it wasn’t
for the distress signal coming from a nearby
SCP Foundation Containment Facility - Site-46.
Any kind of survivors would be better than
nothing, no matter what kind of sorry shape
they were in.
As long as they were still human.
You find your way to an opening in the side
of a mountain, and slide into the cave, hoping
you weren’t spotted.
The whole world is crawling with those things
now.
You can’t let yourself be seen.
As you trudge down the cave towards the entrance,
you see what looks like a huge, black snail-trail
splattered on the ground, leading into the
facility.
You try to avoid it and press on.
You don’t even need a keycard to enter:
The door has been left ajar.
The facility reeks of those things, but you
can’t see any of them.
You just hope they’ve moved on and left
some human survivors in their wake.
The place looks abandoned.
Every step you take echoes through the empty
halls.
When you find that the elevator’s out, you
take the stairs all the way down to Level
B5…
Keter Containment.
Lucky for you, it seems all the cells are
empty now, the horrors that were kept inside
of them have all long since flown the coop.
You keep following that slimy, black trail
until you find an abandoned office.
There are no people here anymore - just a
broken barricade, some empty medicine bottles,
and a bucket that the people inside the office
had apparently been using as a toilet.
You breathe a sigh of disappointment at finding
no one alive here, but you’re at least relieved
to be out of the sun.
You can finally remove your jacket and head-wrap.
With your uncovered eyes, you notice that
a nearby computer terminal is still powered
up.
You sit down at the desk and turn on the monitor.
Because of the Emergency Procedures put into
place in a K-Class scenario like this, safeguards
no longer apply.
You can access all the information you need
- up to and including finding out what actually
happened.
In the dull glow of a nearby emergency light,
you see a dark shape slumping through the
halls in shadow.
You tense up, then exhale as it slithers off
into an adjoining hall.
You’re safe - for now.
The terminal has finally loaded and authenticated
your access.
You’re staring at the file for S.D.
Locke’s Proposal for SCP-001: When Day Breaks.
It’s the only name you can give the apocalypse
your world is currently experiencing.
This is one of the only anomalies in the entire
history of the SCP Foundation to be given
the Apollyon containment class - meaning containment
is truly impossible.
SCP-001 is the most dangerous enemy that the
Foundation, and planet earth, has ever faced.
It’s always been a principle of the SCP
Foundation to battle in the dark so that the
civilian world can thrive in the light, but
now, the light has become the enemy.
Anyone exposed to any amount of sunlight for
even the briefest period of time is subjected
to the effects of SCP-001 - and those effects
are beyond horrifying.
The SCP Foundation Administrator released
an urgent memo telling Foundation personnel
to make their way to Site-19 at all costs,
because they need all the help they can get.
Those exposed to SCP-001 in the process are
no longer considered human - their new designation
is SCP-001-A. These new entities are to be
avoided at all costs.
But, in case of emergencies, the Administrator
says it is permitted to cut off parts of your
transformed comrades and eat them to avoid
starvation.
No attempt should be made to kill them, since
you won’t succeed, you’ll just put yourself
at risk.
When the sun changed and became SCP-001, it
instantly affected 6.8 billion innocent people.
The second the visible light touched them
- whether it was from the sun itself or even
reflected off the moon - their bodies liquefied,
melting like candle wax into puddles of living,
gelatinous slime.
This effect isn’t isolated to humans, either:
Any biological entity exposed to sunlight
immediately underwent the same irreversible
melting process into SCP-001-A.
And the horror had only just begun.
People transformed into SCP-001-A will retain
shades of their former intelligence and personality.
They may even try to will their new gooey
mass into a shape resembling their original
form.
However, these individuals will lose their
sense of self if they come into contact with
other instances of SCP-001-A. When they come
together, 001-A instances will bond on a molecular
level, wadding up into horrific, giant blobs
with only one purpose: Integrating more matter
into their bodies.
That’s why they have to be avoided at all
costs.
You continue to search the computer terminal
for answers.
Perhaps there was some kind of contingency
plan put in place for this.
Some way to reverse the effects, or at least
escape the nightmare Earth has become.
Instead, you find a series of attachments
linked to the SCP-001 file, detailing what
seems to be the last days of the people who’d
barricaded themselves in the facility.
Most prominent among these were Researcher
Dr. Logan Igotta, her partner, Ari, a security
officer named Commander Anand, and a few others.
Dr. Igotta had locked herself in the office,
where she recorded her final messages to the
world.
In the first audio log, Dr. Igotta and her
companions seemed afraid but hopeful that
there may be some way out of this situation.
Dr. Igotta reported that most of the workers
at the facility were transformed during the
initial event.
Their melted bodies had fused outside the
facility, and now they were trying to bust
their way back in.
The defenses had held so far though, and they
seemed confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape this
awful situation.
You open the second attachment - an incident
report - and realize that things may not have
been as hopeful as Dr. Igotta let on.
She reported hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside again,
begging for them to come out and experience
the sun with them.
They wanted desperately to add to their ever-growing
biomass.
In order to experiment with what exactly would
happen, they sent out one of their few remaining
D-Classes wearing a full protective suit.
He didn’t last long.
The huge creature grabbed him with tentacles
made of reconstituted flesh.
It began ripping off his protective suit as
he screamed for mercy.
It was a monster made of dozens of people
and animals.
He could never overpower it.
The second the sun touched his skin, he melted
away, and was absorbed by the great mass holding
him in place.
Guns were ineffective against these SCP-001-A
super-entities.
Fire would do no good.
It seemed that extremely low temperatures
were the only way to slow the immense blobs
down, and even then, not permanently.
There was one ray of light in the darkness:
The Site Director had a secret tunnel underneath
his office, connected to a tram that could
hopefully take them directly to Site 19 without
risk of SCP-001 exposure.
It was a good plan, and by far the best option
they had available to them.
But the best plans often don’t work in practice.
You open the next attachment on the terminal.
This time, it’s a video feed.
You can actually see Dr. Logan Igotta - and
she looks harrowed by what she’s experienced.
As it turns out, while the others, including
her partner Ari, attempted to exit through
the tunnel something had happened.
Dr. Igotta heard Ari’s voice over her radio.
But there was something wrong with it.
It was too low.
Too guttural.
And filled with gurgles.
SCP-001 had gotten to her.
She was changed.
The monster from above had crawled in through
the ceiling.
It had taken them, all of them, and converted
them into something less than human.
Any hope of escape now seemed gone.
Ari told Dr. Igotta that it would be fine.
That it was such a bright, beautiful, sunny
day outside, and she was wasting it locked
up inside that office.
She tormented Dr. Igotta with their shared
memories of picnics in the park on sunny days
in the past.
The monster with Ari’s voice did everything
it could to try to convince Dr. Igotta to
give up and join them, but she wasn’t ready
to go just yet.
You look away from the screen when you hear
a sound in the corner.
You see a dark puddle of some unknown substance,
and then, some skeletal hands rising out of
it.
The hands are pulling themselves out of the
puddle, followed by a skeletal face covered
in matted hair.
You have to stop yourself from screaming,
until a flash from a nearby security light
makes the figure disappear.
It’s a normal puddle again.
Your mind is playing tricks on you.
You open the next attachment, another video,
and see that Dr. Igotta’s condition has
deteriorated.
She looked pale, frantic, and thin.
She was using a knife to draw her own blood
onto a piece of bloodstained parchment covered
in strange symbols.
Igotta ranted about her theory: What if 001
took the minds and bodies of its victims,
but not their souls?
Through performing some kind of arcane blood
ritual, she hoped to at least rescue and keep
the soul of Ari, even if her mind and body
were lost.
You open the next attachment.
It seems that Igotta’s ritual worked, but
not in the way she hoped.
The twisted soul of Ari, driven mad by SCP-001,
had taken over the file.
It begins corrupting the text of the SCP-001
file into crazy ranting about how futile it
is to fight.
It then cut to an even more frightening video
feed: Dr. Igotta in her sleep, tossing and
turning in a makeshift bed in the corner of
her office.
The camera approaches her, in first person,
and lingers over her sleeping body.
An oily, skeletal hand reaches past the camera,
and runs its fingers through Dr. Igotta’s
hair.
It’s the exact same hand you saw reaching
out of that black puddle earlier.
You must have seen Ari’s lingering spirit.
With a lump in your throat, you open the next
attachment and watch the video.
You see Dr. Igotta, now truly broken.
She’d been haunted by Ari’s demonic spirit
for a long time now, and it has clearly taken
its toll.
She is waving around a handgun while she speaks.
She now believes there is only one way to
escape.
But not like this.
She doesn’t want the gun to draw attention
to her body.
She doesn’t want to become part of that
mass, even if she is dead.
She opens a drawer on the desk she’s recording
at and places the gun inside.
Dr. Igotta then apologizes to her loved ones
who are likely long since dead or assimilated,
and turns off the recording for the last time.
In that moment, you realize that there’s
a single drawer in the desk in front of you.
When you reach forward and open it, you see
that the same handgun Dr. Igotta was holding
is laying inside.
You pick it up and study it, weighing up your
options.
Perhaps there truly is no other way out...
Then, you see an update on the file.
One more attachment had been added while you
were studying the gun.
You feel your heart pounding in your chest
as you reach forward and open the attachment.
The text has been changed entirely.
The file on SCP-001 is now a poem - an ode
to the sun, and to ultimate togetherness.
Then a video file spontaneously opens itself
on the screen: It’s a video of you, shot
from behind.
You see those oily, skeletal hands reaching
for you in the dark, just like they did with
Dr. Igotta.
In that moment, you panic and fire the gun
behind you, hoping to scare off the spirit.
Instead, the sound of the gunshots attracts
something far worse.
The immense blob of screaming, melted flesh
charges towards the office.
You try to barricade the door, but it’s
not enough.
The flesh seeps and bursts through, and grabs
you in its meaty tentacles.
You scream and try to escape, but it won’t
save you.
Nothing will save you.
The flesh carries you upstairs, out through
the empty halls, out into the cave.
You can see the light in the distance as the
blob ferries you towards it.
You won’t be alone for much longer.
In fact, you won’t be alone ever again...
It’s a natural instinct in many species
to protect their young - and sometimes it's
not just their own babies, but any young that
look like them.
Regardless of your personal feelings on human’s
earliest stage, it is a scientific fact that
human babies are designed to emphasize their
own adorable helplessness to make sure that
other, older humans take care of them.
A baby’s cry is an inherently distressing
sound, and when we hear it, some deep, primal
part of us feels the urge to comfort and care
for the child until the sound stops.
But of course, we’re talking about the world
of the SCP Foundation here - where there are
bunnies that can eat anything, teddy bears
that might steal your organs to make duplicates
of themselves, and chocolate fountains filled
with trillions of murderous insects.
Nothing is what it seems here, and even the
most innocent and cute creatures may be hiding
a deadly secret - SCP-734 being no exception.
Today, we’re talking about The Baby.
This anomaly proves that dangerous things
can come in small packages, but where others
only saw misery and death, the SCP Foundation
saw a certain potential…
Our story begins in the maternity ward of
a hospital in the USA, where every medical
professional’s worst nightmare was unfolding:
An unknown but incredibly fast-acting flesh-eating
pathogen seemed to be running rampant across
the hospital’s population.
It began when patients who weren’t even
admitted for dermatological issues started
complaining of severe itches and extreme skin
pain.
Some nurses and doctors in the maternity ward
began to experience similar symptoms, as well
as one of the infants, leading to a massive
quarantine effort.
While the initial symptoms first appeared
to be limited to severe pain and discomfort
on isolated parts of the skin, the condition
of the afflicted soon escalated.
Their skin began to messily flake off as the
cells comprising it lost physical cohesion
and died.
It was a kind of strange, anomalous rot that
seemed to work inwards, first destroying the
integrity of the outer layer of skin and then
causing further disintegration to deeper parts
of the body.
Once the skin had shed off, the pathogen would
turn its attention to what was lying beneath.
Against all odds, the disease affected organs,
muscle tissue, the vascular system, and even
bones.
Nothing was spared.
The victims’ bodies would completely break
down, and they would be dead within a few
hours.
By the time the pathogen had finished ravaging
its victims, what was left didn’t even look
human anymore.
Not only patients but doctors and nurses that
had been walking the wards mere hours before
were now little more than piles of human tissue
sitting in what had previously been their
hospital beds.
Whatever this was, it seemed like the fastest
progressing infection in recorded history.
Hospital staff and administrators were terrified
- this appeared to be an entirely new disease,
with a mysterious form of transmission and,
worst of all, no cure.
They were even more confused when several
black vans pulled up outside the hospital,
and mysterious men in hazmat suits spilled
out and began setting up a quarantine zone
around the entire building.
Whoever these strange people were, they definitely
weren’t the CDC - little did the hospital
personnel know that this was the group you
never want showing up and putting your location
on lockdown - it was the SCP Foundation.
The infected remains of the victims were taken
away for research purposes, and the Foundation
operatives immediately began conducting debriefing
interviews with witnesses.
They soon determined from a mix of eyewitness
accounts and hospital surveillance footage
that everyone infected with the mysterious
pathogen had all been in a particular section
of the maternity ward earlier in the day.
And when the operatives investigated this
area, they found another strange detail.
An infant had no registered mother present
in the hospital.
The Foundation would later learn that this
was likely because the baby’s mother was
the first victim of the deadly disease.
After eliminating all other possible options,
it seemed that the only anomalous element
that could have caused all of this was the
mysterious baby, though just how the mother
even survived carrying the baby to term was
a mystery in and of itself.
The baby was a caucasian male human infant
between seven and eight months of age.
Nothing appeared outwardly anomalous about
the child, but they could confirm that every
single victim of the anomalous pathogen had
come into physical contact with the child
earlier that day.
Everyone who had been at the hospital was
given amnestic treatment, and the Foundation
constructed plausible cover stories for the
deaths that had occurred that day.
Like so many others before it, the child was
secured and spirited away to the nearest applicable
Foundation containment site.
There it was reclassified as SCP-734, and
finally the real testing into what precisely
this infant was capable of could begin.
Physiologically, SCP-734 appeared mostly non-anomalous.
The infant had above-average intelligence
and physical aptitude for a child his age
but otherwise showed no mutations or abnormalities
that would suggest a divergence from typical
human biology.
Despite a vast array of tests performed by
the Foundation into essentially every aspect
of 734’s biology, they couldn’t find anything
that hinted at the origin of the mysterious
pathogen.
But through some trial and extremely costly
error, the Foundation was able to learn more
about how exactly the pathogen worked.
The only vector for transmission seemed to
be direct contact with the baby itself, up
to and including the fluids and residues it
leaves behind.
Those affected cannot transmit the anomalous
“flaking” effect to others, meaning that
the risk of an epidemic is relievingly minimal.
But of course, accidents still happen, as
was discovered when one agent misplaced her
sympathy for the baby and decided to remove
her mask while interacting with him.
Her logic was that her masked face might have
caused the baby some kind of distress, and
as long as she was only coming into contact
with him via her own gloved hands, everything
would be fine.
But some dust particles were floating in the
air at the time, and SCP-734 sneezed in her
face.
The agent began screaming in pain and recoiling
from the baby, but it was already too late.
Her fate was sealed.
She was taken to the infirmary and given sedatives
so that she could hopefully die in as little
pain as possible.
In roughly 72% of cases, amputation of the
affected areas has prevented the entire body
from succumbing to the anomalous effects of
SCP-734, but this isn’t exactly feasible
when the point of contact is the victim’s
head.
Within hours, the agent’s flesh had flaked
off of her face, leaving her looking like
a red, bloody skull.
A few hours after that, she didn’t have
a head at all.
Throughout the disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent, the Foundation took grisly
photographs.
These photographs are shown to anyone preparing
to work on the SCP-734 research project to
teach them a hard lesson on the importance
of adhering to proper safety protocols.
And these protocols about how to deal with
the Baby are incredibly tight, given that
even incidental contact is often a death sentence.
Anyone entering the Baby’s containment chamber
needs to wear contained-atmosphere hazmat
suits.
Anyone who makes physical contact with the
Baby, even when suited up, is immediately
removed from the area and subject to several
hours of quarantine and observation.
Even inanimate objects that have been inside
the containment chamber need to be thoroughly
sterilized before being removed.
Given that even anomalous children like SCP-734
have very delicate needs, a handler is always
standing by in full hazmat gear to take care
of the baby.
These handlers are rotated every hour to maintain
alertness and safety.
These handlers feed and change SCP-734 regularly
and sometimes even provide toys that have
been approved by the O5 Council.
The Foundation has gone to great lengths to
keep SCP-734 alive and comfortable because
they believe that SCP-734 could be an important
asset for them in the future.
Or, more specifically, they see great strategic
value in SCP-734’s blood.
As mentioned earlier, contact with any matter
from SCP-734 triggers its deadly anomalous
effects, including bodily fluids like blood.
But, unlike many toxic pathogens, in this
case there is no risk of the infection getting
out of control since the infected do not become
vectors for transmission.
Because of this, the blood of SCP-734 can
act as a powerful weapon for both terminating
anomalies deemed unviable by the O5 Council
and assassinating dangerous people who belong
to rival groups.
Contact with the blood would completely destroy
the target’s body, with no other anomalous
effects and no evidence of who exactly conducted
the hit.
SCP-734 has been fitted with an arterial catheter
so that the Foundation can collect large quantities
of blood from the anomalous infant every single
week for storage and research.
But it isn’t just the blood that the Foundation
sees potential in.
SCP-734 himself has scored incredibly well
on the Aeslinger Loyalty Index, the test the
Foundation uses to judge the loyalty of potential
applicants to the Foundation cause.
As SCP-734 matures, if these scores remain
consistent, he will likely be trained to become
a Foundation field agent in the future.
An agent capable of killing someone with a
touch would, needless to say, be an asset
to certain covert missions that the Foundation
would probably prefer to keep off the books.
Of course, the SCP Foundation recruiting certain
compliant anomalies to perform missions for
them is far from unprecedented.
The most infamous of these is SCP-076, also
known as Able, a supernatural, eternally-resurrecting
swordsman and perhaps one of the finest warriors
who ever lived.
The Foundation took note of this and channeled
his eternal thirst for battle into working
with his very own Mobile Task Force.
He could assist in missions by taking out
his bloodlust on enemy groups of interest
and dangerous anomalies.
However, this ended up working a little too
well and led to disaster.
Able was so good at his job that he burned
through all his allotted missions at astonishing
speed.
Left with nothing more to do, Able got antsy,
which led to him turning his murderous desires
on his fellow team members and then the Foundation
as a whole.
It was an all-out massacre before his colleagues
were finally able to kill him and return him
to containment.
The failure of this initiative gave the very
idea of letting anomalies work for the Foundation
in the field a bad name.
But since then, things have changed, especially
with the establishment of MTF Alpha-9, aka
Last Hope, a new mobile task force formed
entirely of anomalous individuals and their
handlers.
These consist of somewhat more stable anomalies,
such as Able’s counterpart, SCP-073, also
known as Cain.
Cain cannot be harmed, with any harm befalling
him simply being mirrored back on his attacker,
and his vast array of knowledge makes him
an incredibly useful intelligence asset.
Another of the several members of Last Hope
is Iris, also known as SCP-105.
Much like Cain, Iris not only has anomalous
powers that make her immensely valuable for
missions in the field, she’s also compliant
and capable of listening to reason, unlike
Cain.
Her abilities include being able to actively
surveil and even interact with photos of any
location, especially when taken with her anomalous
camera.
Someday, SCP-734 could count himself among
other anomalous Foundation agents like these,
providing he continues to show promise and
doesn’t develop a dislike of the Foundation
as he ages, since after all, he won’t be
a baby forever.
So if ever you find yourself on the Foundation’s
bad side, you have a good reason to be paranoid.
You’ll have no idea that one day, the man
who’s going to kill you will approach and
shake your hand with a smile.
It won’t be until later when you feel that
strange tingle on your palm and feel the skin
starting to flake away that you’ll realize
you’ve been a dead man walking for hours.